good morning everybody good morning
it is
904 a.m on friday
on february 26 of 2021.
as the chair of the
criminal justice
public safety committee i find that due
to the state of emergency declared
by the governor as a result of the
colbig 1910 demo
in accordance with the government's
emergency order
number 12 pursuant to executive order
2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronics
this is a public hearing with potential
for executive sessions to be held
throughout
also
again this is a public hearing with
potential for executive sessions to be
held throughout
please note that there is no physical
location for the members of the public
to observe and listen contemporaneously
to this meeting
however in accordance with emergency
order
i am confirming that all members of the
committee
and select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoo
electronic platform
and the public has access
contemporaneously
listen and if necessary participate in
this meeting by zoom platform or by
teleport
through the electronic calendar on the
general website
the notice of this meeting complies with
house rules and rsa 91-day
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting
or email
hcs
leg.state.nh.u.s in the event the public
is unable to access the meeting the
meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting assisting us brad grieble
who's our committee researcher
please note that all votes that are
gary
oh
yes
please note that all quotes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance hopefully gary makes it
back in the room by the time we do that
when each member states their presence
please state
whether there's anyone in the room with
you during this meeting which is
representative greene i am here with
representative wallace president
representative
here
[Applause]
clerk is present
here
i'm here and i'm in my office alone
representative newman
i'm here my wife is in the house
representative conley
representative klein knight
just give a minute for her i still see
her
she appeared very greatly then this
year's songs but we'll keep going back
okay representative bradley
hi
the chair is present
now i'll just state this in case i
forget my understanding is that
representative bolden and representative
colony will be
dead
obligations this morning will be joining
us also representative welch the vice
chair
was here a few minutes ago so he will be
joining this one and wait
answer it
representative ordinance he didn't
okay
i just represented knight just appeared
bro
representative playing night are you
here
yes
oh it's here we go
[Music]
this time
the criminal justice public safety
committee will now hold the public
hearing on house bill
436 votes live rules identification
procedures
[Music]
oh
this bill is sponsored by two members of
our committee
as well as
another representative who will be doing
pushing that online
oh
come and find out representative cushing
chairman i do not
representative jaffray representative
would you like to do the honors yeah
i see our friend representative paul
disarrozon
[Music]
this time
the chair recognizes
representative welch she introduced the
house bill
yes
and this is an addition to it hospital
calls for eyewitness identification
procedures
the village remedies for non-compliance
the eyewitness identifications are
serious
and slightly
[Music]
and
that's
that's all my knowledge in the field
you know like everyone else that signed
the new
section on line nine
base a new section
remedies
and representative also remembers this
people uh represents from the innocence
projects to
um absolutely yeah they all know explain
seeing no hands raised i want to thank
representative welch
first testimony
and uh just some remembers of the public
if you are present and intend on
testifying please raise your hand now
um
your digital hand
and as a matter of practice we're going
to limit testimony to two minutes for
witness
uh however the witnesses will be uh
permitted to answer questions by members
of the committee members of the
committee you will be limited to two
questions program this
mr chairman of miss powers is uncluded
great good morning may i begin
yes
thank you thank you all for the
opportunity to testify today and for
considering this important reform my
name is beth powers i am the state
campaign's director for the innocence
project a national organization
dedicated to exonerating wrongfully
convicted people through post-conviction
dna testing and reforming the criminal
justice system to prevent future
injustice
in 2018 the new hampshire general court
passed a law requiring law enforcement
agencies to adopt a written policy on
eyewitness identification procedures
that conforms to the model policy issued
by the attorney general the innocence
project has attempted for years to
ensure uniformity of eyewitness
identification best practices across new
hampshire's law enforcement agencies
we're grateful for the collaboration and
support that led to a model policy from
the attorney general's office and the
completion of multiple trainings by law
enforcement officers however all of this
work in the absence of confirmation that
all departments across the state have
indeed adopted the model policy leave
citizens unnecessarily at risk of
wrongful conviction
hb 436 is needed to finally ensure every
citizen regardless of county can know
that law enforcement are conducting
proper i went eyewitness identifications
nationally there have been 375 dna
exonerations of which 69
involved eyewitness misidentification
many states include remedies in their
statutes that dictate consequences for
not following established policy
such as instruction to the jury that
they may consider the lack of compliance
with the policy in determining the
credibility of an identification or
instruction allowing a court to consider
non-compliance with the policy in
considering suppression of an
identification
a remedy was not included in new
hampshire's law initially because
stakeholders agreed that law enforcement
agencies would adopt and follow policies
that comport with the core principles of
the model policy issued by the attorney
general's office however uniform
adoption of these policies has not
happened in years have passed leaving
new hampshire rates unnecessarily at
risk details of efforts to conform adopt
confirm adoption of the policy can be
found in my written comments along with
further details on the national
landscape of eyewitness identification
reform we urge you to pass hb 436 which
will assure uniform justice across the
representative testament
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh
i notice in here we have a change that
talks about the enforcement manual
pertaining to partial identification
as a
current as of january 1st 2019
i'm always concerned about putting
a manual state because they always get
updated
is this a good idea to put
of the manual
or
what happens
sure thank you for that question i
understand your concern and the reason
that i think it's a good idea to put the
date is because that current version
which actually is an update from when
when the law passed to your point
exactly that the the manual was updated
the eyewitness identification procedures
that are outlined in the
dated manual in this law
conform to what is
widely accepted to be the best practices
for eyewitness identification reform so
right now there's what's called the core
four reforms which are reforms that we
know if these simple reforms are
completed
um help to ensure that misidentification
doesn't happen
and so right now the date that you see
in that law that particular policy
we know that the core for and what is
the sound accepted science is reflected
in that policy so that's why i think it
does make sense to include that date now
if for some reason we needed to update
it in the future i think that's a
conversation that could happen but right
now if they were continuing to follow
that policy and that date we would be in
in really great shape
representative harper thank you mr chair
substantively it seems like the only
real change is uh
um
changing the words from they
to such lineups
they seem to quite clearly refer to
lineups i don't understand
what has transpired
since this bill was enacted or an event
that happened
that
you that we find this necessary to vote
on this today or to
consider this today
sure so i'm not
i'm sorry would you like me to answer
that
yeah okay
so i'm not sure uh the version
what you're looking at but there is an
inclusion of a new section that allows
for remedies
if the policies are not enacted so i do
believe there's further to the change of
representative true
thank you mr chair and i thank the
witness for taking my question
under the remedies
uh number two
the court may consider the failure to
comply
as
of this chapter as grounds for
suppression
can't the court right now
consider that as grounds for suppression
you know i'm i'm going to leave that
question for uh another witness coming
up professor sure who is uh has
practiced under this i don't want to
speak to that i know that that is not
explicitly stated in the law right now
so i know that that is not currently
a stated option but i'm gonna defer to
him on you know what the court is
allowed to do in their discretion what i
would say is this makes it explicitly
clear that a jury instruction is to
happen and that this can be grounds for
suppression but i'd prefer to to defer
to him as someone who practices in the
state if that's all right with you
representative muse you recognized for a
question
thanks for taking my question
um can you refresh us um
as to
why the remedies that are present in
this bill weren't included in the
original legislation i wasn't here in
2018 and i'm just curious what the
background is on that oh of course thank
you so much i wasn't here either but my
organization was
and my colleagues were and i'm up to
speed on it and actually some of the
folks you'll hear from later were here
and some of you were here because this
committee uh supported uh supported this
bill
so
this is an effort that we actually
started almost seven years ago
um trying to ensure that eyewitness
identification procedures were uniform
across the state and just a reminder on
the importance of that i know i said
this in my comments but of our dna
exoneration so people that we're able to
exonerate with dna we're able to see
other contributing factors when we have
an exoneration and 69 of those had a
misidentification that's really huge the
fact that people who were exonerated
through dna later were shown to also
have been misidentified
really is very telling and shows us that
this is something that we need to be
ensuring best practice so we're
preventing this from ever happening so
what we did was we began working with
the attorney general's office and
working with stakeholders in new
hampshire to say what do we need to do
to get a model policy in place and to
their credit the attorney general
issued a model policy in 2015 and it
really captures what we call i already
said this the core four it captures
these best practices and my
understanding is that the understanding
of of us and of uh the attorney
general's office and of the stakeholders
who were involved at the time
was that uh including the new hampshire
police chiefs association who deserve a
lot of credit and have done a lot of
training on the policy is that a more
prescriptive bill laying out
the remedies would be filed later if we
weren't able to ensure everyone adopted
it but we had sort of the word of
everyone involved that this will be done
everyone will adopt this everyone will
be using these best practices and that's
what's important to us what's important
is that this is these best practices are
followed everywhere in the state um and
that is what has not happened and we've
really
tried to run this information down to
find out where is this happening ask the
attorney general please confirm that
everyone has adopted this policy and
that is what we have not been able to do
over the past few years and i detail
that more in the written comments um but
that's that's why we're here today
because we have not been able to confirm
that everyone is using this best
practice that really does prevent
wrongful conviction
follow it please please
represent muse
yes so
so as i understand it the remedies that
are laid out in this bill
really won't have any impact on the vast
majority of uh police departments that
are following the policy now oh that's
exactly right for the departments who
are already following the policy they're
already following the policy so that's
that's exactly right and what we're
concerned with is ensuring that that
everyone is so that if someone in one
county happens to be arrested there's
much less risk of them being exposed to
a you know outdated practice that puts
them at risk of wrongful conviction we
want to sure ensure everyone is
following this policy
you know hands raised
i want to thank the witness for a
testimony
thank you
and he says a reminder tesla testimony
will be two minutes
thank you sir can you hear me
thank you sir good morning
representative abyss and members of the
committee my name is james testaverdi
i'm currently the deputy chief of police
for the national new hampshire police
department and i've served the national
police department for over 22 years i'm
here to testify in opposition to house
bill 436 on behalf of my agency and the
new hampshire association of chiefs of
police i submitted written testimony
last evening so i'm not going to
read that verbatim to you i'm just going
to speak to you on a couple of the
points
that the
young lady of the innocence project
spoke to first of all i would like to
say i agree uh with
representative testerman in his question
regarding placing the date inside the
statute i personally believe it's a
mistake for one there was not an
attorney general's law enforcement
manual written in january of 2019 the
newest manual came out in november of
2020 prior to that it was 2008 prior to
that 1993 prior to that 1984 i can go on
but you see they're spaced out by
decades
and i testified in front of i believe it
was this committee i'm not saying
members in roughly 2018 when the bill
was first proposed and our agency was
100 behind it so i i just want to give
you a perspective
in april of 2015 the attorney general
sent out a memorandum saying this is the
newest best practice for eyewitness
identification
within months
we immediately we began to transition
and within months the entire agency uh
had transitioned to the newest best
practice that was 2015.
three years later i was testifying to
say
codifying a procedure a best practice
procedure handcuffs us pardon the pun
because
when the newest best practice comes out
we have to come before you again to
amend the legislation so i believe the
statute that you did pass in 2019 um and
it
that attorney general's memorandum in
didn't make the manual until 2020 it
took five years but as soon as the
memorandum hit coming from the attorney
general the chief law enforcement
officer in the state we immediately
transition uh secondly i know you'll
probably hear i'm assuming you'll hear
from many attorneys i'm not an attorney
but i've been doing this for two decades
and i've spoken to many attorneys this
bill is looking to place remedies
in case um these measures not followed
ladies and gentlemen the committee in my
humble opinion that i have attorneys
agreeing with me
this occurs every day in every court
across the nation eyewitness
identification is a piece of evidence
along with physical evidence dna
evidence witness victim suspect
statements i can go on and on if they're
not obtained properly the judge can
place different amounts of weight or
make them inadmissible the judge also at
trial turns to the jury and
explains to them how much weight that
they can or can't give a piece of
evidence i've witnessed i've been taught
this and i've witnessed it
dozens if not hundreds of times so i
personally believe the law we have is
good i'm behind the innocence project
where far as far as this is the best
practice we're adhering to it and have
been since 2015 and i don't think we
need more laws in this uh scheme i think
we need more education training and
funding for law enforcement so that we
can have positive and ethical outcomes i
will entertain any questions thank you
thank you miss mr justified uh the chair
would ask a question and i want to thank
can questions
can you explain how many of the police
departments have adopted or
or are currently following the best
practices
thank you representative marston thank
you mr chairman and thank you for taking
my question
so as i understand that
what you are saying
is that this this piece of legislation
is not needed because it's redundant we
already have it on the books
precisely sir
thank you sir
anybody this may ask a follow-up
question
from the chair and
thank you again for taking my follow-up
questions
so
i guess my question would be how how
would we
how would the departments be required to
actually adopt the best practices if
it's not within the law
mr chair that's an excellent question
and my answer is this
if you step away from what we're talking
about today with eyewitness and and pick
any other pick dna evidence pick a
statement because they've been
conducting interviews for hundreds of
years if we do not adhere to the law the
best practice nashua's accredited 459
best practice standards over 200
standard operating procedures
555 page roughly attorney general's
manual on and on and on if i obtain any
piece of evidence that's contrary to any
of those documents in my training a
judge can
if he or she deems it appropriate put
less weight on the evidence or make them
non-admissible in and of themselves
i hope that answered your question
thank you
representative
thank you mr chairman and uh thank you
if i'm reading the bill correctly
there's really only one well other than
the date change
on line four if you have the bill in
front of you that says that they want to
remove
today
to such lineups
i guess i i'm confused do you know what
that means you know what would be the
difference from they to such lineups and
um
having not crafted it my opinion when i
read it is that they wanted to be more
specific
and they might have been too vague for
the drafters liking um i don't think
that line
the way i read it would affect us as i
said and i agree with you sir the date i
believe could be problematic because it
wouldn't allow us to fluently transition
to the best practice and i think that
the remedies are redundant
thank you chairman
um thank you
officer for taking my question
um
and thank you for your service to our
state i just want to know because
another representative asked you if you
know if this was being followed best
practices on in the other police
departments
is and you and i i heard that you didn't
know
now with that data being missing how can
we
make it our responsibility and hold the
state accountable to best practices
everywhere
representative i understand your
question and that's why my example
before was
the attorney general said a memorandum
if an agency reads the memorandum and
says we don't agree we don't think
that's best practice we are not going to
use it
any defense lawyer any prosecutor seeing
that we are that that agency or that
officer was not using the best practice
will come up in court which is how the
system is set up that would in my
opinion be evidence because an
eyewitness identification as evidence
obtained
um
i don't want to say illegally but at the
very very least inappropriately
contrary to best practice contrary to
the opinion of the attorney general and
having seen how it works firsthand i
would be shocked if a judge said yeah
that's no big deal we're going to allow
it in because i've sat through these
procedures where if we don't if we're
supposed to do a b and c to
recover a knife used in an assault and i
skip over point b that knife might not
make it in
and that's a huge
that this is such a huge risk to ignore
the attorney general when they come out
with a memorandum and that's why i gave
the example
the memorandum came out in april it hit
my desk in may
we immediately transitioned the
detective bureau i have our standard
operating procedure in front of me i
actually testified before the committee
and brought all these documents emails i
sent out department wide i'm just not
able to say which agencies automatically
adhered but if they
i don't know how their evidence and
their identifications are ever going to
see the light of day in court
follow-up chair
representative knight you're recognized
for a follow-up question
thank you
um are these best practices defined in
our law or are they
like you're saying they're made up
per department when you get the standard
operating procedure that you just
told us about
is that law
it's not
to my understanding it's not law the law
well i'm gonna backtrack on that the law
says we have to follow the attorney
general's protocol the attorney
general's protocol spells out step by
step what the procedure is
if you deviate from that you're not
following the ag's procedure
therefore
in court that could be shown that it was
not that's not a proper piece of
evidence it wasn't obtained
uh properly if i answered your question
sorry uh third follow-up if i may
represent tonight
we do have to limit members to
two questions each uh per week
he's not
mr chairman
thank you mr chair and thank you for the
witness for taking the question
um is is your concern about the way that
this
law is
this bill is currently written
a function of the date
or is it a function of the inclusion of
the set the new section about remedies
that's my question
so the date i believe is problematic for
the reasons i stated before as far as um
impeding future best practices that come
out uh if
if if we had it codified back in 2015
i'm sorry
if we waited for the law in 2015 when
the manual when the uh
memo came out we would have waited three
years to transition to the standard
instead of doing it immediately my
problem with the remedies is
they occur and i guess i would say if we
put these remedies in this bill
then i would
sit here and say please go through every
criminal rsa and add the same remedies
when it comes to any type of evidence
it's already happening but i don't know
why you would do it for this bill and
not aggravated felonious sexual assault
yes thank you um
would would your concern um be um
not as great if the date if the way the
date was worded was maybe the current
version
and if the remedies were removed from
yes sir if the date was removed and the
law said we are to adhere to the
attorney general's
current best practice
um
i personally believe somewhere in there
there should be a grace period and i
would even be fined if a date was
determined um because we have an agency
of 180 manchester state police large
agencies can't do it overnight but i'd
be fine with a a
a reasonable uh grace period and yes if
the remedies weren't there i
i read the current law i really have no
issue with it other than it doesn't
mention anything about a grace period
and there is a mention to the actual
manual which changes every decade
thank you for that answer thank you
representative calling
thank you mr chairman um
thank you
um sir for taking a question
uh the current bill does have uh
something of a break period and that
would take effect 60 days after passage
that's sufficient time you think for a
race carrier or time needed
uh
based on your answer to the previous
question
so based on the answer and please
correct me if i'm wrong i thought the 60
days from the passage was the date the
law took effect
uh when i say grace period what i'm
referring to is not
the law what i'm saying is
if
if a new best practice comes out two
years from now and there was a grace
period for all because i believed some
best of my knowledge is over 300
agencies in the state um knowing that
nashua
cannot adhere to a new best practice
within a 24 hour span if it said
when the attorney general comes out with
a new best practice law enforcement will
follow it they will have x amount of
time um to adhere to it i think that
would be fair and i'm saying that to
show it's not that we're against the
innocence project when i testified three
years ago i said everything they said is
accurate i'm just afraid of codifying a
procedure uh we're on board with the
thank you
thank you for your testimony
representative i see your hands raised
but we are going to limit questions uh
by members to two questions per
per witness
i have a question representative jeffrey
is
what i'm asking
sure
yeah no shares there yeah sharers here
we're gonna start with uh
can everybody hear me now
yes please um
uh my name is albert sher i'm a
professor at unh law
i've been in the criminal justice system
here in new hampshire
uh in various capacities for the last
almost 40 years
uh relevant to this particular bill i
teach a course uh about police
investigation and the constitution of
foundational course called criminal
procedure which included in that course
is uh
constitutionality of eyewitness
identification procedures i've submitted
uh my opinions are mine only not those
of unh school of law nor of unh proper
i've submitted written testimony so
rather than go through the written
testimony
let me try and
capture some of the answers to questions
that have been raised and comments that
have been made
the innocence project has been trying to
implement this help implement this
reform and collaborate with the attorney
general's office for seven years
um
four years ago
i helped write a survey that was sent
out to every single law enforcement
agency in new hampshire in anticipation
of the original bill
and eight
eight
law enforcement agencies responded as to
what their practices were
um
um we then drafted a bill uh the bill
that uh and we included originally we
included remedies in it and then we
negotiated we had a meeting at the
attorney general's office which i
intended attended with the attorney
general's office with three members of
the police chiefs association
and they said not to worry everybody's
going to comply with this we do not need
remedies period
and that's why remedies were left out
four years later the attorney general's
office
surveys
collects the information from all the
police departments it seeks to collect
information from every single law
enforcement agency
in new hampshire about whether they're
following this policy as the statute
requires only 45 percent of the law
enforcement agencies responded to that
survey so we do know that
55 percent of law enforcement agencies
that are not responding to whether
they're following the policy or not
included in those who
did not respond to the uh
to the uh request of the attorney
general's office is
some that are following it like nashua
nashua did not respond
um
so the measures the remedies that are
implemented here are are are mild
they don't require that if you don't
follow the policy it be suppressed or
the jury must ignore it it just says
they can consider it
cur under current law it's up to a judge
to decide whether the
eyewitness identification procedure has
been suggestive number one
whether it's been unnecessarily
suggestive number two and whether the um
the identification even if it was
suggestive and unnecessarily so is
otherwise reliable that's that's what a
judge needs to consider
this adds to that that the judge may
also consider whether they complied with
the attorney general's best practices
that's all this does and it allows the
jury to also consider it it's a mild
remedy for
failure to comply i know of no judge
who's ever suppressed an eyewitness
identification because they didn't
comply
with the some policy they look at the
identification itself and see see
whether it's suggestive and
unnecessarily so so we need these
remedies to get police departments in
new hampshire to tell us what they're
doing and whether they're complying it's
really simple it's really
straightforward it's closer to
housekeeping than anything else
uh lastly
i hearken back to when this original
bill was before this committee those of
you who are on it i'm sure remember the
testimony of jennifer thompson
jennifer thompson woke up one night in
north carolina being raped
she was scared for her life she did not
expect to live
um and she promised herself if i lived
i'm gonna remember everything i can
about what this guy looks like
so he can be found
and prosecuted
she lived
she described the person to the police
she picked
a man named ronald cotton out of a
lineup and she identified him at trial
he was convicted and sentenced to prison
several years later post-conviction dna
testing found that he could not have
been the person who sexually assaulted
her
that's why
compliance with best practices
is so important those of you who were on
this committee back then i'm sure
remember her testimony which was
overwhelming and very powerful
and so uh i
real strongly encourage the police the
police to follow these practices but i
strongly encourage
this uh committee uh to vote ought to
pass on this
i'm more than willing to entertain
questions
mr you were the beneficiary of a
negligence of the chair to keep track of
the time but uh
i keep trying i i'm afflicted by being a
law professor if i had to guess that was
uh representative bolden you recognize
for a question
thank you mr chairman i was a little
late today so i'm catching up but
um i wanted to
ask if
um this uh the the witness is telling us
that
the consequence of
current practices could be
that
a
victim
does not successfully identify
their assailant and the victim does not
get justice is that what you're telling
us that
if we
and so conversely if we
successfully change
the
uh
the guidelines that we would have more
justice
is is that what you're telling us
yes i think by adopting this it is it
makes it more likely
that those police departments who are
not following the practices the best
practices of the attorney general's
office
um will follow them and there will be
more justice both
where the right person will be
prosecuted and for those who may be
thank you see seeing new enhancers i
want to thank the witness for his
testimony
yes so i'm cynthia musso i'm from the
new england innocence project and uh
formerly of the public defender's office
in manchester
and i just wanted to uh sort of
reiterate a couple of points that buzz
made and you know he sort of made them
but i did want to sort of weigh in and
reiterate that the reality is and one of
the things i think that we get tripped
up on is that there seems to be this
sort of idea that this is kind of a
punishment to the police when reality
this is a protection afforded to
innocent folks that are facing you know
wrongful convictions you know in our
system and it's also a an affording of
protection to the victims of these
crimes there's a crime in massachusetts
that we that we represented uh the uh
defendant in where he was identified by
five separate people
in three separate sexual assaults and
the practical reality is dna
post-conviction testing revealed that he
was not the perpetrator of those
assaults
unfortunately this was so long after the
fact that there had these victims who uh
their their assailants were never found
these were brutal uh stranger assaults
in in massachusetts were really left
without justice as was our client who
was sent to prison lost his entire
military career uh and lost all of his
hopes and dreams on on the basis of
these witness identifications
in cases where uh the procedures that
are proposed to be put in place were not
put in place
uh it certainly would not have been a
punishment uh to anybody uh had the
procedures kept out these eyewitness
identifications because the correct
person could have been found earlier and
the wrong person would have been able to
go home and i think i don't want that
that point to be lost when we're
thinking about the importance of this
bill
representative muse
thank you um and thank you for taking my
question
um
can you tell me how the remedies uh that
are in the bill
would actually reduce the odds of the
situation that you described happening
so
a person is is falsely accused by five
different people uh later can you know
and the conviction is later uh
overturned by dna evidence
how do these remedies lower the risk
of that actually happening to an
innocent person yes that's a great
question i think that the important
thing to recognize is that uh
what we would rather be doing is
correcting these things before people
are sent to prison rather than after
right and so any protections that we can
put in place that are going to ensure
that unreliable evidence isn't put
before a jury is critical in making sure
that that pre-conviction process is
followed in this particular case for
example if the procedures had not been
followed and the judge as the gatekeeper
of that evidence had prevented that
evidence from going to the jury there
would have been no evidence against our
client to convict him in the first place
because there was no forensic evidence
that led to his conviction uh other than
these this eyewitness testimony so the
practical reality was there would have
been no evidence in that case and our
client would not have gone to prison in
the first place often our
post-conviction uh statistics and the
things that we learn in these
post-conviction cases highlight the
deficits of the criminal legal system
that happen pre-conviction and that
that's certainly the case with this type
of uh evidence
thank you
representative newman
thank you mr chair
um my question is do you
is it your opinion that the that if we
leave the remedies in this bill that
will be more effective in what you are
trying to what the innocence project is
trying to accomplish
absolutely i can speak to this both as a
public defender and as as a
representative the new england innocence
project the practical reality is is that
these bills can go into place but
without any remedy
the bills become somewhat meaningless in
other words if the court doesn't have a
way to act on the bill the bill just
becomes something that is kind of
ethereal uh
i as a public defender was not even
aware that this bill had been placed
when it was originally put in place but
this remedy will definitely make it
accessible to criminal defense attorneys
in a way that they can use this in
defense of their clients when there is
uh you know faulty eyewitness
identifications
follow mr chairman
recognize for a
follow-up thank you um
is it also your opinion that um
the fact that some
police departments do not uh comply with
the law in a timely manner is a
different issue and that this bill
as as it is right now it does not
address that issue and that is not a
the fact that police i'm a little
confused about your question but i i'm
gonna say is the question that uh
that uh the timeliness is whether the
timeliness is material or not
yeah i i
i believe that you're saying that the
that these remedies have to be in there
and i believe my opinion is that the
professor um
shear said that there was a problem
because people didn't respond and people
are not complying but that's a
completely different issue that we may
address some other way
other than amending this bill to take
care of that
that's my question
the timeliness i think and the the
non-compliance the reason that those
things are important to be you know
together and to be here i think is that
the reality is is that again again i
mean i think the fact that the police
departments haven't complied with the
statute is completely related to the
reason why we need a remedy written into
the statute i mean those things are
interrelated i mean that that's the
proof is in the pudding right there
right at the end of the day if there
isn't going to be compliance and there
isn't going to be proof of compliance
this is why we have to have a remedy
otherwise the bill becomes uh
meaningless
representative knight you're recognized
for a question
thank you so much um thank you for
taking my question
when people are falsely accused as i
understand it the state gets sued and
our taxpayers put the bill for
non-compliance happening in our police
departments is that true
are you asking me if when people are
wrongfully convicted they can sue
yes
uh i mean i think the practical reality
of i mean is it possible i am not a
civil attorney i'm a criminal attorney
so those would never be that would not
be something i would ever give anybody
legal advice about uh the practical
reality is that uh
there are a number of uh immunities that
exist that insulate and protect police
departments and the state um from
answering and and having a lot of
accountability as far as um
non-compliance goes and so the practical
reality of suing whether you absolutely
you know whether there's a bar to it or
not uh is that those suits are very
rarely successful even to the extent
that they are initiated in the first
place
representative knight recognized for our
follow-up question
thank you so what you're saying is that
it's even hard it's even harder to
identify in people to make their cases
when they're actually wrongfully
convicted as well
not adding insult to injury on top of
the people of new hampshire having
to pay out of pocket for the police
officers mistakes on not following a
compliance protocol
right
representative martin thank you mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question
let's say that we got a crime and let's
say we've got a couple of eyewitnesses
eyewitnesses um
going to be examined by the prosecutor
and going to be examined maybe even by
the defense attorney try it to the court
hearing except
the understanding of how the law works
so of course that that's the nature of
the trial process what we've learned
from statistics over time and what we've
learned from wrongful conviction cases
is that people's memories are actually
scientifically very unreliable and that
the crucible of cross-examination which
we rely on so often in criminal court to
suss out truth is not always very
effective at doing so the practical
reality is we all believe the things
that we think that we saw with our own
eyes and explaining to somebody that
that's actually not accurate is really
difficult and explaining that to jurors
is really difficult as well it's very
often that folks are not lying the issue
is not that we think people are lying
the issue is that people's memories are
mistaken the five people that identified
our client in massachusetts as the
guilty person were not lying they just
didn't remember correctly or they didn't
remember the details correctly there's a
number of different factors that can
kind of go into that and certainly yes
people can try to cross-examine but
that's really insufficient and it's why
we need the judge as a gatekeeper and
why this remedy is so critical in
hello
representative morrison you recognize
for a follow-up question thank you mr
chairman
the the question just needed a yes or no
but let me go on to say
the prosecutor is going to examine an
eyewitness first
when we ask when a question is asked for
witness even if it is directed really to
be a yes no question we normally don't
want to instruct the witness how to
answer it
president meant it wasn't intended that
way
i apologize you may start the question
my question resolves in that the
prosecuting gets to decide whether
somebody is is
credible or not credible
the defense attorney gets the chance to
do the same thing and present that kind
of an evidence situation
but
let's be honest the eyewitness
no matter how many of them there are or
how little there is if there's only one
they too have a right to testify
and this is all about credibility with
that all being said it's so
big and subjective there's no piece of
legislation that's ever going to resolve
the truth in the matter
that's my question
the practical reality is there is not
one statute that's going to solve all
the problems of the criminal legal
system but it doesn't mean that we
shouldn't make efforts in small ways
that would make uh dense into uh
inaccurate information being presented
to a jury and the reality is although we
uh know that uh
i mean at the end of the day prosecutors
and defense attorneys actually don't
make determinations about credibility
that's left up to the fact finder and
the jury and what we're trying to do is
to give the jury the most accurate and
truthful information because we don't
want the jury to make import make
decisions and make choices about
people's guilt or innocence and about uh
the their their lives based on uh
information that's uh
demonstrably false or has been
coerced through
thank you
i see you no from the hands raised uh
are any members of the public who wish
to testify that are in attendance that
seeing no hands raised we will not close
the public hearing
on house bill 436 and representative
news if you do the honors of
reading the
signing fee
yes mr chair there were 15 uh people who
signed in in support of the bill and
thank you representative muse i'm doing
up close with the public hearing on
at this time we will
whether we're not in
well and any
still at point of one i want to
recognize she had to recognize your
question parliamentary inquiry
thank you
we didn't do our pledge of allegiance at
the beginning of the meeting can we do
it now
all right representative martin first of
all thank you for reminding me of that i
do apologize for we did not do that um
if everyone
everyone doesn't mind maybe you
recognize i'll recognize representative
marston to lead us in the pledge of
allegiance
[Music]
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america and to the
republic for which it stands one nation
under god indivisible with liberty and
um would it be appropriate to find a
suitable and respectful location for the
flag i have a hard time seeing it's
going to be moved okay the flag has only
moved to the middle for the pledge of
allegiance uh however good negligence of
the chair we i forgot to recognize
representative morrison
hence the flag was in the middle of
blocking the view
but you always can see on the computer
at this time we will open the public
hearing on house bill 270
relative to the post prediction dna
testing
representative connolly leave
you around recognizing this music thank
you sorry for my um eagerness watch
watch out for those wires
[Music]
uh mr chairman committee members i am
casey carley state representative dover
here now to introduce hp 270. this bill
contains some modest enhancements to new
hampshire's existing post-conviction dna
testing program which this committee has
seen before in a bill from last term
offered by the former committee chairman
uh this bill uh in a prior term left the
criminal justice and public safety
committee with a 20-0 recommendation
and like many other pieces of
legislation that ran into the covid
related shutdown it did not um
advance uh past the senate or even to
the senate
um so the language contained in this
bill does a few important things first
it clarifies the existing statute on how
someone would petition for this type of
redress uh specifically the court uh
which they would sort of make their
request
it includes a provision to assign an
attorney to someone who pursues this
type of testing
uh but only if they meet uh who is
indigent and only if they meet existing
rigorous requirements to qualify for
this type of release
it clarifies the process for testing the
biological material what lab would be
used
how the results would be shared
with the state and with the person
seeking the testing
um another important uh point to note is
the bill lets people who have completed
their sentences uh but who uh believe
they were wrongfully convicted uh can
request this testing in an effort to
clear their name this person
i like all others who might apply for
the relief would still need to meet the
existing standards
uh for their request to move forward
so a little bit about why this necessary
um
you know we've
become accustomed to this idea of dna
and biological evidence being sort of
everywhere and we see that in csi and
other tv shows but
um
the reality is
not many cases have dna evidence
and we're talking about a small number
of cases
where this type of redress would likely
be requested
and the number of cases where
the individual would qualify and where
the biological evidence would be enough
to exonerate someone is really a tiny
we also have seen i suspect many of us
news accounts of people exonerated for
um
serious times like murder and rape
through dna after serving long sentences
uh one caveat is that here in new
hampshire nobody has been exonerated
through these means and while i'd like
to believe that that means nobody in our
prison system
um pastor president was innocent the
data nationwide just suggests otherwise
passing this bill would give someone who
finds themselves in this terrible
situation a method of seeking their
freedom or their clearing their name
safeguards in the statute would already
protect the state against frivolous
claims or attempts
to
pursue this redress and finally while
the bill does contain a fiscal note
the judicial council has reviewed this
and based on the you know very few
number of um
dna testing requests in a year the
fiscal note does indicate quote uh an
insignificant increase in expenditures
um i asked the committee to recommend
passage passage of the bill i will take
questions i'm also happy to seed the
floor to experts who are expected to
testify after me
[Music]
thank you representative my
um belief is that this bill um was not
significantly changed i don't know if a
word or two changed but the concept the
representative marston thank you mr
chairman thank you mr conway
representative for taking my question
i heard you say that to the best of your
knowledge you don't think that this has
taken place in the state of new
hampshire where somebody has been
exonerated because of the dna
testing is that correct uh
representative
um in my job as a reporter you learn not
to say something is the first or the
only because there's always one that
someone will come back i that is the
best of my knowledge that this that a
dna uh
has not cleared someone i suspect if i
was incorrect somebody will correct me
in testimony and i will certainly
correct the committee representative
martin you have a follow-up question
thank you mr chairman so my follow-up
team representative carly is this this
is not to to address a wrong in trying
to write it it's being proactive ahead
of time in case it should happen thank
you representative we have um this
process on the books already this
essentially um modify it's really a
housekeeping bill in terms of aligning
our existing statute with best practices
from other states it's not um you know a
radical reforming it's
it's it's really just cleaning up the
statute in a lot of ways
representative
testament thank you mr chairman thank
you representative connolly
is
is this
a capability now that will
end up with
less in this case the prisoner's dna is
in some larger database
can other agencies access this
and
maybe make the connection of a previous
crime
this person is he opening himself up to
prosecution
california
guy across he they ended up with his dna
and they found out
representative i don't have a good
answer to that question i believe in the
california case it was a family member
um that they tracked him down through i
could be wrong on that but i i don't
know enough about
what's in place with dna in our state
but i suspect other people might be able
seeing no further questions the
representative
thank
the chair will recognize
hi good morning can you hear me
you can hear
that
decimal will be limited to two minutes
to members of the public we will do a
better job of enforcing this go around
yes i will be quick thank you so much uh
thank you for the opportunity to testify
again and on this bill i really
appreciate it my name is beth powers i
am the state campaigns director for the
innocence project a national
organization dedicated to exonerating
wrongfully convicted people through
post-conviction dna testing and
reforming the criminal justice system to
prevent future injustice this committee
heard and unanimously passed this bill
last year and we thank you for your
support and again ask for your support
this year nationally there have been 370
75 dna exonerations however none have
occurred in the state of new hampshire
which is what representative conley just
stated that does not mean there are not
wrongfully convicted people in the state
it means that we have not had any
exonerations proven through dna
hb270 would clarify and modernize the
current process for seeking dna testing
post conviction this change would not
make it easier or lessen the standard by
which a conviction is overturned but
would rather simply create a clearer
path for obtaining dna testing these
changes not only benefit the wrongfully
convicted often in the course of
settling an innocence claim the actual
perpetrator of the crime is also
identified and therefore prevented from
committing additional crimes changes to
the existing post-conviction dna testing
law would enable justice for the few who
have experienced the unique horror of
wrongful conviction who could benefit
from proving their innocence through dna
testing for those few bill for those few
this bill is monumental i've provided
written comments that detail the changes
proposed in this bill along with
national context
i won't go into that now in the interest
of time but i'm happy to answer any
questions i thank you and urge you to
thank you miss powers for your testimony
the chair would ask to inquire of a
question and i want to thank you in
advance for taking my question
uh
this is more of a nationwide question
but
your organization has handled a lot of
post-conviction cases involving dna
uh how often or how difficult is it for
that dna to be provided for you know
testing
would say that is going to completely
depend on the case and on the state
there's a lot of factors to consider how
old is the case what is the evidence
preservation in the state are they
required to preserve the evidence you
know if someone
often times our clients who are
exonerated have served 10 20 30 40 years
in prison so we're talking about very
old crimes so i would say that it's
going to depend on so many factors one
of the reasons this bill is so important
is because
being able to actually get the testing
is so critical that's why this is so
important new hampshire's law right now
is significantly out of line in terms of
how hard it is just to request the
testing imagine being in prison for
something you didn't do
thinking there's dna in your test in
your case and wanting it tested and not
being able to get that tested that's
what this is about but to answer your
question there's just a lot of factors
uh that will will change that that
answer state to state
thank you and when it comes to testing a
dna or any biological substance do you
do you know the approximate cost of that
test
you know i think that's also going to to
be
dependent on where you are in in in the
in the state it really can vary i know
that it can be a costly process but in
regard to this bill
the number of folks this would apply to
is really small and so i think that um
representative conley
spoke on this on the fiscal impact and i
think you'll hear from buzz later who
anecdotally can speak to the number of
these types of claims he has seen and my
understanding is it's in the range of
10. it's a really small amount so i
don't think that you know the systems
that are already in place to do the
testing are there they exist this is not
building anything new um or anything
thank you for taking my question
representative testerman
thank you mr chairman thank you uh
ms powers uh i have a question
clients
were to submit his dna for
testing and it would ended up collected
could that
could the law enforcement people
prosecute him for some other crime
possibly
you know that's a good question i think
that's something that someone would have
to weigh out in making this decision i
think that someone who's incarcerated
and sitting in prison for something they
didn't do
is probably willing to take that risk so
yes i think potentially if you tested
someone's dna and it came back i'm not
aware of it ever happening i'll say that
to you that doesn't mean it hasn't but
i'm not aware of it happening but i
think more often than not you have a
circumstance where someone knows they
didn't do this and they're sitting in
prison and so they want this tested but
what has happened similar to your
question is we've had instances where
someone is innocent we're able to
finally test the dna and it matches
someone else in the system it's often
matched someone who's currently
incarcerated for something else that
could have potentially been prevented if
that person had been correctly
identified in the first place so that it
does happen that hits come back and
thank you
thank you seeing no for uh no hands
raised i want to thank the witness for a
testimony
excuse me representative knight you have
i did but i was too late i'll respect
uh good morning again to the committee
uh my name is albert scherr i'm a
professor of law at unh
the opinions i express for my own
and not those of unh law or uh unh
proper
um
this is uh this area is is central to my
area of expertise uh i've been
litigating and lecturing and training
and writing about forensic dna evidence
since since the early 90s i handled the
first dna case in new hampshire
i've worked on a
13 year long innocence project case
so uh uh uh uh i'm gonna make every
effort possible did not take two minutes
uh the number of cases that this will ha
that there even is available biological
evidence is
really small you don't see dna evidence
with some rare except you don't see it
in drug cases you don't see it in any
financial crimes you don't see it in
most burglaries you don't see it in most
assault cases that are not sexual
assault the usually you see uh
biological samples of unknown origin in
sexual assault cases and murder cases
those are important cases but it's a
small small subsection
of all the cases out there number one
number two
going forward
and certainly in the last five to ten
years where dna testing has been used
far more aggressively by prosecutors
offices in this state and around the
country
go so going forward you are going to see
less retesting
of dna samples uh because it's already
been done there may be a few here and
there where there's an allegation that
mistakes have been made so going forward
you're not going to see
that many
finally
i've done an informal survey of over 200
criminal defense lawyers in new
hampshire through a listserv in which i
participate
none of them have litigated a uh have
have even applied for have have have
litigated uh the availability of
post-conviction dna testing under the
statute uh some of them know of inmates
who have tried to make their way through
the statute and failed because process
wise it's a good bit
more difficult than we want
but practically speaking this is a
housekeeping measure that makes it
simpler and clearer for what few
prisoners are out there who may wish to
avail themselves of it do so
finally in answer to representative
testerman's question everybody's who's
convicted of a felony in new hampshire
is obligated to give the state of new
hampshire a dna sample so the huge
majority of circumstances their dna is
already in a state genetic database in
the national genetic database the irony
of it is their dna is in there
but
under the current statute it's really
hard for them to get testing on the
biological sample so i think that's
really the the best answer for our
representative testerman's question
hopefully
uh mr chair i came under two minutes
uh
i don't want to
if i may ask you
let me ask if the chair may ask a
question and i want to thank you in
advance for taking my question
uh it's my understanding this would
change the standard from clear and
convincing evidence
to uh is the departments of the evidence
yeah so do you mind explaining maybe the
difference in those two standards
yes uh preponderance of the evidence is
it's more likely than not
uh that the proposition that is being
put forward is the case
50.001 percent
is more likely than not
clear and convincing evidence is
somewhere between
preponderance of the evidence and beyond
a reasonable doubt which is somewhere
over 99 percent clear and convincing
evidence you know oddly enough the best
way to characterize it is to play with
the words you need to be clearly
convinced
um
it's hard for somebody to convince
another person of
that they are that to be clearly
convinced uh of a proposition
particularly in these circumstances
where
uh judges uh
they don't have very much availability
to evidence uh and what you're trying to
establish is
well the proposition is uh it's the case
that this would likely provide
exculpatory evidence even though i was
convicted
and so to have a clearly convinced
standard a clear and convincing standard
is a pretty rigorous standard i think
those people who try and quantify these
standards
think it's somewhere over 75 percent
uh but you know i'm not a big fan of
quantifying numbers but you know it's
somewhere over 75 percent which
you know for
little reason
puts a substantial barrier in the way i
mean i think we all now recognize that
with
uh with these statutes in other states
the floodgates are not opening to
frivolous loss
frivolous efforts to get dna testing
given all the other protections
and there's no reason to put so
substantial a barrier as clear and
convincing evidence in the way
thanks for taking my question if i just
may ask a follow-up question i want to
thank you in advance for taking my
question
but
to your understanding and this is an
approximation how much does it cost to
actually do
the dna test
in
in a state like new hampshire that has a
forensic dna laboratory it's a trivial
uh
marginal cost to do one more uh dna
round of dna testing
um you know i couldn't even put a figure
in it but it it you know their lab is
set up to do this testing it's just them
doing one more test and they do hundreds
of tests a year
uh if it had to be sent out
i've seen it cost anywhere from 500 to a
thousand dollars
uh in the first instance that would be
paid by the individual if they were
declared not indigent
representative hopper thank you mr chair
thank you uh professor for taking my
question
um a couple of times in the legislation
it refers to rsa
526 colon
which seems to put a three-year limit on
the
ability for somebody to
petition the court to check their dna
is that a problem or
yes it is a problem and that's one of
the things we've attempted to fix with
this legislation
you know there's no logical reason that
there should be a three-year limit
on filing a claim for post-conviction
dna testing you know the uh there are
statutes out there that govern
how long the state needs to preserve
evidence
after the conviction is final and
there's no pending motions or court
actions
and that's what should govern how long a
person has to file there's no logic
behind a three-year limit and the goal
of this legislation is to take
take this statute out of that three-year
limit and let it depend on the
availability of
of the biological evidence as governed
representative true thank you mr chair
and thank you witness again for taking
my question
you know of any uh instances in the
state of new hampshire where
somebody in custody or somebody who's no
longer in custody
has asked for that dna testing to be
done and the courts have denied
them to have the right
to have it tested
i know of cases where uh
pre-trial lawyers have asked for dna
testing and for one reason or another
the government opposed it and the court
did not order it
it's not very common at all
but i know of those kind of cases you
know there are cases where uh the
government after they arrested an
individual there's a famous murder case
out of hopkinton in which they arrested
an individual for killing a young girl
and
they were considering charging that
individual with capital murder they sent
the testing out for dna testing down to
the fbi i believe because they didn't
have a dna lab at that point in new
hampshire
and um
the uh the testing came back exculpin
exculpating the individual
so that's a good example of
the more prosecutors
and judges allow
pre-trial dna testing
the less people will need to take
thank you
i believe we're on to our last witness
but if there are any other members of
the public who wish to testify that are
in attendance
cheer recognizing cynthia
hi my name is cynthia musso good morning
again i am uh the representative from
the new england innocence project and i
am a former public defender in new
hampshire for a number of years um i had
some comments prepared but i wanted to
um highlight just a couple of things and
i i did submit written testimony as well
so i don't want to go over that again
but uh what i want to highlight what i
really really want to reiterate here is
that this these amendments make very
small changes that would be very
impactful for the innocent folks in new
hampshire that are unable to access dna
post-conviction testing at this point um
i think the reality is is one of the
things we've been discussing today is
numbers um and my understanding is that
uh the reality is there have been
and i wanna uh commend representative
conley that's right there are no dna
exonerations in new hampshire at this
point the reality is is that even though
we know that it's not reflective of the
fact that new hampshire is in fact a
perfect system but rather uh that uh the
malfunctions that actually plague the
criminal legal system are just as
present here and the reality is we're
not catching these we're not catching
them and this uh these amendments to
this statute are gonna make it more
likely that we're going to catch these
cases um and be able to help some folks
that have been wrongfully convicted of
crimes um but it's still very very
limited um and and there's some sort of
natural limits that are already in place
which have been discussed today like as
buzz highlighted the cases that haven't
been
uh that don't involve dna evidence the
preservation statute which is rsa 651 d3
um there's also uh the fact that um
people don't necessarily people aren't
going to access the statute unless dna
is going to be exonerating uh so the
reality is if folks that it just because
you have dna in your case doesn't mean
the statute is going to be uh something
that you're going to access
um so
the changes are small but the impact for
folks that have been wrongfully
convicted is great uh and the reality is
that justice for the victims is also at
play and i would reiterate that there
are a number of cases we just had a case
in 2019 in massachusetts where we had a
dna exoneration the dna was entered into
the system and the actual perpetrator of
the crime was found that way um as uh
beth discussed in her testimony so uh
the um consequences are really
significant in terms of justice and the
seeing no one hands raise the witness's
excuse
if there are any members of the public
that are in attendance please raise your
hand
seeing no hands raised we will now close
the public hearing
on house bill 270
support
representative
sure um
we had 26 people sign in
in favor of the bill
including catherine cooper from the new
hampshire association of criminal
defense lawyers
and we had two people signing on
opposition
yes
26 people signed in in support and two
people signed in an opposition
and one of the folks who signed in
in support of the bill
was catherine cooper from the new
hampshire association of criminal
defense lawyers
she's somebody that we've heard for
we're going to open the executive
literally we just heard yeah
representative connie you were
recognized
thank you mr chairman i was about to
pass on eq 270.
i'll shake it
has been segmented by president morrison
and just for the members at home this is
not a rule but maybe as a better
practice during the executive session
they want to just keep keep our videos
on just to make sure uh
uh
it would make it would make my job
easier here
just about one second
[Music]
you wish to speak to your emotion about
the past mr chairman there's little i
could ask that would be better than the
would anyone else i'll open the question
representative rose
this isn't really a question i guess
it's just more of a statement i
i really don't see anything negative
that
with the dna but i think
like you can only you're only on child
for that particular client right so that
i don't really think about it
i think you could probably answer that
better
but
it's just like any other evidence i'll
say and you know i'm not speaking by any
specific case that i haven't worked on
but
if i'm going to request something that
if i know that it's going to incriminate
you know the defendant or my client
there is not somewhat of a discretion to
not request at least advise the person
are you sure you want you know
one that comes up often unrelated to dna
but a drunk driving boost
if the person really is impaired do you
really want to request the cooking
camera
it's within the discretion the attorney
but i
that's just one example but just think
in
throughout the country these cases some
attorney generals are
have taken these all the way up to the
supreme court of their state
and they spend hundreds of thousands of
dollars trying to not produce
evidence that's in their possessions
if it's not exculpatory and it's only
going to prove without what some what
they already know i don't you know it's
i understand there's no harm in
producing it but there has been
exonerations throughout the country so
people served jail we've been in jail
for 10 15 years and there was one
mountain board involving a hair sample
this person was in jail for 18 years and
this was actually a case work on body
innocence project
and it's a little complicated but the
hair sample like i suppose when someone
passed away
you can tell by their hair after a
couple hours that they've been taken
away from a certain time period well the
hair sample that they
had inside that
linked addiction i'm sorry that's
defending the case
it had it was taken post-mortem
so when the person's charged murder that
hair sample wouldn't have been there
so they they were actually able to prove
that the
evidence they were planning although
that person did get a very uh
very high civil judgment thereafter
was 18 million dollars they did spend 18
years their life in prison for a promise
they would prove they did not commit and
the reason why it took so long
was that it took
like decades to get the dna testing that
everyone already had
and this is not for they they must have
spent more money defending that case in
florida
and then civil judgment there did this
it never should have gone that long they
had to have the whole time i i would be
roxanne hopper
yeah this is just because i'm new to the
committee i'm kind of curious
um
the reference to
420 whatever
what line
i don't know
so i have no idea what mine is
says there's a three-year limit
obviously it doesn't apply to this
but why is there only a three-year limit
why would people be able to steal their
convictions
much later than three years that's just
[Music]
notwithstanding the rsa so it's kind of
eliminating the rsa which is good
and you want to you want to eliminate
three years here which just does and the
reason for that is that some of the dna
technology
that's just
existed at the time of the condition may
not exist in the present time
so they there are circumstances where
the testing of the asymptote didn't
exist within that three year window well
that particularly is more relevant to
cases from the early 90s mid 90s but
it's still a good idea to keep that
yeah that's not like that's really not
my question my question i understand
that this bill
says not withstanding so therefore it
ignores 526 golden four
but what i don't understand is why
why your
526 colon 4 has a three-year limit why
i understand the question that maybe
that may be an issue for this community
to discuss in a different day
because
it just seems very short
period of time because people can find
somehow
you know i think i think that's
something that we all should look into
and i mean
and i think we'll discuss it
just one thing that i wanted to say i'll
i'll be supporting this bill this year
just like i did last year um but one of
the things to note is that um this is a
very good bill that addresses a very
very very um
small number of people um and and
hopefully
one of the outcomes of a bill like this
is that somebody who may have been
wrongfully convicted will will be
released uh but it is interesting to
note uh the way that this bill was
paired with uh
with the previous bill and the fact that
um
many more people are subject to
eyewitness identification and sometimes
improper identification
so the potential impact of the bill we
heard earlier is
significantly greater for a wider range
of people
so i just wanted to kind of note how the
bills
seem to work together
and uh and i know we're not talking
about the other bill but i guess i'll
i support this bill
seeing seeing known hand
representative
not not really a feel-good bill but
we're addressing an issue that's never
happened in new hampshire
we're addressing an issue that
no one has ever been denied the
opportunity to go back even after when
you're releasing
from jail to go back and have dna tested
nobody's ever been denied that
now nowadays dna is very common
i would think most
defense lawyers
would be looking at
dna testing if they're
for the innocent clients
so it's a great idea it's a great bill
that means
okay
oh i respect the comments of the
representative i will just explain that
what this is doing
in this in our justice system and i i
respect our system i believe in our
system and i
i work in the system
and i stand by it
but i will say
there are limited occasions where
a person is wrongfully convicted
one wrongfully convicted person is too
many
and i i would think that this
if it did happen this puts that person
in the best position to right
or correct that injustice
and the fact that it hasn't happened yet
doesn't it's because it hasn't
we haven't proven it that it's happened
yet doesn't mean it hasn't happened yet
i'm not implying that it's happening in
the future
but
i would say being proactive on this
would be the best approach because
if someone spends a decade in
incarcerated keep in mind
if you have an innocent person in prison
and most likely we're talking about rape
or murder
and you have the wrong person
in jail that means there is a chance
that there is a murderer or rapist
out in the public who is actually
getting away with
that crime so there's really two
injustices there because the bit is the
victim
of that
in the victims families
you know they deserve justice too they
have the actual
correct person prosecuted
in charge of the program so i think it
really the only help
representative
thank you mr chairman and
if you could answer one question before
i spend uh
68 seconds on my speech you could stop
that
oh
it's up to the ag i mean the ag would
could fight if somebody wanted to do
this test is that correct
yes they have the art if they have the
option to object to it or they can
consent to it
okay
all right may i continue then all right
now that i understand that which i
thought that's what was the case um
i can't remember who the presidential
candidate that lived in goffstown
um
she was on the democrat side
uh kelsey
yeah she mentioned an ag in california
on the debate stage where
she did exactly what we're trying to
prevent here
so what my point is is we really can't
control the future
if we don't do anything we can't control
the future a.g
person in new hampshire if they went
rogue on us and started doing this like
the california ag did years ago
so i'm thinking why not support this uh
because of that situation you know right
now it probably hasn't happened
but we can't control the future aeg
office
and now this law will control it that's
seeing no hands raised uh deploring up
all the role the question
is ought to pass if you were in support
of the motion of octopass please say yay
if you are opposed please say hey
vice chairman welch yes
representative burke
yes
representative hopper yes
representative green yay
representative wallace
yes
representative testerman yes
representative true yay
representative pratt yes
representative marston yes
the clerk votes yes
representative harriet gathright yes
representative pantalakis
yes
representative gordon a
representative muse yes
yes yes
representative bowden
yes
representative conley yes
representative bradley
yes
chairman abbas
the chair of ots
mr chairman with only one person being
absent we have
20 to nothing
five
they
still call it a majority report but
absolutely
thank you
representative
thank you mr j could you explain once i
cut off of when a bill with an fm can go
on consent
and when i can't afford
this
[Music]
all right and just to the members i
understand before we take a million
questions
unless you know the specific answer to
the question
please don't raise your hand but my
understanding is that in order for
somebody to go on the consent calendar
they do not have a fiscal note we are
growth so this happens this one out of
zero dollars but it's a fiscal note
nonetheless
of course right
it says on
the end of the official note there would
it would have to be taken off and said
yeah
i just want to mention that there was
testimony that um the
defendants would have to pay for
the testing
and the and the other piece of that is
that the um state if they're the ones
that's trying to prove it of course
i will uh
be sure to uh consult with the park
right now representative newman
is this regarding that specific issue
and do you have an answer for it
no i i have a question of the chair
adjusting
we might be able to do another executive
session
i understand that i'm just concerned
about uh or i have a question about
there was a real issue erased in in this
bill about the time limit and that it
was very short and in this time in this
time of time restraints
i was going to vote for this bill and
maybe we could fix that later is that a
right approach to that or
is that doesn't matter
that's a that's a question that it would
if i can control how you voted every
single time representative newman it
would make my life a lot easier
if i i didn't understand you i didn't
hear your comment
and i could control
how representative newton voted all the
time
we're answer going to wait to 10 45
which was in one minute and we're going
to start depending on which block you
is
you can go to cedar water for a dip
gary can representative popper can show
you where cedar waters is
representative
i
yeah but they won't stay that's the
are you warm
oh yeah
it's nice though it feels like something
else
all right let's let's uh let's stick our
cc
star hd fighter i can make the motion if
relative to the seizure of personal
computers and other electronic devices
in child sexual assault cases
the chair is going to represent
recognize representative marston to
if there's any members of the public who
intend on testifying that are
[Music]
thank you mr chairman and thank the
fellow members of this committee for
i've got
a little story to tell you because this
bill as it's presented also has an
we'll talk about that in a moment
the reason the amendment came about was
because when i put this request into ols
and we sent it out to me as they as you
all know you ask for a bill
they research or what have you and then
they send it to you for your approval
well i waited and waited and waited and
i never got anything back from ols
so i ended up inquiring what happened to
my
request for a bill
well we sent it to you
14 days ago
oh what what address did you send it to
my old
four-year-old
email address which was a legislative
email when i was up here before
and i had long since deleted it
and now i've got that all straightened
out with the state
so that people will just send it to my
regular email
so when i finally got it i only had
three days to approve it
and get it back in or it would have died
off
so i just said i just went ahead and
said yes it's good let's go
then when i read it some more
i realized there were some stakes in the
bill and that's why the amendment is
there
but now let's talk a little bit about
the bill and what it's about
because i'm a firm believer
that we have bills presented to us
to try to rectify problems
if there's if there's no problem to be
solved why have a bill
well in this case
it's a very serious problem
i believe it and i've been involved with
little leagues and so i know about
child's sexual abuse
not that i've done it but i know that
there are people that do it
my point is that this case came about
because of a constituent of mine
who came to me and said
the
person that did
was
was arrested was convicted
and is in jail i believe he got
sentences
running i guess one after the other so
he's in there for a little while
this started back in way back in
13 if i'm not mistaken uh
and i've got a lot of notes here from
the parents that they gave to me
and what they're looking for is not
any more to do with the case
and the predator
gets done and over with and they're
happy with the results
but they had one question from the
get-go
they asked the police when they went in
and into his apartment and he was an
acquaintance of the family
and arrested him
there was a and they knew the story the
police did that this happened on this
guy's couch
with a computer
looking right at the couch
and all the technology now this was not
an ordinary
computer this was something that was
handmade or to that extent that somebody
created it and put all kinds of devices
into it and on it
so you could end up
well being able to take either photos or
videos and this was in the room where
the molestation occurred
the police
didn't
impound or confiscate the computer they
didn't ask for a warrant
the prosecuting attorney
didn't do anything about this guy's
computer
now mind you the parents are jumping up
and down
at this time saying
we want to know if our son
has been videotaped or had pictures
taken of him in the process of this
crime
and everybody ignored him
they got the court they asked the judge
the same thing
and he said oh no you don't have a right
to do that
so i take that
a predator
a child molester has more rights
than the parents or the kids to know if
they're going to be posted on the
internet
does that make sense to any of us
a predator has more rights
than the parents to know if their kid is
on the internet
and nobody is everybody is saying no we
don't we don't want to look at that
we're not interested
well the parents are
not for their case
they just know what happened to them
they don't want it to happen to some
other parents some other children and we
know
and i know
having been a president of a little
league and looked into
i one time
went on site to find out how many
predators were in
the district that my little league was
in
and it was somewhere in the vicinity of
150 to 200 predators around little
league fields etc etc
so they're out there
and they love taking pictures and they
love putting it on the internet
and we gotta find a way
to stop that
and so
the section about computers and
pornography and child exploitation
they're there if they had gone in and
looked at this guy's computer and found
pictures images or video
that would then became also a federal
crime as i understand it now i'm not a
lawyer and i could be wrong
but i understand it could be a federal
crime which would enhance the penalties
that didn't happen
so
so the bill as it is is asking that
we seize the personal computers and
electronic devices
a law enforcement officer who has
probable cause to believe that the
personal computer
or other electronic devices is being
used to violate any provision of this
chapter
may now here's where i make messed up
without obtaining a search warrant see
such personal computer or other
electronic devices
so my amendment
changes that
that it has to have it's not without a
warrant there has to be a warrant and
then they can seize it
and they're only seizing it for the
purpose
of looking into the computer somebody
who doesn't have a gripe in this it's
not the parents looking at it it may not
even be the
law enforcement people what they want to
do is look in this guy's computer
and find out if he's got images
and he's playing around as well
after he's done the molestation now this
molestation happened to this young man
about five years and
maybe a parent is going to testify after
i get done
to just give you some of the flavor from
their point of view
so
i found that i
that this is something that
i i like to ask a question when people
bring a bill up
what are you trying to solve
what are you trying to do
and what is the cost
to go to the last part of it
the bill does have a fiscal note
and it's it's just it's just an
estimated yes i would tell you i would i
read as i read it of about ten thousand
dollars now i don't i don't understand
how that comes into play but
i don't wanna not point out all the
parts of the bill
[Music]
so
i want to have the amendment brought up
and i'm assuming that that can be done
at this time mr chairman
no they need it would need to be offered
during the executive session but if i
i understand your amendment and if i can
just maybe clarify the testimony
the original bill
on line six
contains the language without obtaining
a search warrant
that same language on the original bill
appears on line 13 without obtaining a
search warrant it's in my understanding
that the amendment which is amendment
2021-01
line 6 and line 13 of the original bill
by we're saying by saying after
repeating a search warrant
correct
copy of the amendment if they use give
me a thumbs up a thumbs down on their
video
we have it here in the chamber you have
the people here it's the easy one easy
one i'm talking about
okay thank you mr chairman thank you for
i know that this is kind of a
strange
piece of legislation
but i hope i've explained
where i'm coming from and this needs to
be resolved in some manner unless
people here kind of think oh we're just
some town molesters well if we catch him
we catch him if we don't we don't and
the the materials can be on the internet
for the rest of humanity
and that's the question the problem that
i'm bringing to you and with some
corrections to this bill i'm seriously
hoping that we can get this into a
situation of ought to pass with an
amendment
and i will take any questions that
i don't know maybe it's me i think i'm
confused a little bit so the whole
essence of this is that if
they believe people are dealing with
child pornography and everything or
exploiting children
you want to make sure that they have um
a warrant before going in
and confiscating
representative yeah
in a few words yes
the question really came down to this
man was arrested
but at the time they went into his
apartment and arrested him
they didn't take the computer and the
parents were saying take the computer we
want to knock my kids on
and so they needed they would have
needed a warrant let me give another
example if i had
if you had a murder and the guy is shot
and the gun is on the floor
and the police walk in
they're not going to grab the gun they
might have to have a warrant before they
can pick it up
but don't it make some sense that
they're going to take the gun they're
going to examine it
who owns it
has it been fired is it the same caliber
of the wound in the person
evidence that the guided dead fired it
because he's got residue on his hand or
what is the story they're not going to
just look at that gun on the floor and
go oh that don't mean nothing
what the heck guys
so they're gonna do something with it
but what the parents are asking here is
this kid was in a room
on a couch
while being molested and this was not
just a one-time incident this went on
for several years
the parents thought this guy was okay
with that kid they had already
investigated him but they didn't know
what was going on
but in this room is the computer
facing the couch looking at it and
able if in operation to take pictures
or to take video
and the parents simply wanted to know is
my kid on them
doesn't that make sense to anybody here
who has children who hopes to someday
have children and if they were being
molested would want to know if their
kids now been put on the internet
am i right am i wrong
um
you want them to take the computer right
yes
okay
so if they went for hope i'm sorry
yes thank you
so if um
you think
they
they're going in
because they believe
this person
you know have these offenses
however
i believe you're saying
they shouldn't be going in period
because
they didn't have a warrant
because when i read the original bill
maybe that's where my confusion is
coming in
um
it looks like they see seize the
property
because they believe the person is
guilty of computer pornography and
everything else
so
however they went and i'm assuming that
they might have had a warrant to go in
before or they might have just gone in
because somebody called and complained
and just said um
my neighbor you know
has been touching my child or whatever
you know and um and they go in
typically they would take the computer
but you're saying if you didn't have a
warrant don't take the computer
is that what you're saying
[Music]
yes and no
like the
the complaint could get the police to go
in to arrest this men was had been done
many times
the parents had complained to the
manchester police department
and they had looked into this matter
and then they finally determined that
they were going to arrest this gentleman
and when they walked in and they
arrested them
i'm assuming i don't know
police procedure but i'm assuming they
have the right to arrest somebody
without a warrant that's my
understanding but they don't have a
warrant to grab his computer and
therefore they didn't touch his computer
it would be the same thing in the sense
of the gun on the floor
they they going to arrest somebody but
they're not going to grab the gun
because they don't have a warrant to
pick up the gun they got to stop
everything
we'll go get a warrant from a judge
i'm just i can't get out that way that's
fine i have no objections
i'm hoping that they answered
that
thank you so what you want is for
automatically when they go in to
to arrest a suspected child officer to
make sure they always take the computer
so that they can check to see if there
is anything on it
is that what you're asking for
yes and no
no if the guy's got a computer in
another part of the house or in another
room
no don't let don't you have no right to
go touch his computer
but if where the molestation is taking
place in that room and he's got a
computer facing that couch which in this
case that was the case
there is no way of knowing whether he
did or he didn't it would almost need an
independent person to look into his
computer and not be looking to see what
other things he's doing but is this
child in his computer on video or
pictures
that would make sense because it's not
just indiscriminately
but it it is that they
should have a warrant to still take his
computer because it was
it was a part of the crime
it was used in the crime not his
computer in another room
computers and or the components from
computer
can be anywhere
in the house
they could have been used previously
that particular time
you ought to seize all the computers
take a look and see if there's a problem
you know wouldn't you
wouldn't you want something to just say
mandatory and and if there's something
i would agree with you but i've talked
to lawyers and i've talked to people and
i've talked to the police
and i go back to a statement that i made
in presenting this
piece of legislation
the criminal has more rights than you
need the children the parents they got
uh no mr chair i uh i weighed my
questions
[Music]
thank you mr cameron
thank you for taking this question
this to me sounds like we are telling
you
telling the priest what procedure they
should do
so am i correct
somebody has got to tell somebody what
to do when you make an arrest and you
see the the
weapon if you will or the the the
instrument of the crime
do you not think that be the case
yes i do but further question
you recognize for a follow-up question
do we know for sure that that computer
was never taken
yes
absolutely
representatives
thank you everyone thank you
representative for taking my question
um you know the last couple of bills
that we just heard hearings from on
protocols of documentation
and procedures on evidence gathering
wouldn't that streamline the process for
this problem specifically
and solve future problems across the
state and make sure that
indeed we are gathering the correct
evidence
thank you for your question and if i
understand you correctly yes that is
correct
thank you
representative greene
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative taking my question
which
what you're saying
is without a warrant
that this could be thrown out at any
time but because there is a warrant and
they have the evidence then it makes the
i would say so but i'm not a lawyer and
i'm not in that
profession and that's why
myself
and the family that's brought this to me
that's what we're trying to figure out
and see if we can't solve a problem
because they never ever
that computer still exists today to the
best of their knowledge unless somebody
has as the father said unless somebody
has as a recently which makes no sense
anyways but taken the computer and
thrown it in the merrimack river but yes
that's what we're trying to solve
see no further hands raised i want to
thank the representative for assessment
thank you all and i hope my parents end
up
having a chance to testify
oh there they are
hi
my my name is scott spence um i am the
stepfather of the um child that um was
um abused in this case
and um
just to um give you a recap what
happened in this case was that
like
representative marston said the um
the computer was there and present and
it had
cameras that were available on it
um the camera the computer does exist to
this day
and the reason that we were told that
the computer did not
wasn't taken
was that in the c cac interview that was
taken
um
by my son and my um stepson
because my son was the one that actually
caught the
abuse happening to my stepson
um so basically this happened to two
children um
in the
course of what happened
um
the
they didn't mention the computer
um so it wasn't taken
and they actually went to the
perpetrator and asked the perpetrator if
he used the computer on the children
and he said no so they didn't even
bother kind of going after it
and
when the we pressed the issue they went
to
the prosecutor did go to a judge and
asked the judge and the judge said no
because it would violate his fourth
amendment rights but at this point the
computer was gone from the premises
well basically what we would like to be
asked with this bill
is that when the time of arrest
a a search warrant be issued
to
go for the electronic devices so that
way they can be checked so that way
another family doesn't go through
i guess the not knowing of what we've
and it you know it would bring it to a
different level if there was something
if there wasn't something hey no problem
um you know there's no harm no follow i
guess but it
there is stuff there and like um
representative testerman said if there
is something there
then
you know a computer can be moved
so if there's something in the house it
should be it should be checked
so that's what kind of we were asking is
that
and a kid wouldn't necessarily know for
instance my my stepson
wouldn't have known if he was being
recorded because not only in this
computer system there were
you know
cameras in the monitors but there was
also a camera sitting on top of the
monitor
so that could have been turned easily
and he could have been videotaped he
never would have known
so basically like
you know we were asking is something the
issue at the time of arrest so
i thank you for your testimony
representative wallace thank you mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question i'm sorry that you had to go
through this horrible situation
my understanding correct that you'd like
to see
to make sure there's no images of what
may have transpired not so much for the
purposes of conviction but to prevent
further victimization of the victims in
these types of situations and to ensure
that that
those images do not get out to the uh to
the worldwide web
correct absolutely um you know we have
no idea whether um our son is out there
on on
in any type of
um
i guess the the dark web or wherever you
know
and you know i really don't have the
stomach to go searching either you know
so
we don't want any any other child to go
through this or family i should say to
go through this and you know i don't
want my stepson to be
on the computer one day and oh all of a
sudden there he is
you know
i mean and once these things were out
there it it probably be very difficult
to put back but i don't want to be
not found and be able to be put back out
there sometime later on in the future
and
if if it does
if images are found
it will add to a case against the
perpetrator
representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony sir
uh i'm just curious could you elaborate
a little bit more
because it's confusing to me why the
judge would not
issue a warrant you know
you know i know there is a fourth
can you explain a little deeper why the
judge if you know
you know would refuse a warrant because
i would think a warrant would be you
know easy to obtain
what we were what we were told was that
um our both our sons did not mention it
in the cac interview
and that it would violate the
perpetrator's fourth amendment rights
that's what we were told and that's as
far as it went
and
as far as we
are concerned
in my
my view that was unacceptable
end of story i think that
personally more investigation should
have been either taken
or that
um
something like this should exist so that
it could have been taken
at at the time of the arrest
thank you and
and you can't i'm sorry if i could
elaborate and you you can't rely on the
child
thank you chair
thank you for taking my question and i'm
really sorry that this happened to you
and your family
i just want to go on the record and say
for everyone here we take this on the
committee very very seriously
and i want to know
if
you would be okay if because the issue
really is a lack of streamlined process
and procedures of documentation that our
police
are having in this state would you be
okay if
this issue were to be resolved in
another bill
um it all depended upon the wording and
such i wouldn't know it's again like i'm
not a lawyer
and i don't know how i mean
as long as the issue was
um i guess resolved where the point
where
that it was
the the perpetrator possibly isn't
getting away with a crime and it's a
base basically it's not only
what my goal is not only to help the
families in knowing or not whether or
not that
images are possibly not on a computer
and getting them off but it's also
possibly aiding
the police
or law enforcement in knowing
and getting extra charges on a possible
perpetrator so
that's that's the goal point blank
so if it's in this bill or another bill
so be it
thank you so much and again i'm sorry
for what you've had to experience and um
it's really brave and to come before the
state and share that with us thank you
so much
thank you
representative
thank you mr chairman i'm so confused
about this bill and this is a reflection
of
probably me but i guess security on
what is proposed here i understand this
awful situation that the gentleman from
manchester his family went through
that's
horrifying
but as i understand it the original bill
would remove the requirement for a
warrant to seize electronic devices is
that correct
and the question of the chair i'm not
the question but while we have a witness
on the stand maybe
delay your parliamentary inquiry after
thank you for taking my question um
in on past bills we've heard uh
testimony from folks on the state police
internet crimes unit
and i do know that they investigate
crimes involving
pornography children
and computers
and i'm curious if any attempt or if you
know
any attempt was made
between the manchester police in this
particular unit because it would seem
like
a computer in the same room that the
assault took place
would constitute
probable cause
for their involvement
and i'm just curious
if that has uh is anything that came up
no and actually we've sort of kind of
reached back out to that department
recently because of this bill coming up
and
basically it's kind of
falling on its face again because we
actually know where the computer resides
to this day
and it's fallen on its face again but
that was just our personal thing and
we've kind of resigned ourselves to
the fate of that computer and everything
else and that's not the point of this
bill is to get anything for ourselves
it's for the future
so because this bill came up the
manchester police um chief did reach out
to us because he had heard of this bill
and he talked with us about you know
our case and etc and we did um talk to a
detective and stuff and
he kind of it kind of fell flat on his
face so
um nothing was
you know nothing went forward on that
but we would one would think that it
would
do what exactly what you said but no it
did not
thank you representative
thank you for taking my question
um i may be
dumb about this but i always assumed
when they re
arrested somebody
that they took the computers and whatnot
in order to prove their case
that that was our assumption as well and
that is not the case
that's what thank you for trying out of
this bill
so thank you
see no no hands raised i want to excuse
the witness and
i want to thank the representatives a
lot of us have uh the ones that didn't
speak i'm sure i can say that we all
i'm sorry for you and your family
chief
um alan aldenberg
good morning mr chairman can you hear me
yes we can hear you
appreciate you listening uh give me the
opportunity to speak this is in fact the
manchester case and
we are extremely extremely sensitive and
to these cases in this case in fact was
um
was thoroughly investigated and the
person received an extensive um
prison sentence obviously none of the
family it never is in these type of
cases um unfortunately manchester police
department investigates hundreds of
these cases a year we have detectives
that are very well versed and trained in
this
i'll i'm hearing all this testimony and
at the end of the day what it comes down
to is probable cause
and
that's why we went in front of the judge
um
to obtain a search warrant for that
computer and there was not enough
problem cause
as so if we're trying to circumvent it's
gonna be a dangerous world if we're
trying to circumvent
the search warrant process um simply to
seize a computer that
we cannot substantiate that there's a
probable cause to believe that that's
evidence of the crime um that's to me
that's not meant to
be insulting to anybody i'm not trying
to
dismiss what the family's going through
but at the end of the day
if there's not enough probable cause to
seize a computer that may be
where the crime took place or another
part of the home um
you know based off the investigation we
do what we can do
and establish as much probable cause as
we can to make an arrest and to get
search warrants on any case that we
investigate no matter what it what it
may be so there's already process in
place and it's it's called the
constitution in my opinion thank you for
listening
thank you
and i thank you for your testimony the
chairman just didn't want to inquire
over with an inquiry and i want to thank
you in advance for taking my question
so if i just understood your testimony
correctly
the police department applied
for a search warrant to obtain to seize
the computer
but it was denied by the judge or the
court was that correct
thank you for taking my question
representative hopper uh thank you mr
chair thank you chief for uh taking my
question
um
from the beginning of this hearing i was
rather confused but now i
seems like i understand
my question is
a statement and a question the statement
is
i'm sure you're aware that most people
who engage in uh abusing
children sexually or also typically
have addictions to pornography and all
kinds of other crap
why isn't that nexus between um
a person who was engaged in sexual
sexually abusing a child
and the
great probability that he also has
information on a computer
stated that the computer had to be in
the room but the computer could be in
in uh
anywhere you can still videotape
so my question is how can we rewrite
this
so that when somebody is being uh you
have uh substantial evidence that
somebody is being
sexually abused
that that in and of itself is probable
cause to seize electronic devices that
again i think that would be a stretch
without
articulating
the appropriate level of probable cause
to get a judge to sign the search
warrant
i mean
i just there's no way around that if you
through the investigation if you do or
do not establish enough probable cause
to get your warrants um
you know
that's that's the world we live in
rightfully so um
so i don't
i don't think you're gonna circumvent
that you know this in this case you know
in many cases like this the children go
through cac interviews very difficult
interviews
done by trained forensic interviewers
that
based off those interviews they may
develop additional probable cause that
there appears to be in fact that a
computer may have been used okay then we
can reapply
for a search warrant or amend our
initial search warrant to try to get
into that computer or computers
but without that probable cause
you're not going to the judge is not
thank
you
representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you
originally i think the
bill if i read it correctly was
that you have the right to just grab
that computer and i agree with you the
constitution would probably come down
and slap anybody that did that pretty
hard
but now
the amendment says that you have to get
a search warrant
yes
yes so
if i if i walk into your your home and
as evidence of the crime that we're
investigating and you know the
representative used the
the example of a gun on the floor okay
okay there's guns there it's
relatively clear that may have been used
in the commission of a crime we are
going to lock that residence down and
we're going to apply for a search more
before we remove any property from that
home
so
just because you you
you know
it's going to say the amendment's going
to say you have to apply for a search
warrant well that's what we do now
and if there's if there's not enough
probable cause for a judge to sign that
search warrant
then we're not getting into the computer
that's that's what the process is now
i don't mean to sound i don't mean to
and
i just
just to clarify i don't i don't believe
anyone in the committee uh finding your
testimony to be demeaning or insensitive
by any means
we all understand it's a very sensitive
subject but
you know the fourth amendment is written
as it is and i think that's that's what
the
chief is saying and we have to respect
especially law enforcement who are
impacted by the
uh
so i just want to clarify and understand
i didn't receive any sense of it
thank you for your testimony
representative yeah just follow up mr
chairman uh thank you uh chief for
again with a very sensitive situation as
this is and i'm sure you guys did
everything you could to get that warrant
um
now that the bill went to that you're
going to grab the computers which would
be against the constitution too you've
got to get a search warrant
you know i hate to say it but the bill's
really not needed at this point because
would that be true
that's correct borrowing any uh
constitutionally accepted uh
existency um but in these cases um
i'm not
you know i'm not part of icac but we
have people that are but
i'd be coupled to say that 100 of the
time
those type of investigations result in a
search warrant of a computer
thank you sir representative pantologist
thank you mr chairman i
in
mr
and the other representative's
testimony
he said that
they did not the judge said that they
did not
mention
the computer is that the reason
why
he could not have a search warrant
that's correct representative there was
not enough uh sufficient level of
probable cause for a judge to sign a
search warrant to search that computer
now that does not mean that
you know you
you don't stop your investigation and
you know if further information comes
forward then you can reapply for a
search warrant but in my understanding
in this case there was no additional
information to substantiate that
thank you
representative newman
thank you mr chair um
my question is is the way that the uh
the amendment is written it says
may sees the computer after getting a
search warrant so it seems like you may
do it if you get a search warrant and
isn't that the case right now
follow-up
representative newman you recognize for
a follow-up
so just make sure i completely
understand it does not require you to
get a search warrant and seize the
computer in all of the cases that deal
i want to make sure you stand your
question correctly
um are you asking if we'll apply for a
search warrant every time in these type
of cases with computers are involved
representing any qualified question
yes my question is since it says may and
not shall
does the law require the the is it your
opinion that this
that this law causes you to have to get
a search warrant every time you
uh arrest somebody for this kind of
crime
we would anyways
representative testerman
[Music]
if
is there
any
law rule whatever
that would allow you to
to
assume
i know this is a difficult word but
when you go into a situation where
you're going
to arrest somebody for
child abuse
to assume
that any computers in the area may have
been used for that
and
[Music]
having to go to a judge and say well i'm
sorry the child didn't
mention computers
and
therefore i don't have probable cause
to me it's a little shaky
i
i'm just frustrated
that there has to be some way to get you
to
to let you go in
[Music]
seize any electronic devices along with
the suspect
and
take a look and see if there's something
on that
that's related to the case i know
i'm not sure that's a fourth amendment
issue but maybe it is so is there any
kind of
wording of
a law rule or something that would
not that i'm aware of i mean
i understand the frustration i
understand the frustration of the family
in particular
[Music]
but just to assume that something's on a
device and for us to just arbitrarily go
into it
and say if you do that and say you
discover stuff
that incriminates the suspect and you've
done so without a warrant you've now
compromised your case
um
so again
in these type of cases a search warrant
will be completed it's already
i don't like to find work or i don't i
don't like to find work around the
seeing no hands raised i want to thank
the witness for his testimony
there's any members of the public who
wish to testify that have not testified
already
that are in attendance please raise your
hand
signal hands raised
at this time
we will close uh the public hearing
on household 520
25.
mr chair we had uh zero people signing
in in support of the bill
and we had 10 people signing in in
opposition
this at this time
guys we're going to open the executive
session
it was the
relative to an eyewitness identification
procedure
recognized
okay
[Music]
uh well you're not recognized for
yes um
i will opt to pass on
you wish to speak on your motion yeah i
can speak a little bit to it um
it was very concerning to to hear that
um
the um the group what is it called the
innocent project had actually reached
out to all of our police departments
asking for you know information as to
whether they were even compliant with
the agreement
and um
and from what i heard
most of them were not compliant
um
the deputy chief from nashua
basically stated that nashua
is certified in so many different ways
and what have you but we're here
representing the state
not one town or one city or
or anything we're here representing the
state
um the citizens of the state
so with that said even if only two
police
departments
are compliant
it seems like we need to do something to
bring the other
uh
departments across the state in
compliance
with the agreement that was made seven
years ago from what i can tell
so um
that is my reason for wanting to go
forward with this bill
because obviously
it's not across the state
and um in terms of the
concern about
i don't know
what's the right date so i can't speak
to that but for what the bill is trying
to do
to
pull our law enforcement accountable for
so again
and i'm not sure if anybody else um read
any of the documentation that was sent
to us from the um innocent project as
well as from buzz
and
it was actually was quite moving
to see that that so many people have
worked on this
and on a very good bill and that it did
pass
previously
um but here we are again like a lot of
other bills have passed
um to go through this all over again
and the testimony of the young lady was
really really emotional to me
so i just
hope that my
colleagues agree and that we move this
representative welch
yes there was some concern i understand
during the testimony but remedies for
this
well the only remedy is the jury shall
be instructed as to whether or not
there's credible evidence of compliance
or non-compliance
there's no sanctions to the law
enforcement or anything else
[Music]
if you don't mind just raising your
digital hand sometimes the hand being
raised off the screen so just i would
raise it with visual hand it's actually
easier for the chair and uh
[Music]
yeah i'm having
the purpose of the innocence project
it's a good idea it's it's
it it's
long overdue
and there's a lot of cases
of uh
that
innocence has not been properly
attributed
but here's my problem we've got a law
that wants to fix
instance budget it's really fixing
police
procedures or police
they told us
[Music]
these
several hundred agencies that we sent
something to
some of them didn't
respond so they didn't have procedures
in place
we're trying to tell the police to do
their job
and this isn't the bill for it i i just
i understand the issue of people being
concerned
about
police not doing their job and there's
some people who are more concerned than
to use that as evidence
to pass it bill
representative chestnut and thank you
comment representative
thank you mr chairman and i
am going to vote against the op to pass
motion
and the reason is you know hearing
the national police officer speak on it
and where i'm having the problem is the
date
you know why do we have to back up to uh
fine representative that made the motion
cannot explain that
so i'm stuck on that part
you know i've supported a lot of things
that the innocent project
has brought forward and i do support
them i just think
this was poorly written in the way
they're going down the path is going to
be very problematic for the officers or
the
police
i would have been a lot happier if they
that this was going to start on x date
in the future
you know with all the
manuals written to make sure that it's
in
i would have supported that
just the way it's written
[Music]
you know just it's just very problematic
as the officer said
and again you know i go back to line
four where they want to remove the day
to such lineups so you know there was
really no clear
explanation of why
i'm gonna do my best to convince both of
you to agree to agree with the chair
let's see how i do it that's my skills
so i agree the online four you know
changing data such lineups i didn't find
the original confusion i think they just
but while they're going through the this
bill you might as well clarify if you
see language in any bill it never hurts
to make it clearer if you see something
you see oftentimes it says he
shall do this
they tend to change say he or she i mean
clarification
um
for prestigious current as of january
1st 2019 because my understanding of the
testimony
is that every 10 years an updated police
practices manual come out
so the most current one is january 1st
2019. i understand that this
eventually
maybe come outdated and i would assume
that that would be on january 1st of
right
so i would think at the time at that
time we would want to
maybe revisit that issue then
but you're right it did say the latest
the problem that's happening and
so
if there's a best practices guidelines
set up and
when it's being applied
involving identification of wages there
are so many
loyal procedures well i can go on all
day about it but it just
it can lead to false identifications
very easily
so when you're encouraging the police to
follow the best practices it's to make
the identification as reliable as
possible which would actually support a
conviction not necessarily finding
someone innocent
because that can be for some crimes your
only evidence to link the defendant to
the crime is the identification
if the identification procedure is not
followed correctly
and all of a sudden
that becomes
you know
discredited but now you're most likely
going to have yourself a not guilty when
you may have had a guilty just because
the best practices wasn't followed
or there was a mistake in the
identification i just gave a random
example when i
uh the defendant had appeared well there
was a lineup of eight photos
for the identification process well out
of seven of the photos no one had a beer
so you understand
get it it was like
i said what is this where's waldo i mean
seriously there's not a single person in
the lineup that has a beard
except for the defendant and then
so talk about an easy identification
i just i looked at them like this is
i thought that was an egregious use of
of uh
witness identification and
won't go any further than that
so i'm just explaining it's my opinion
that having a identification procedure
followed
correctly really serves the public it
serves the defendant it serves the
police it serves everyone but why have
best practices if no one's required to
it's just not it's just an idea i mean a
lot of money gets spent putting this all
together implementing the system
if the majority of the police
departments have fallen already
that's great
but that just
they won't they will be unaffected by
this
that's just my thought representative
chestnut
the
your point of order is recognized thank
you i believe you've called on mr
testament before and the whole committee
hasn't had a chance to speak and you're
calling on him a second time
representative marshall you're
the point of all your raising is taken
and that by the way was a correct point
of order because he's actually
discussing the rules of the chair and
whether being followed thank you for
making a correct point of work i do
appreciate that there's been a lot of
misunderstandings and what is and is not
a correct one
the mason's manual does this does
suggest that the
when you call on any
committee member to speak a second time
is
um you're supposed to have
let everyone speak for the first time i
i will say and i'm going to ask i'm
going to plead with you to a drawing
point of order the problem with that is
that you also want to have a healthy
discussion amongst the members as we're
in a executive session because i was
directing my comments and specifically
looking at representative chester and
american birth all the time
i in order to keep that healthy
discussion going i would
clearer for them to respond right away
to those comments i don't mean any
disrespect to any members on the
committee but your point of order is
actually correct
uh
so if you don't withdraw and i'm going
to agree with you and then not recognize
representative testament that have
martin
myself are you withdrawing your point
are you withdrawing your point of order
yeah mr chairman
hi i'm i'm out you were drawing your
point of view
all right i'm going over myself listen
to mars and you're recognized
this isn't my point of order or am i
recognizing i'm recognizing you to speak
now because you haven't spoken yet
thank you i at this time i'll point out
that representative rhodes had her hand
up as well on this particular bill
i'm sorry i'm good
you may be good but your hand was up my
hand was up i noticed okay so my point
on this bill
i asked i always ask myself this first
question i was taught this when i first
came up to the state house
what are you trying to accomplish with
the bill what are you what problem are
you attempting to solve
well as we listen to the testimony
especially from officer
uh testament i may not have his name
quite right here or testimony
he pointed out that the attorney
general's office of new hampshire
has a policy
for how the police department is going
to do it now he cannot as an attorney
general go out to every little town and
village and hamlet and city
and tell them you must follow these
procedures
but they are
clarified they are there
and
like pesto verde said
nashua falls him he believes manchester
follows them being large police officers
the point being
that we're not solving any problem with
that's my question and i
will at the end of it unless i can get
turned over there's no grievance prior
to this in my opinion for anything and
never brought up any case where the
witness in new hampshire
had had a wrong identification
and last but not least
i don't think there's any cost to this
build but
they didn't there's no
no so ultimately in my case and i'm only
going to speak to one time i've seen no
remedy here
and i too
will not vote to ought to pass and will
be willing to make a motion to itl
thank you mr chairman
well there's an active motion on the
floor we're going to see how that works
out
thank you mr chairman i actually
respectfully disagree with a lot of
things been said i
i think that this is a this is a classic
case of
if you fail to plan then
you plan to fail
and just because you don't always have a
situation right here
right now
it's also called being proactive
and
it seems to me that
one thing that is very consistent is
there's a lot of inconsistency
i i personally had a situation where
you know my prior life when i sold real
estate i was you know getting ready to
walk into a vacant helmet as being
somebody was stealing all the copper
and
you know like i looked right the guy and
said oh my gosh like you're are you
seriously stealing the copper
and the guy took off and i had to you
know go identify him like an hour later
and
it was very difficult to do that
you know and i'm reminded of another
situation where
i was um someone was talking to me about
like a study that was done in a room
full of college students that they gave
a situation where it was like a really
stressful situation like a guy came in
it was all like a play
and everybody almost describes something
differently because everybody's brain
thinks differently so
you know some people might notice the
shoes why somebody else notices the hair
i think this actually does solve
a lot of problems that
you don't really know are out there
until it's too late so
ordnay
thank you mr chair
um i will support the ought to pass
but um my preference is that we amend
the bill to
take out the current the date um and
actually
we could back put back the
language of latest version
but
without those changes i'm willing to
support the bill
thank you
thank you representative bourdain i may
inquire of a question
um would you have any opinion on an
amendment that says current as of
would you be willing to
request an amendment and offer that
today
that amendment would
uh put back in
sorry
that would amendment would
remove the strikeout
and uh
thank you representative morning
representative
thank you um
i don't know if this was already said
but i appreciate you hearing uh the
reasons why i'm gonna vote to pass um
the goal i believe of our committee and
our jobs here
is to do our our best
effort
to protect our people
and our police from doing the best jobs
that they can
and
one of the things that came up that was
really
um terrifying that um chairman abbas
brought up is that like
we have the potential here to have
guilty people continue to do the crime
because
we have the wrong people because we
don't have the proper protocols in place
this would protect our police from
making fair
cases and getting the actual criminals
and
make them more prepared so our
criminal justice system is working
efficiently and streamlining across the
entire state and with all due respect to
my colleague across the aisle i feel
like
making sure the state is running
smoothly in every single criminal
justice town and city is the aeg's
responsibility as part of his job
description
so with that i think this is a definite
need
before i recognize
representative chestnut who may want to
respond to my comments so
five minutes ago i get a call and
represent
representative newman
yes mr chairman thank you and my comment
is uh i would think that instead of
having the current
version with a date that just current
version would cover it so that when the
next current version comes out it's
excuse me representative green
thank you mr chair uh reading the
testimony of the chief of police
he was quite thorough in his testimony
and he asked that we itl
[Music]
i recall okay
so it should say
uh latest version
representative welch yes these uh
manuals come up from the aeg office
they don't come out on a regular basis
at one point
earlier
probably 20 years ago
got a collection of them from the ag's
office
and i took them out to the local place
in my my uh
they were anxious to get them because
they hadn't had one for years
i don't have a problem with the date in
here
if we go back to the original
but
you can't expect the ag's office to be
writing these manuals every year because
it doesn't happen
and i think the reason this data's in
here
is because that is the first time
that they caught up with the law that
i just wanted to respond to something
that representative green had said about
chief chester birdie um one of the
things that he did say in his testimony
was that the the courts are already
holding police accountable for these
convictions and if you actually
sort of use the same standard you know
waiting for a case to get to court um
and then uh
trying to create a situation where you
know errors in procedure are kind of
brought up in front of the judge and
things like that i'm not sure that that
happens in every case and that every
lawyer is qualified to do that and um as
representative rhodes and and some of
the other folks have said
i think it's really important to have
those pre-conviction procedures uh
tighten down
uh as as much as we can
and one of the things that we heard
during testimony is that well one of the
ways you know that's happening is when
police departments are responding to the
survey
and because the response to the survey
wasn't that great and one of the police
departments that evidently didn't
respond to the survey was nashua it's
just very hard to know if this is
happening consistently
so to me the remedies seem to be
seem to be a very good idea and uh and
they also
and essentially i think one of the other
things that we heard
is that the vast majority of police
departments are already complying with
this this is not going to have a big uh
a big impact
one way or the other but where it may
have an impact
is on somebody who's improperly
identified aware a procedure has been
used incorrectly
so i'll be voting for it
[Music]
in this session i i heard uh
people say that there are a police in
new hampshire that
in this session i did in testimony i did
not hear anyone testify
that we had police in new hampshire that
did not follow
the ag's memos or procedures
i did not hear any testimony like that
at all i heard
testimony that people didn't respond to
a sermon
but i did not hear any testimony that we
had police
in new hampshire saying
we aren't going to follow the ag's
memories i did not hear that testimony
um
please bear with me if i talk about an
amendment that we don't have in front of
us but it has been discussed
and we ought to be very careful when we
start changing
when we start talking about the printed
manual
because the printed manual comes out
every 10 years and the ag is updating
that manual
he could update that every week
and that updated
his copy of the updated memo by uh
procedures by with this memos
are part of the procedure so it's not
not the printed copy we're talking about
the a.g is updating that every
day he can update that man
i digress
[Music]
a lot of people talking in testimony
about the
faulty eyewitness testimony
this bill
has nothing to do
with faulty
eyewitness testimony
[Music]
it doesn't address it
it doesn't deal with it
eyewitness testimony is faulty in itself
one of the examples they gave was a poor
woman who was being raped and she tried
to concentrate
and and memorize this guy's face
so she and she went and she identified
and she was wrong okay
but none of this
none of this addresses that
none um
because it's not dealing with eyewitness
testimony it was a sad case it has
nothing to do with that bill
um
i heard testimony
um the court shall consider
yeah
the the court may consider yeah that's
all judge's prerogatives
um
so if uh
ability to comply
with the ag's procedures
that is an invisible item intercourse
and that is something that can be
considered
and may weigh
evidence uh at a lower uh value or may
comments were made is there a
demonstrated need
which is always a very important thing
to look at a bill
is there a demonstrated need for this
bill
is there a demonstrated need that we
have procedures that are already being
followed
and if they aren't being followed the
judge
i don't see a demonstrated need
is it already on the books
yes it's already on the books of the
procedure manual
issued by the ag
and all police in new hampshire
as he is the chief of police of new
hampshire
all
police are to follow
there's no demonstrated need
it's already on the box
um i don't see any purpose
for voting otp
on something that already exists
in our state now
and i would vote ipf thank you mr
chairman
thank you representative if i can just
well i'm gonna let representative
customer respond
[Music]
summarized a lot of things
this spill is not
solving a problem it's giving a judge
some instructions
that is not solving a problem
of people supposedly not doing their
jobs if we had any evidence of that we
don't have any evidence of that but you
i just don't see a reason for it
so
let me just explain
what would happen if an office if this
was passed and it's assigned to wall
if
if a police officer just basically does
not follow the procedures as we stated
in the manual from january 2019
the remedy
okay well what they're what they're able
to do in court this is a pre-trial
issue it's just like a motion to
suppress uh you know evidence obtained
through a search warrant that you
believe with outside the scope of the
warrant or the search warrant with
getting a problem cause
what this will do is if they don't
follow that procedure that can be
considered as evidence
to for the judge to consider whether to
suppress the identification
if the judge does not want to suppress
the identification the judge would be
allowed to
provide a specific jury instruction
telling the jury about weighing the
credibility of the
identification
all this is doing is saying and if the
police are following this already that's
great
i don't believe they keep
track of the statistics on how many
motions to suppress are allowed
on suppressing the identifications
because they're so fat specific to why
that particular
identification was suppressed the one
that i
used an example of we never even got
that far to argue with because it was so
egregious
it was just out the door
sometimes that will happen
but
this what this does yeah with an officer
that does not follow this procedure it's
not
that's not the egregious problem it's
just provide it does provide an outline
remedy what to do when that happens
and it leaves the judge of discretion
i would argue that there is some
discretion the judge has already but
this codifies what the judge can can't
do
and that would actually uh
limit the make i think maybe
emotions to suppress easier for the
defense counsel so i think that's
important
so it's the city doesn't have a remedy i
think it does
but to identify the problem
i mean
this is the issues of identifications
this is a problem that happens in every
state and it's it's very common
especially when you're dealing with
someone who doesn't know i mean there's
been a false identification that i've
heard of
that are
he was identified and i was able to
prove he was two hours away
he worked in the medical field so the
medical doctors were time sensitive so
that identification was
not even close whether that witness was
lying or that witness was mistaken
that was really that was really what it
is what the concern was
so it does happen but
following the correct procedure
i believe would be
easier
for law enforcement to really do their
job but also to women to evaluate the
reliability
follow
we're talking about the judge not the
police
we're talking about
the judge has
these various options
he has i'm assuming and i'm not
and don't intend to get into a court of
law
but i'm assuming he has those options
anyway
what am i giving him news he doesn't
have
and why am i telling him how to do his
job
well that's a fair statement but i would
say that applies to all the rules of
veterans
so there are qualified rules and
evidence that apply
and this i think this gives a fair
amount of discretion uh depending on
what how the judge wants to perceive it
and that's really because that's i
believe that's the best way to do it
because the actual
uh
the issue of whether to suppress or not
it's going to be very fact specifically
depending on how egregious the uh
situation was so
i think we've had enough discussion
everyone's had a chance to speak it's
very spoke already you've got your hand
hi where was that new man that's where
would you like to move the question i'm
gonna and for the members i'm only gonna
well
i mean i got new
information i want to say
you do yes
all right representative when you
recognize first
thank you mr chairman i believe i'm
agreeing with the chairman i think that
having a list to go by is something that
helps everybody to do the right thing
the right way and solves the problem
thank you mr chairman um i agree
with everything uh representative true
said and then
my friend representative muse what he
was saying too is that
if i understood them correctly that
the police are following this
so again we come back to why are we
doing this
but the biggest
reason i'm definitely now going to vote
no
is a good friend of mine
a state representative a chairman in
this
building sent me article 23
that does not allow and it was a june
2nd
1784 is when this was uh before
article 23 does not allow us to back
date anything
and this is backdated
in the bill
uh to january 1st 2019 so that's against
the constitution as far as i'm ready so
the exposed fact those thoughts let me
just verify
any rap retroactive retroactive
application of laws
are unconstitutional i agree that
100 right that's the correct statement
of law
and the exposed factors bus is the
federal
constitution also has that so we have it
twice
this is not retroactively going to apply
this does not take effect
this shall take effect 60 days after its
passage so for any mistakes that are
made
60 days after this is signed into law
this is not going to apply to this is
going forward
so
this does not violate that
example of that we had last year was the
the raising the smoking age on tobacco
they wanted to raise the 21.
sounds like a great public health reason
to do so however there was no
uh it would have applied right away or
within a short time period so if you're
20 years old and you had a car with
cigarettes what you legally owned today
would become a crime
right and there was no justice
that's an unconstitutional okay because
now you're
the exposed factor that's the way i
looked at that that was they were not
being compensated they were also being
penalized for something that they were
doing that was legal it's called the
constitutional case to reply
retroactively though would be if you
didn't even have the cigarettes in this
possession anymore but he had them in
this possession you still charge someone
for what they did at the times d
this we're not this is not
charging anyone with something
in the extent that it is we are
you know no no one's been charged with
anything they've already this is this is
going to apply 60 days after it takes
effect it's not applying to anyone
that's been charged already
i agree but we're talented if you don't
mind mr chairman um we're telling the ag
that he has to go back to january 1st
2019 so in my eyes we are
going back to acting no that's the
that's the fate of the man
all right
trust me if if it was written that way i
would have recognized representative
marston
[Music]
and to be honest
that
i would be surprised that though that
there was that egregious constitutional
violation would uh
even be presented
i'm very confident that's not that's not
did you hear me
no
i would like to move the question
the dean of the house might recognize uh
representative pratt for the very last
comment
fine
representative pratt
i just learned
today
oh yeah representative that that
document is actually updated
by attending general so that manual
they're talking about it also says
um the attorney general can update
so uh we are talking about documentation
so fluid documents could change daily
needs time after it changes for
[Music]
consistent with the testimony that's
thank you um i didn't have confusion
around the date
but i'm very clear on the date now that
it is a book that's updated every 10
years
so
for me i believe that you need to keep
the date
because it's not updated for another 10
years so 29 2029
and um
with the testimony from the innocent
group from uh buzz
if there was a change to this piece of
the document
it would have been stated
we had i think four different um emails
sent with with testimony and
all through that document
nothing of any update to this and that's
why they were
expressing that we want this to go
through
because
we've they're people that are not
following
their own policy and practice
so we might not be able we might say
right now today that in new hampshire we
don't know
anyone
that um was affected by this however if
this is made
made law
personally i think you're going to see a
change
and you will know exactly what's
so for those that are afraid i would say
this is a good bill and it really should
be um
in law
as it stands
and um
i would be curious as to what happens
over the next year
and we will still be here together
before everyone starts yelling at me and
say i'm out of order i'm just gonna say
now the chair does although this is not
a public hearing the chair does have any
discretion
to ask a question remember the public of
the president and i see
albert shearer's president i'm going to
ask a single question just one and try
[Music]
as you can hear us talking about this
10-year manual everything's updated
every time
is that a living document to your
knowledge or is it something that's
updated every 10 years
the chair just recognized
mr shearer to just answer that one
specific question
as hard as that is to answer the one
um
the attorney general's office may
send out a memo now and again on a
particular issue but the manual itself
is updated only every 10 years
so therefore you do not believe that to
be a living document
correct
thank
i i think we should move the question
is he standing in the hallway
without the amendment yes
[Music]
right
seeing no hands raised i'm sorry that
took a long less longer than i ever
anticipated
is about the past if you were in favor
chairman welch
aye
representative burke
new
representative hopper no thank you
representative green nay
represent
i'm sorry representative wallace yes
[Applause]
no
the clerk votes yes
representative harriet gaffrey yes
representative pantalakis yes
representative o'hearn
representative
yes
representative muse
representative newman
yes
representative bowden
representative conley yes
yes
representative bradley
chairman abbott
the chair votes yes
mr chairman the vote is thirteen eight
seven nine
by a vote of thirteen days and seven
days the motion taught to pass
yes i am going to make a minority report
at this time we will close the
house bill 436
this time we open the public hearing on
house bill
relative to employment restrictions for
registered sex offenders
[Music]
and this time this year recognizes
yes
representative representative thank you
very much for your patience sorry we
were running behind schedule
[Music]
yeah my pleasure can you hear me
yeah
great thank you so for the record um
representative kevin verville from
deerfield new hampshire representing
rockingham 2
serving the communities of candia
deerfield and nottingham
i'm here today to
present to the committee and thank you
mr chairman members of the committee for
your your time i'm here to present house
bill 408
relative to employment restrictions for
registered sex offenders
um
this bill was filed
at the request of constituents
when you get a chance to check your
email if you haven't already
you'll see there's an email from me uh
citing news clippings from the two cases
that
brought this bill to to ahead so
there was a bit of a loophole in the in
the law regarding uh employment
restrictions on registered sex offenders
uh this bill uh simply fixes
that loophole closes that that loophole
this bill
you know really is not a partisan bill
uh it passed
last year
on on the consent calendar out of the
house and um because of the uh the covet
issue it was laid upon the table in the
senate where it died so the the bill
before you today is the exact same
language
that was agreed upon
a year ago
by a bipartisan subcommittee
this is it was reviewed by at the time
going off memory the state police the
attorney general's office
aclu and so at that time all of this
language was uh
was agreed upon and
uh so like i said this this simply
closes a a loophole um that exists in
the in the current law
and uh with that i'll take any questions
represented true
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question
um i'm not that good on computers so
before i get to your email
yeah so the the
i'm not a lawyer um and lawyers actually
hammered out most of this this language
but it allowed registered sex offenders
um to be employed in jobs which uh had
them on uh repetitive um you know access
to minor children and uh and that that
was sort of the issue the first case um
was revolved around a uh landscaper uh
in deerfield and uh you know the the
court ruled that the registered sex
offender could work as a landscaper
hiring and having direct supervisor
supervisory role um over minor minor
children because the
the language in the law
wasn't clear enough to prohibit it
and that
that occurred back in um
[Music]
give me one second my my apologies i
have too many screens
too many screens open i might have
accidentally closed it well i think it
was around 2018 2019
and then there was a a second case that
ended up coming out and uh that was a
registered sex offender who was a ride
operator at the deerfield fair again
putting him you know uh in a position of
of you know not only repeated contact
with uh with children but you know close
contact uh helping people on and off
rides
etc
and so it's those two uh it's those two
cases that uh that really
brought to light the need to clean up
thank you representative
representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you
what happens in need to protect children
at all costs but what happens if this
individual works at
you know shaw's
hannaford's mcdonald's uh market basket
uh convenience store i mean there's kids
running around those places all the time
um
you know what would happen in that case
that this
proposed law restrict that
um i i apologize to representative uh
true uh thank you for your question and
representative brett thank you for your
question um so the the answer is is the
most definite maybe and and the reason i
say that is it really depends on um what
the job is right so the the law is being
tightened up um
so that
a registered sex offender cannot
knowingly engage in any employment or
volunteer service
which purpose involves the direct care
instruction
guidance
or repeat interaction with a minor so
not it's not
it's not that there may be many uh
interactions individual interactions
with um children with minors
it's the repeat
interaction with a minor
so if if the person is is you know a
manager of a department that is staffed
you know with a minor
then no that person couldn't do that job
because that's the direct supervision
right direct care instruction guidance
um over of a minor so
so no they couldn't do that now you know
could they could they be a a grocery bag
or or a cashier um yes as long as the
other person or people working that
station
were not uh were not miners
i hope that answers your question if it
doesn't i'll take the follow-up
certainly
yes if i could representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
you know these people have to work
somewheres and usually if you have a
conviction i'm assuming you're working
at a lower paying job
um which possibly would be mcdonald's
but i did see 13 an hour
um
offered but
you know i i guess
you know how would we regulate that
you know so the individual doesn't lose
his you know to end back up in jail once
he's
you know served his time
um you know if he was working at
mcdonald's because there is a lot of
kids there
but she's trying to name any uh
businesses or franchises specifically
just sent the wrong implies the wrong
message i understand why i'm using a
hypothetical all right your reference to
the business was only a hypothetical yes
password
yeah thank you representative for the
follow up
so
for for one thing i will not
um i will not agree with the supposition
um that people
right under the registered sex offender
program are necessarily um in lower
paying jobs i i don't i don't believe
the
intent of the bill
is not to deny people
a right to work a right to earn a living
and
and to participate
in society
the intent of the bill
is to make sure
that registered sex offenders
that are not supposed to be
near minors
are not employed
in occupations
[Music]
that
engages
which the purpose involves a direct care
instruction guidance
or
repeat
interaction
with a minor so
that the the person should not be
holding a job
where they have repeat interaction with
a minor
now
sexual offenses are varied and i'm
certainly not an expert in that area but
one of the things that that we know and
i believe is is common knowledge or at
least relatively common knowledge
if sexual predators
often groom their victims
before the crime is perpetrated
and the grooming activity
takes place over a period of time over
multiple
dare i say repeat interaction
with fed miners so this bill prohibits
that that opportunity to be made
available to a registered sex offender
so it it it doesn't preclude them from
holding a job which has interaction with
interactions or potential interactions
with minors what it prohibits is that
repeat
interaction with a minor so that they're
not
working with that same person you know
each day or each week or each month and
and the the intent of that is to make
sure that that sort of grooming and
communication um
pathway
is is not allowed to to create itself
that's that's the intent of the bill and
and that was you know
i believe that was the intent of the
original law right was to to prohibit
this this type of employment
it not only protects the children i mean
clearly that's our priority here but it
also protects the registered sex
offender
by um
preventing them from being in you know a
a situation that
potentially could make recidivism um
that much easier so this this really
benefits
both populations
thank you for clarifying that that makes
a lot of sense
representative pandalagas
thank you mr chairman
thank you for taking my question what
you are
are you saying
that these people should not be in
uh thank you for the question
representative and it's a good question
and absolutely not i am not saying that
they shouldn't be uh that they should
i'm not saying they should be precluded
from management positions but they
should be precluded from managing minors
right because if you're managing
somebody that is a position that
requires repeat interaction with the
employee
and if the employees are minors then
that
is not management position uh for a
registered sex offender so um you know
if they're managing the accounting
department which presumably would be
staffed um with adults
there's there's no issue there but to to
have them uh be the manager of you know
cashiers or or stocking clerks things
jobs like that that are often uh staffed
by miners that that would not be that
would simply not be appropriate
thank you
representative
thank you mr chairman and uh
thank you for uh allowing or for taking
my question um
one of the things just looking at the
way that the the bill is worded um
the
language is being struck uh
used to seems to have taken an approach
before of specifically naming
the professions that would be impacted
or the types of jobs that would be
impacted
the the changes
make it must make it much less uh make
it i'm sorry make it much more ambiguous
and
i i'm wondering
how you think a person would know
if they were in a job that
they shouldn't be if they had this kind
yeah thank you for the question
representative so
um the
when i originally filed the bill um
that those exemplars
um were not crossed out and
that that was a decision that was made
by the subcommittee uh in the previous
term and again this this bill this bill
passed
last year unanimously through the
committee and on a voice vote on the
floor of the house
it was decided by the subcommittee at
the time
that
to make these examples because it's it
both strikeouts start with including but
not limited to
and so
the question was should there be such a
laundry list
provided because it's not it's not
that list is not a narrowing of the
scope of the bill
it was included language originally to
sort of illustrate examples but it they
both places it struck out it starts
including but not limited to
and so it it was believed by last year's
subcommittee that it actually made the
bill more confusing to include that sort
of laundry list of um
of occupations
registered sex offenders when uh when
they're released right and and are
allowed to enter into society um
they
they have people that explain to them
the do's and the don'ts right that they
have to follow um going forward so a
registered sex offender
if they move from uh one community to
another right they have a specific
amount of time at
in which they must notify that they've
moved right they have to notify the
authorities so all of these and that's
that's just a restriction on registered
sex offenders there's a there's a lot
there's a lot of them
because i village residents
i'm sorry i i've got somebody coming
over on the audio
um so
this is this is simply another um
restriction and
it was um
if that and that's why the um in part
two paragraph b
um was was added as an extra protection
really for the for the for the
registered sex offender um you know that
they would be notified upon employment
um of this of this prohibition so you
know we're trying to to protect
everybody we're not trying to to create
added penalties we're we're really just
trying to make sure that you know the
registered sex offender is not put into
a position that um you know could
potentially cause them to backslide if
you will um and obviously the primary
reason for the restriction is to protect
minors
the most vulnerable uh in our in our
community and so that that's why the
subcommittee last year had chosen to to
strike the laundry list
follow up please
represent you recognize for a follow-up
you for the explanation um
that was very good um
i just wanted to confirm that the bill
from last year that we're talking about
is hb 1462 which was actually heard by
the labor committee not by criminal
justice is that correct
uh thank you for the question
representative um yes that was the bill
number um and that was the committee
that it had been assigned to um last
term i i never i i never said that this
committee is is who heard it last year
um so i i apologize i didn't i didn't
make that clarify uh that that clear in
my my opening remarks but yes you you
are absolutely correct in both of those
points
thank you
representative
thank you mr chairman thank you
the risk of what hipping this uh bill
something i don't like when people do
mine and i'm trying to do it but what
would happen if this passes to people
who already
hold positions that would be covered
under this bill
um
who are to the best of anyone's
knowledge not doing anything illegal or
on board towards minors with interact
would they be forced would they lose
their jobs or
so if if the
if the bill is is passed as it's before
us um it would take
take effect uh next january first
and at which point yes if a registered
sex offender
is
in an occupation
that gives them repeat interaction with
a minor
that yes they would have to they would
crawley you're recognized for a
follow-up question thank you mr chairman
representative thank you um
i guess again along those same lines of
impacts on labor in the event that one
of these individuals
holding a position where they are not
interacting with minors
and then a minor is hired by someone
other than them
is again the individual
uh thank you for the question
representative it's uh certainly an
interesting
hypothetical
um the registered sex offender is
required to notify their employee
employer of their status as a registered
sex offender
and so
the hiring and firing decisions by any
business are made by the business owners
or or managers
so
um
yes it's it's not impossible to conceive
that a business may choose to
hire a minor into a position
and if the manager of that position was
a registered sex offender they would no
longer be
representative marston
thank you mr chairman
and thank you
representative for taking my question
um of which i have
two and hopefully i'll be recognized for
further
uh
in the first place i'm questioning
the validity of
the last time i said according to you of
striking out
all of that stuff about
you know
including but not limited to
and then you went on and stated a lot
which i've seen before in many instances
on different things that you really want
to be sure you know that teachers
coaches
little league people like that people
that work at camp counselors and scout
masters and girl scout masters
school administrators
why are you striking that out instead of
more or less leaving it in to amplify
that you don't want them around those
kids
yes thank you for the question
representative again
um
the bill was submitted by me last year
and the committee referred it to
subcommittee for work and it was the
decision of the subcommittee not my
decision again the these strikeouts were
not struck out in the original
submission of the bill last year
it was the subcommittee that chose to
strike that laundry list
that subcommittee had a working
working session
um at which
the
the people it attended was a
subcommittee myself representatives from
state police representatives from
attorney general um attorney general's
office with specific expertise in this
in this area
the american civil liberties union and
so um
quite a bit of thought and discussion
went into um the changes the the
basically the amendment to the bill
that i originally
submitted and and it was that
subcommittee that chose
to strike that language
so whether that language
is struck
and and to make sure we're being
specific starting uh near the end of
as well as
the end of 17
and 18
it has no effect
on the what the bill does right it it is
simply um
language that lists
examples
so whether that language is in or out
does not change the effect of the bill
representative marston you're recognized
for a follow-up question
thank you and i appreciate your comments
to that extent uh
if i were to consider this bill i would
like to see an amendment put in that
would make those changes back
pick out those lines struck i also do
like the idea that you have a
section two b
which states about what the public and
private employer shall do
and i think that's that's a great
piece of legislation going forward that
states they got to make sure if they
have they can't hire somebody if they
got kids involved but it doesn't get
into
uh it does make private or public and
i'm just saying that i think what you're
doing is trying to restrict employment
and
with that being said i'd like to see the
lines put back in
where would you concur
[Music]
was there a question
yeah at the end i said would you concur
that's a question with the statement
okay thank you
um
thank you for the question
representative um so to be fair um i i
appreciate the compliment on
section two part b
um that language was actually um from a
former state rep from i believe
brookline um
who who crafted that language and the
next time i see him i'll be
if the question if i understand the
question correctly and if i don't please
let me know
the question is would i as the prime
sponsor of the bill
be open to
removing the strikeout that starts at
the end of nine and goes through 12
and removing the strikeout that begins
basically halfway through 17 and goes
through 18.
if that's the question then my answer
would be
yes it would not bother me if if a
committee member
filed an amendment to
put that language back in to remove that
strikeout because it has no effect
on the working of the bill
the only thing i would caution
i tended to agree
with the subcommittee
and with the the other uh experts
a year ago
that the the bill is
more clear
and cleaner without that language in it
but i would not be opposed to that
language being put back in as it's shown
on on
the paper in front of us
um thank you
um thank you for taking my question
at the very end um paragraph three
roman numeral
is
only two
teachers
is there was this whole situation
thank you for the question thank you for
the question if you could just give me
uh one because this is
okay it's a very serious matter if you
give me one second just to re-read
paragraph three so i can answer
intelligibly i would
be obliged
please take your time you may read the
paragraph
so the the answer is um
no so
this
this bill
um
[Music]
let me gather my thoughts one second my
apologies
paragraph three
is already a part
of rsa so
um
the bill is not whole claw the bill
um was to modify
existing rsa
and so
what we're doing
is
because this this this is um
a10 right 632-a colon 10. that's the
part of the rsa that we're changing the
the
crossouts
remove language from the existing
rsa
the bold is
inserting new language
into the rsa
and that language which um is in um you
know a normal sort of 12-point font
is already existing law so so three
pre-existed
the bill last year and pre-exist
this this bill so
it doesn't it doesn't change it
that the two cases that that
made my constituents request this bill
to be filed
did not revolve around
educators
certified or otherwise
ride i forget amusement amusement park
thank you chair
um thank you representative revell i do
you currently know how many sex
offenders there are employed in the
state of new hampshire
thank you for the question i do not
so potentially follow-up sir
thank you you're recognized for a
follow-up question
so potentially
we have no idea
how many of these people will be
immediately unemployed and have zero
resources available in place or
structure set up for situational
or do you sorry do you have any
resources available or protocols put in
place from for maybe a lot of people
that we could be putting in
a homelessness situation a starvation uh
situation or any of these situations
that they that might be out of their
control once we
um discontinue their employment across
the entire state
thank you representative so you've asked
me three questions
um similar but different so which which
question
if i could take them one at a time if
you could if you could give me your
questions one time
no if you could re-articulate a question
that i could answer i would be obliged
this answers the question
and i apologize to the chair please ask
one question at a time
everyone remember the committee you
eliminated two questions your witness at
the approach of the chair
president you already asked one question
of this witness earlier
so please just ask a single question
within the chair discretion to
doesn't state have
any available resources
for an unknown number that you want to
make a law for to provide
in the after effect that they will be
unemployed
thank you for the question um
one
i will i will suppose
that the number of individuals that this
bill
will impact
will likely be
limited
and
i make that statement going off memory
of discussions from over a year ago um
primarily from the representatives from
i believe it was the aclu
um it might have been a different group
that sort of tracks and and works with
these people
there's been two cases brought
it seems very limited in scope
the state
does have
resources
and makes resources available
to
poor
to needy
to unemployed
and to indigent
persons
we have we have a fantastic food bank
communities have food pantries
um
there's there's other there's other
welfare programs
uh that are available to people in need
and so to to answer the question does
the does the state have programs uh to
take care of people that that may uh
lose their job for whatever reason the
thank you everyone on the committee's
exhausted big questions representative
owen thank you for your testimony and
for fielding
more questions than i can count
yeah thank you mr chairman thank you uh
members of the committee i i appreciate
uh the very good questions i appreciate
your time i know you're running uh a
little late and i know you you probably
want to get to launch because you have
some more public hearing so uh thank you
for your time and i look forward to
thank you representative
witness is excused the channel
thank you mr chairman mr chairman i'm
going to try to be brief on this here i
first uh for the record representative
al
baldus our rockingham county district 5
which is londonderry
i first want to say i want to compliment
the chair last year
um who uh matter of fact brian sullivan
that did a great job on the subcommittee
on this bill on making the proper
changes
because they're the ones the committee
there that made that deal with labor all
the time
and these here these different cases
understand and knew the needs for this
bill so i have to compliment them
because
like representative revell said this
wasn't him that made those changes this
one bill was in the hands of the
committee okay it was very definitely
non-partisan but i complement the chair
because he was the one that really
pushed and did a great job but anyways
this here bill is more of a housekeeping
bill
cleaning up the language tightening up
the language uh with many hands in it to
make sure that the language was proper
i think it's a good bill it makes sense
and if you take a look at i use
manchester for any area
um they were asked how many people um
while you were talking i did a google
search on uh
you know uh sexual offenders in new
hampshire and the first thing that
popped up was 2500 in manchester
okay uh and then i'm sure i have about
15 in my district here in londonderry
but the bottom line is they already know
per other laws that are out there uh
that they do not work with minors they
do not uh hang out with minors they do
not try to groom miners okay that that
stuff's already another laws because i
believe there's about another five or
six laws that pertain to um predators
so
what is very important as a former human
resource manager when i retired from the
marine corps was
section b
which is important because this is
something that human resource management
under hiring people should say that a
public or private employer shall either
verbally are in writing
advise an applicant for an employment or
volunteer position that position applied
for me involved contact with miners
which may be prohibited under the
section if the applicant was convicted
in this way okay just any jurisdiction
uh any of the offenses specified in
paragraph for this section
that was dissected with the committee
last time and they came up with some
great language which they're cutting off
the past they're actually doing the job
of the parole officers because the
parole officers already know
that there are people that they're
watching in supervising do not get jobs
with children so that's already done new
hampshire is a great record of
protecting the children democrats and
republicans uh in the labor and in
criminal throughout the years of my time
have done an awesome job even in
children and family law
so
this language
already passed it would have already
been in law if culver didn't come
forward because it already passed the
house
we all supported it on both sides so i'm
hoping that
we move forward with this bill pass it
one more time and let's let's it's a
children's protection bill basically and
it's just reinforcing the laws that are
already in place and that's all i have
thank you representative for your
testimony representative marston you're
recognized for a question thank you mr
chairman thank you mr barbasaur
representative bonisal for your
testimony
my question is only one as it stands
right now
the lines the line item from 9 through
and then the other one in 17
that's i looked it up i went into the
rsa book and those are in the
rsa
and you're crossing them out and i'm
asking you if you would be okay if we
don't cross those out leave them in and
bring along the new part to the law
which is b and all of that you
understand my question sir i fully
understand your question i want to thank
you for the question yeah i mean that's
fine you could do that but what you're
doing is you're you're changing all
these duty experts that came in
and came up with this language
you know uh and worked with the labor
department under chairman sullivan there
and uh you know which came up with a
great bill and they thought the words
that were in there
you know they tightened it up so if you
want to open it back up and make a
little more confusing uh with more
language in there that's fine i i
respect
whatever you want as long as we're
representative pandalakis
thank you mr chair
thank you representative for taking my
question
this really clarifies this bill really
clarifies
miners which is supposed to be in it
anyway and the other language that was
in there was very confusing
am i right i thank you for the question
now representative you are 100 right
because i think even ben berudi and you
know the other republicans on that
committee there thought the same thing
why it was important to them to change
it
representative gabriel
um
i'm trying to remember
when we kind of went through this last
term and i guess there's different
and what have you so
if i remember correctly i think there
was a bill that talked to this a little
bit but it also talked to the different
degrees that a person
and i don't remember what the numbers
were whether it was like a degree one
two three or something like that
that
allowed sex offenders to do certain
things based on whatever level they were
if i remember something like that
do you know if any anything like that
i i remember um
something like that i think
representative penalakis are probably no
better than i am since she's she's kind
of one of the grooves there and criminal
law and had a probably better memory
than i do so i know there was something
that came further on the different
stages of groups within the sexual
predator um law but i i'd be lying to
you if i try to even come up with
something to remember
all right
thank you i think that needs a little
representative pantologis you have your
welcome before
thank you chairman
and thank you dear for taking my
question
the other representative said these
people that would lose their jobs have
amazing social systems and you just gave
us a figure of about was it 2500 or was
it
2500 that i got off of the um incident
yes thank you so much so the number that
was on a question that was a statement
that you gave to us
and that fear i'm very thankful for but
are you aware since you are
um looking up manchester statistics are
representative i've been working with
the homeless for um 15 years um work
with homeless veterans we got about
almost 450 veterans off the street to
hud uh certificates to the bash program
so i'm very aware of that i also know
that we got many homeless that don't
want to go off the street i also know
that i've gone around with people
counting homeless throughout the years
that are out there and help
yes i'm probably one of the duty experts
when it comes to homeless here in the
state
for answering
i see no hands raised i will thank the
representative of legendary first time's
testimony answering our questions
thank you mr chairman have a great day
committee
seeing no hands raised
at this time
the chair will we will close the public
hearing
[Music]
representative much you want to do the
honors
yes on h bill on hb 40
408 we had one person sign in in support
one person signed in in opposition and
we had one person sign in as neutral
okay
thank you
if there's any members of the public who
have not testified already
please rate please raise your hand
see no hands raised the public hearing
my name is rebecca edelenel i'm a
sergeant with the state police unit
commander for the sex offender registry
i just wanted to be available for any
questions that may come up i know there
was some discussion about the number of
sex offenders the number that are
employed and so if there's any questions
that i can answer i want to be available
for that
well i'll make it easy i'll ask a
question
thank you for the thank you for your
testimony
i've been thankful for taking my
questions
do you have any information on the
amount of registered sex offenders in
the state of new hampshire that are
currently employed
so i am i've reached out to our i.t
department to get specifics on their
employment and the unemployment rate i
can tell you that we have about 2900
sex offenders within the state of new
hampshire not just in manchester but
throughout the entire state
manchester alone has about 400
i can tell you that there's about
27 of our offenders in manchester that
are homeless
but i can
until i get the numbers specifically
from our i.t department who need to pull
that from our database the majority of
our offenders are employed
and are employed in various ways whether
it's construction
to
um a service of other kinds of vehicle
service in in other areas where they may
come in contact with children on a
regular basis
certainly one of the areas to think
about is a convenience store you have
children walking into a convenience
store
every single day after school the same
convenience store they're going to see
the same people working there so that's
the type of interaction you're looking
at with this bill and we have many
offenders that are employed in in those
types of situations
[Music]
representative hoffer you're right ask
for a question yeah thank you mr chair
just ask the uh witness what um
in the case of a convenience store
if this bill passes would that mean that
that person would be in violation of the
law
so i think one of the things to think
about with a bill like this it's all
about interpretation if someone is
charged and arrested then it's going to
be how it's interpreted through the
court procedure through the jury through
the judge whoever is handling that case
if if you say a repeat interaction and
somebody is in in the convenience store
every single day
buying a candy bar after school and that
person is selling them
a candy bar that is a repeat interaction
with a child now it's not involving the
care instruction or guidance of minor
children which is what the current law
thank you
representative bolden
[Music]
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question i'm sorry if this was
already covered today
but um can you tell me of the 2900 in
the state how many
were um convicted of crimes involving
children
because as i as i understand it it's
possible to be a
registered sex offender for crimes that
do not involve children
that is correct we do have adult victims
um
it is
roughly around
two-thirds of that number
um if i i would have to do some research
to get the exact numbers but it's around
um
around
freaky
that's a question
representative gabriel
um thank you chair thank you for taking
my question
really i was trying to determine i i
think that sex offenders have
certain levels
of
um based on their crime i believe
that's correct we tier offenders in new
hampshire so it's tier one tier two and
tier three
uh tier one
offenders are mostly misdemeanor
offenses
uh and then tier two and tier three
would all be felonies
um
with generally victims under the age of
13.
thank you
[Music]
sorry
thanks for taking my question and thank
you chairman
i really appreciate you having that data
pulled up
um
as
the numbers you just gave us
uh
this i just want to clarify as this was
written this is this was
um determined as a housekeeping bill
would would any of these those people be
in danger of losing their jobs if this
i mean i can't say whether or not they'd
be in danger of losing their jobs again
it would be all interpretation if if an
employer can justify that the you know
an example that i i think of a lot is a
farm hand we have a lot of offenders who
are farm hands and within the state you
also have a lot of children and children
group child groups that go to farms to
for school trips for birthday parties so
whether or not that
employer can justify that there would be
no interaction with children
he has to determine if he's gonna
keep that person employed or not
uh follow-up chair for me
you're recognized for a follow-up
question
thank you
so as this bill is written now it
doesn't clearly determine
the guidelines for protecting people
that are in rehabilitative cert like
they're getting their lives together
versus people that are actually
i think that it's it's open for
if you change it from what it currently
is it is certainly open for
interpretation um i think that the word
the phrase specifically repeat
interaction
if it was repeat interaction
with the purpose of direct care
instruction or guidance that's more
clear but because it separates direct
care instruction guidance or repeat
interaction
that can be interpreted many different
ways
seeing no hands raised i want to thank
the witness
for
for taking our questions and providing
l and i'm the unit commander for the sex
seeing no further hands raised
at this time the public hearing on
we're going to oppose the public hearing
at this time
we will if we open the executive session
the chief will recognize representative
ruins to make a motion
thank you mr chairman i make the motion
of lots of pass for telstra 408.
that's it welsh oh there
thank you
i now open the
representative
thank you mr chairman i
know a person
a person as an adult
has
a hard enough time being able to put
pieces together and
move about their daily lives after a
sexual
assault let alone a child that is just
probably so ungodly confused on what has
happened and why this happened
any future children from
from being a victim of this genius crime
and
and he is allowed to participate in the
vote because he was in his seat
prior to
us
calling the question so
we'll just clarify that now
representative marston you're
recognizing the chairman i just have a
question
we're doing 408
yes
and that bill is in regards to what i i
didn't understand what the
representative rhodes was saying so it
didn't make sense to me because i don't
have the bill in front of me i have
another chance to pull it back up but
what are we dealing with
sex offenders
[Music]
oh
okay before i
um thank you
uh so
i think this is very serious and i want
to go on public record saying that
i
thank you i want to say that um this is
a very serious matter
and i
this is a personal matter
uh i do take this very serious
but
trying to be a representative that's
fair
and
uh
also represent other people that have
rights especially if they paid their
time
and they are working without any
problems i just don't think that this is
clear on the consequences that would
happen to their lives
and i don't think that's fair
um i think this bill needs to be
retained and worked on and that's why i
can't support this motion not because
that i don't think this is a very
extremely important issue i do thank you
professor representative martin
thank you mr chairman
uh i i i wonder if we got a report from
mr representative muse on the support
and opposed on it you did
the numbers may i have one one one
one
one opposing one neutral thank you
that's a new organized yes
if they do not strike out if they do not
return to the original rsa
which has these those wordings in it
from line
uh
on down through 12 and then again i
looked it up 17 and so forth
if they don't
[Music]
leave them in the log which is there now
by
breaking all of this out
i go along with what the b is i think
the the section two b with the public
and private employer et cetera et cetera
et cetera i like that in there
but if you're not if you if you're
crossing out all that stuff up above
it's in the law now
that causes me to to not vote in favor
and would i be willing to make an
whoever did it
anytime you create a list in a bill with
penalties you're going to leave
something out
even though it does say in here
uh
[Music]
kind of uh yeah it says notwithstanding
yeah but
you create you create a list you're
gonna leave something out
and i've always felt as though it's
better to get the the
broad
brush approach
and this is really what happens if they
eliminate the list and they put in
but that is a there was a point of order
on that earlier today so we're not going
to follow that strict descent so i'll
get called out again
representative
it is with fear and trepidation i will
speak on this because i don't have the
gift of gab
i've never kissed the blinny stone and i
don't express myself very well
i wish to address
is it on the books
yeah it's on the box already this whole
thing is already on the box
is it enforceable
i'll get back to that point
uh
sexual assault uh number number one a
person is guilty of a class a felony uh
a child abuse sexual sexual child abuse
all right some words were crossed out
that that's already on the books
there's a class a poem we're all in
agreement with that
the changes
i don't see why they're needed
[Music]
um
part two
a person is guilty of a class b felony
if
after having been convicted
he knowingly fails to provide that
information
so you can add more words to that
from here until eternity
what we are left with as not on the
books
is a public or private employer shall
either verbally or in writing advise an
applicant
employment a volunteer position
blah blah blah
that is a horrible thing to put in law
a public a private employer shall either
verbally or in writing now there's
there's something that will keep lawyers
employed uh for their entire lives they
can argue those well did he say it
verbally did he say just a horrible
horrible thing
other than the stuff that's already in
the books
we're left with
this meaningless statement
of public or private employers shall
verbally
advise and operate
they shall verbally advise an applicant
this bill says he must have already told
them
about the information of his fire
conviction
so the applicant must
tell the employer
i was guilty of uh
i'm
convicted of sexual offense
and then the employer must say have you
other than the stuff that's left on the
books
we're left with
nonsense
in my opinion and for that reason i
could not support
this bill as as it's changing the irs
thank you miss
mr chairman
very much um
i'm actually going to support the bill
because i think it's more protective of
children i also know that we have a
separate rsa
651 which actually
gets into the different tiers of sexual
offenders so
people who've been convicted of
felonious sexual assault
and felony level sexual assault crimes
are on the list
for life
people who are convicted of the
misdemeanor crimes are on the list for
10 years
i think as long as you're on that list
you're potentially a danger to children
i i don't have a problem with the way
that this law defines or with the way
with the way this bill um actually
defines the offenders i think the the
bigger issue may be with the other rsa
and whether or not we actually have a
good process to get people on and off
that list
but that's a separate issue
[Music]
well right now i'm not sure if i support
it or or i don't support it um
but what i have taken the time to do is
read
the letter from the department of
corrections
and they were the ones that were neutral
but they shared the same concerns as the
commander
of sex offenders register rebecca
and the concern was
the open interpretation particularly
around
repeat the terminology repeat
and that's a concern to me as well when
i look at to read this because we keep
in mind that yeah we send people off to
jail
but on the same token
we it's supposed to be rehabilitated
to come back out into the out into the
world
and when people come back out into the
whether their sex offenders whatever
they've done
wrong
um there's
so much set up to help them to
restart their life
so when you say
a year from now that if someone working
in the grocery store and where kids come
all the time
they no longer have that position i
would have a problem with that
because i look at it as um and i and i
suggest that you do take the time to
read the comments that they put in here
even though they were neutral the real
concern was that
we spend a lot of money to rehabilitate
people
and we send them back out
and hopefully have them continue
rehabilitation
and um so i don't know i i'm struggling
with that and mainly because of the what
who's going to call
the situation a repeat
you know
do they have the best judgment of it you
know i
it's kind of like a slippery slope in my
opinion that we could be dealing with
so what i can say is looking at this the
first thing is i
i understand there's some concerns that
people might lose their job i understand
these concerns
with how that will affect especially in
an economy like you're dealing with now
especially during a pandemic
i
with that point take into consideration
this bill is
designed
to protect children i think the
representative verbal and he testified
did a
excellent job explaining the psychology
that goes behind how this offense is
often committed it's not committed the
first second third time someone
interacts with a child it's who's it's
it's
planned over a longer period of time
what i understand that
child predators they actually
they literally
scope out children that are vulnerable
to take advantage of and to exploit
so what this says is
they will prevent the repeat
interactions with a mom so if you work
in a grocery store
on the loading dock in the back of the
store
there's not any perceivable situation
that i can see where that person would
interact with the child never mind
repeat interactions with the same child
i'm not sure why a child would be on the
loading dock or girls
is the interaction with the child if
your job duties require you
to interact with the child
uh that's different
i would say like a daycare for example
probably not the best place to have a
child sex predator be working i would
hope there's already a lot of books
preventing that but
by listing
professions you've now narrowed the way
that's often interpreted by course is
that the legislative intent to narrow
the scope of its application
that's why you don't want to have the
list because if you were you're going to
forget something we can sit here for two
days straight come up with all the
places that we don't feel that a child
predator or child sex offender should be
working now i don't we put the smartest
people in the state all in a room we're
going to forget
so
this leaving an open-ended allows
the discretion to include stuff in case
there is something
you want to include any profession
period if you regularly interact with
the child
and having the employer know about that
know about the person's history
that goes to liability now the employer
can't say i didn't know the employee
still wants to hire the hire the child
sex offender
or a child rapist or whatever that's
that's their
i mean
that now they know they can't say they
didn't know
so i would certainly uh
i believe this is a very good
bill that passed on consent last year
it passed out of i believe it passed on
the labor committee 19 to one or there's
on the consent calendar
uh i'm
i understand the concerns people have
but i think this strengthens it doesn't
necessarily create new law but it's
strengthening and clarifying existing
law on a very important subject and i
would hope that i would be supporting
representative green
thank you i have a question for you i
was late getting in and what was the
status of the state trooper
on this bill
i don't know
i don't think they they took a position
they just offered to answer questions to
help answer any concerns
representative
thank you mr chairman um
i think there's a strong argument here
for retaining this bill i think
collectively we all
strongly support the concept
um
there were some problems identified one
people losing their jobs through no
fault of their own
since they come out of prison
or whatever the adjudication process was
um
and then we would just
limit where they could work moving
forward i've heard that potential
impacts with people's livelihoods
we also know um
just through the data and through the
statistics that
uh one's co-worker is often not a
you know it's more often than not family
or a friend of the family
we heard that two-thirds of these
um crimes are committed against children
under 13.
a horrible statistic there ever was
but under this law we would then be
limiting where the other served the
people who did not commit that attack
can work
and we are
uh well i'll say that so i guess i would
say
i'm not going to support this now i want
to support it
thank you chairman
um
i will be supporting this bill um
i
appreciate that it's more broad in scope
and doesn't list out
um
certain situations so
i think it's a strong bill and i think
that the importance here is really
protecting
i get a regular
update for the my city
and the sex offenders who happen to show
up in the last week or so
and i am
appalled at the number i see who come in
who
in most cases have an interaction with
some child under the age of 13.
and
people will tell you that they've
already served their time they've
rehabilitated
as i understand that's not true
and i think this bill is really
important i think we ought to pass it
you know retain it whatever people want
to do
i think that's the wrong thing because
essentially we're saying
uh
the kids
are not near as important as the
representative
thank you mr chairman um
mr chairman i i think it's no secret
that
i have resisted many times
to
enhance you know
like from
lower crimes up to class a mr felonies
and etc
but i don't think
this bill
is outreach
i think it protects children i think it
protects
the
child predator person
um i'm going to support the bill because
i just think that it is the right thing
to do for the children of new hampshire
representative pratt
uh
last 29 years
the president scientists out of the boys
i know background checks that i've had
to do
you'd be surprised how many people have
come forward sex offenders that haven't
been told they've been through the
they didn't tell us some of them haven't
registered locally now which is supposed
to be
trouble for the planet with us
but um i think it's taking up a lot of
time
thank you thank you i think in seeing uh
representative
representative hopper yeah just quick um
i'm i'm not sure how i'm gonna go thank
you mr chair
we're gonna find out soon
uh
guidance or repeat interaction
with a child minor
and if you go down to the bottom of the
thing it basically means uh
put some of the responsibility on
employers also
so if i was running a had a convenience
store
in manchester and i found out one of my
employees regardless of how good he was
or she was
i would fire them
[Music]
just on the up just for the
liability probability
that something did happen
even though that like it was already
said
most sex offenders are
are
[Music]
abusing children that they're related to
and or close members of the family it's
not
i don't know of any instance where a
store clerk
offended uh
there probably is nationwide but
probably pretty rare
so i don't know i really
i don't know but i really don't like
the ambiguity and that
that part of the bill
it seems like that should be uh clinched
i believe everyone has now spoken with
i also don't remember so this is the
thank you mr chair i was originally
concerned about the paragraph that
required the notification by the
employer
but i noticed for the other paragraphs
there are penalties assigned when when
those are violated but in that section
there is no penalties so if the
they should be doing that but if they
inadvertently don't do that i don't
believe there's a penalty to the
employer and if it gives the defense
lawyer something to work with then so be
it that i think i'm going to support
the clerk will now call the role if
you're in in favor
are in support of a motion about to pass
please say yay if you are opposed please
vice chairman welch aye
representative burke yes
representative hopper yes
representative green yes
representative wallace yes
representative testerman yes
representative true okay
representative pratt yes
representative marston
may
the clerk votes yes
representative harriet gaffrey
no
representative pantalakis
yes
representative board may
representative muse
yes
representative klein knight
no
representative bradley
yes
chairman abbas
the chair votes yes
mr chairman the vote is 15-6
by a vote of 15 years
in
report
something's getting held up okay
question
you have a parliamentary inquiry
uh we we might be you know we could
answer uh get to another executive
session quickly a quick one
not only but okay what's the question
did you say you would write a report and
uh
i just said that someone would write it
i think
oh i'm sorry that's a conversation that
can happen at any other period of time i
wasn't here i don't know i understand
but let me just let me just
let's just keep it moving because that's
a
at this time we can close the public uh
the executive session on house bill
408.
um
[Music]
okay
this line we are
you're opening the executive section on
the chair is recognizing representative
are you making the most of them
correct me if i'm wrong
but we on february 10th
i know what we'll call the exact date
but
we have we've had a public hearing on i
was killed
six points
in my my understanding that there was a
desire to present an amendment
due to our kind constraints in this
committee which i have
expressed to this uh committee members
several times over
we are under time constraints uh it's
unlikely we would be able to get the
amendment in on this bill
being able to do the work on that it
deserves it was requested to be retained
so they can at least be
assigned a subcommittee to work on the
summertime i believe that that's a very
fair request
of the members of the command
who want to work on something
but as you can tell there's something
else we just as we're limited on what we
can meet on what we can do
so the chair will be supporting the
representative marston thank you mr
chairman
looking back at my notes now that i have
a chance and i know what we're talking
about
i found some problems with this build
and i found the fact that
there was some consideration there would
be some consideration to itl this rather
than retain it
and if we retain it at some point in the
future can we then ipl
correct we can and i will say that if if
this bill is not retained i would be
supporting an itl but speaking with
members of the committee
i i
want to work on this issue with faith
and i believe that the bill itself is
well intended does have problems and by
retaining it it will allow those members
the opportunity to work on the very
after that subcommittee which will
probably be during the summer time into
the fall if we have an executive session
then
i think we may probably have a different
looking bill by then
thank you for the clarification mr
chairman
seeing no hands raised uh the corporate
role if you are in favor of the motion
retained please say yay if you are
opposed please say name
vice chairman welch all right
representative burke
yes representative hopper yeah
no
representative wallace yes
representative testerman yes
representative true
yes
representative press yes
representative marston no
represent
the clerk vote yes
representative harry gathering yes yes
yes
representative boardnay
representative muse
yes
representative newman
representative conley yes
representative klein knight
yes
representative bradley
chairman abbas the chair votes yes
mr chairman the vote is 19 to 2.
by by a vote of 19 years in two days the
motion to retain has
passed there will be a subcommittee
appointed representative gabriel would
you be interested in chairing that
subcommittee
and uh representative colony would you
be interested in participating in that
[Music]
i'm just going to appoint representative
hawker and their
representative marston i would like to
you both are on together
thank you this time we will close the
and we are opening a public hearing on
house bill
316.
this film's being introduced by
representative kessler
what's that testimony you have to take
well i'm here to introduce bill 316. i'm
dave testerman i'm a representative from
uh merrimack ii that's franklin wards
one and two and the town of hill
this spring
i was asked if i wanted to uh
sign on to a bill i didn't think it was
a spy as a sponsor
and i said fine and that was about the
last i remember
the last couple days i've been reading
this
what this bill tries to do
and i can't support it any longer so i'm
going to remove my support from it i
don't know what that means as far as
what happens to it here in the committee
representative testament you as i recall
you did that last term as well
i killed it
you did you did it on your own bill last
[Laughter]
but we do have witnesses president to
testify in support of it
i
my difficulty with it is i couldn't
figure out how you can make it work
so
anyway
mr
chairman
again i've asked him to unmute
the chief
experience he's unmuted mr chairman i
don't know if he's having technical
issues on this side
i believe he is the only witness
sign would you testify so we'll just
give it another minute too
yes
so
head
and he is allowed to talk uh
yeah mr head
you are unmuted
great thank you um thank you mr chairman
thank you members of the committee my
name is richard head i'm the government
affairs coordinator for the judicial
branch
um you should have received a letter
from me last week i don't know if this
bill is going to go forward
in light of
representative testerman's testimony
we do ask it and this is actually an
issue with with bills generally
sometimes where it has an effective date
upon passage
um and
when bills like this are passed within
the judicial branch it requires a
substantial amount of of work on our end
if there are forms that get changed if
the uniform
charge table needs to be updated
any one bill doesn't take a substantial
amount of time but the cumulative total
of bills over the course of a session
creates a fair amount of work in terms
of creating the modifications within our
systems within the forms
educating police
law enforcement generally judges
and then also some of the technical
changes the electronic changes that are
needed
house i'm sorry rsa 14 colon 9-a
says that any changes to judicial
process actually should have an
effective date of january 1 2022
and you may see a similar testimony from
me throughout the session where we see a
bill that has a short
effective date
we just ask that this bill if it is
going to go forward be amended to
january 1 2022 as an effective date
we also just note without any position
on it that it does have some oddities in
terms of structure it creates a
misdemeanor in a document that is
essentially a form
and we have not seen where where a crime
is actually identified and described in
a statute that is a form and not a
criminal code provision
and it also does not have a definition
of good behavior but again not taking a
position on it those are just things
that we're noting
in terms of the bill i'm happy to take
any questions but
my primary purpose was just ask for it
that's true
thank you mr mr chair
thank you for thanking my question
well
i might have backed off at the last
second there but the title of the
analysis of the bill is
the dependent remain in good behavior
um
you tell me what
so do you know what that means
so it's
in the it's actually in the context of
this bill i do not
um it is not clear from the from the
bill as to what that means typically the
good behavior is is used
uh in the context of revoking something
so in in in fact the current form has it
that context in which the summons uh by
by receiving a summons you're
essentially receiving a benefit you're
don't having a warrant issued for your
arrest
and you have to remain of good behavior
um by sort of
and then you also see it in bail you
also see it in probation it's typically
defined in a bail or probation order as
to what that means
um as is just sort of what are the
requirements of good behavior
in this context
you know if you default to some case law
it talks about it has to be a statutory
violation
it becomes very unclear when you get
into like ordinances things like that is
a violation of an ordinance a violation
of good behavior but in this case it's
not sort of taking away the right to a
summons it's not taking away bail it's
not taking away probation but in this
case the addition is creating a crime
uh so then the question is you know is
is somebody who might commit this crime
on notice of what that crime actually
entails by not having a definition of
good behavior
oh
thank you thank you mr chair and thank
you for taking my follow-up question
i was pre-med not free law
but
is it is it basic is good behavior
basically say i'm expected to obey the
laws
because i'm a citizen all the time
it's good behavior saying
we're going to
at least you
fulfill your court date as long as you
and so in this case it's just saying
so at least in the current form yes
the short answer is in very very broad
terms i would generally agree with that
um but what becomes less clear is when
good behavior failure to remain of good
behavior is itself a crime
as would be as would be the case in this
bill
where then becomes
it's not it's not in that case in this
case defined where
normally in a in a criminal code those
types of phrases would get
defined
convert
thank you mr chairman and uh thank you
mr head for your testimony
uh
you stated that you wanted if we did
pass this um
you wanted the date changed to january
1st is that 20 22nd or 22
2022 correct so the the way the statute
reads um rsa14 colon9a
says that the effective date of bills
would be that modify court process
create new crimes which this one does
should become effective the january 1st
of the year after the session
thank you for taking that question mr
head
my question to you is simply this
if he goes out
and he creates another crime
that in itself is a violation probably
of his release is that not correct
well this is not a release this this
particular form is a summons for arrest
so this this form is is simply uh you're
you're being issued a summons of arrest
instead of having a warrant issued for
so this is this is the this is before
anybody has
gone through trial or been convicted or
pled to anything
oh thank you
i i
correct i misunderstood and i misstated
when i said that he was being released
my guess my question is
if he doesn't behave himself regardless
of whether we have a law or not and he
commits a crime if we just do the
process don't we
yeah that's
if i understand thank you for the
question if i understand you know if if
somebody
receives a summons they go up and commit
the crime that crime still has its own
penalty associated with it
and they can be fully charged for that
separate crime
and go through trial on that separately
that's correct
sir
mr chair my hand is up
well i'm sorry i didn't see it
thank you
uh thank you mr taking my question uh
could you just um educate me maybe on
the policy or the reference that you use
that
guides us on uh
that we ought to use january first uh
as uh an appropriate date
yeah absolutely so
um there's a statute um rsa 14 colon 9-a
and you should have you uh last friday i
sent a letter to the whole committee if
you've had a chance to to see it um
that statute says and i'll just read it
each law affecting judicial practice and
procedure
or establishing or eliminating criminal
prohibitions civil causes of actions or
remedies or limitations of actions shall
take effect on the january 1 following
passage
and in this case this particular bill
since it would affect judicial practice
and procedure
and create a crime being that being a
misdemeanor
the the bill or the i'm sorry the law
that governs effective date of bills
says that it would be effective it
should be effective on january 1 2022.
it's a fairly common thing we see it in
a large number of bills um
and
i'm just i try to identify it where i
see it
for the committee and ask for an
another question
yes follow-up question could you just
repeat the rsa number please absolutely
um rsa is 14
thank you
you're welcome thank you for the
question
chief shigori i figured out my technical
issues
uh she will be next up
we excuse the current witness on that
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee
um
to go a little surprised by some of the
things that attorney had said because
so 2019
594 594-14 someone's instead of arrest
was amended to add the language
to remain of good behavior
a warrant of arrest may issue so
it was already there about warrant but
it didn't say what the what the warrant
was for
what what what the offense would be so
so that language of good behavior
already existed in this statute
and it already said it was a misdemeanor
the next sentence is any person who
fails to appear in answer to such
summons shall be guilty of a misdemeanor
that language already existed to say
that a form doesn't say that is kind of
surprising because already existing in
the law
but to go to why that i asked for this
bill to be filed and i thank honorable
representative testerman for doing this
on my behalf because i i was the one who
asked for this
i'm on the interbranch
criminal and juvenile
justice council and i'll say this isn't
something this was a discussion i had
with judge king during one of those
meetings when he told me he's the head
of the circuit courts who handle most
misdemeanors which a summons can only be
issued for a violation or misdemeanor
in lieu of an arrest
um that it's a it's a misdemeanor if
they don't behave of good behavior and i
said
i said i don't see that i see a warrant
can be arrested i can be warrant for
rest can be issued for not being a good
behavior but i don't see where it's a
misdemeanor because there's a period in
there and
i said if that was the intent of
legislature
then they should have had
it added that to the second sentence in
that last little bit that has to be
part of the form
i mean this is a long-standing law uh
goes back to 1941 someone's instead of
an arrest
uh but this was a a change that came in
when this bill was discussed in 2019 i
approached through our lobbyists i said
we need to get that little bit clarified
as to what happens if they're not of
good behavior i mean we charged with a
warrant for what
it wasn't clear
um and it already says if you don't
appear which it appears in the first
sentence that lasts a little bit
and the second sentence says
uh so i'm sorry it says it said before
upon failure to appear a warrant for
resume issue any person who fails to
appear and answered shall be guilty of a
misdemeanor
it added or to remain a good behavior
warrant
may issue but it didn't say for what
what offense that would be
um and i didn't hear any discussion in
about there was no definition of good
behavior
um it wasn't an issue
apparently until now
i mean this this law has been in effect
over a year with good behavior added to
it
and
i just wanted clarification that
what exactly
we're charging this person with
because it says a warrant but it doesn't
say what for
it was a minor change i'd ask for it in
and from the discussion with judge king
that was the practice of the court or
the what he thought the practice of the
court should be anyways
thank you i think that you might needs
might know is unmuted so thank you
um
could you
do you think that a
change to the wording of the bill
as it's written
that references
the definition of good behavior
um as a crime in a in another rsa might
be sufficient to solve the problem of
this
well i think
two points it has to be added as i say
that it has to be added in there as to
what we're arrest what the warrant's
gonna be for and i don't have an
objection to adding a definition of good
behavior by case law when you look at
good behavior as regards to suspended
sentences or suspended or to revoke bail
it has to be a
crime a criminal act which is a
misdemeanor or higher offense or serious
motor vehicle offense as stated on the
bail forms and the suspended forms it's
not spelled out it wasn't spelled out
when this was put in effect in 2020
if that is what's needed i certainly
don't disagree with adding that
it would be
misdemeanor felony under state or
federal law
uh that's the basic that's what's on the
bail forms
and or serious motor vehicle offense is
what's on the bail forms but it requires
the idea i think behind passiveness
last year well make it effective last
year passed in 2019
was to make it so that
if that law enforcement more likely to
put people on a summons then take them
into custody
unfortunately and so they added good
behavior because that was a a concern is
that we didn't have anything if we
release somebody on a summons to say you
have to be of good behavior
but without and it says you would arrest
you can arrest them on a warrant but i
don't know what for because it's not in
the second sentence
that's why i added it but if the
definition of good behavior what's
intended that's certainly i believe
appropriate for the legislative body to
set what the legislative intent is
um
i i
the courts have have defined it and and
through case law as committing a
criminal offense
which would eliminate violations because
does that answer your question properly
further questions
i think one other thing point i'd like
to make is that
when i had this discussion with judge
king one of the points i made with him
was i'm not likely to use a summons
unless i know
because the intent was to give more
summonses out rather than arrest people
okay but i need to be assured they're
going to be a good behavior and that i
have
some teeth to the good behavior
that was the idea behind this is a
warrant but what do i charge them with
so so i said i'm unlikely to release
somebody to arrest somebody on a warrant
that i don't know is going to show up
and i don't have anything to do if
they're really not of good behavior
because i don't know what i'd charge
them with an offense
what an rsa is if somebody fails to
appear right now if i give them a
summons and they fail to appear
i can charge them with a misdemeanor
under 594.14.
it's right on the form i can do that
i think
you know good behavior
added definition great but i think it
needs to be in there that that's a
misdemeanor so i know what the arrest
warrant will be for
and just to clarify the legislative
intent when this was modified in 2019
and i understand the need to give some
time
i don't think this is a a huge ask for
changing law enforcement training
because it's not a big
good behavior is already in there
in a sense the the big change would be
in the forums getting new new summons is
printed up and changing the
there may be a minor change that's
needed to the uct the uniform charge
table i doubt it would be much though
because
594.14 should already be in there
for failing to appear so it shouldn't be
a huge
change for failing to uh
failing to abide by a summons shouldn't
be a a huge change because it's the same
sentence same rsa that should already be
in
an intro there
uh
interesting comment i know about it it
clarifies a lot for me
saying that thank you very much for your
testimony
thank you and thank you for
the challenging times you're meeting
under
i see no other witnesses
recess i guess until the chairman comes
back
and mr chair we had three people signing
in to support this bill we had three
people signing in in opposition and we
and
now all right
were you on mute before yes did you guys
hear my motion
all right uh just everyone forget the
last
ten one minute sorry about that
uh people the members at home were not
uh they were muted so we're just gonna
stop no no listen let me just start over
we have to start over because
please
uh
we opened the executive session on house
bill 525
and at that at that time we opened it
about maybe two minutes ago
representative burt was recognized for a
motion of any speed to legislate
then that motion was seconded by
representative walls
and at this point in time i recognized
representative popper to speak uh on
that topic
i while he was speaking i realized that
the members from home
were not non-reactive to anything and
we've now figured that out
so
does anyone have any objection to us
continuing with this process no point of
view
but i would like to talk at some point
you were recognized for reporting order
are you challenging a ruling of the
chair no i just have a point of order
after after a representative makes a
motion and it's seconded the motion
the person making the motion is usually
recognized to speak to his motion and
you did not give mr
representative burke that opportunity
i appreciate you pointing that out i uh
will most certainly recognize
representative if your hand was up and i
did not see it it wasn't off uh so my
that is my mistake but considering that
his hand was not up and i didn't know
i let him i recognized representative
hawker whose hand was up
and uh i'm sure representative burt was
upset by that he would have made a point
so i'm just going to let representative
hopper re-begin his point all right and
i'm sure representative burt will be
recognized thereafter thank you uh thank
you mr chair
okay so um
for the people
online
my point was that i think this bill
should be retained
i believe that there is an absolute
uh clear connection
between
uh people who abuse little kids
and pornography
and the abuse of pornography
and so therefore i think if we carefully
write this bill we write this bill
it seems like
we should be able to
write it so that when a person is
charged
and caught sexually abusing a child that
any electronic device that contains
information
within the scope of that person's
control
is subject to a warrant for
investigation i think in this particular
case i am willing to bet that they were
able to get that guy's
computer
i'm pretty sure there was probably a lot
of information
other information that might have led to
the arrest of people that are involved
in child pornography also
because it you know
the two behaviors go together
so i think we should be able to craft
this so the police could have more
easily obtained a warrant in the case
of the folks that were testifying this
morning
representative
please except my apology for recognizing
a different performance no need to
mr chairman committee members the reason
i
make the motion of itl and i just want
to make it uh for the record i've been
on criminal justice uh this is i believe
my
fourth term my record will show that i
support
anything that we can do to slow child
molesters down from abusing their
children
but the reason i'm
making the motion to itl this is
the original bill
was totally against the constitution
the second for the amendment
was added in
which
removed you know got away from the
constitutional issues
but it went back to current law that we
have now so we heard from the police
chief that they did request a warrant to
seize the computer
sadly um cac or s-ac i'm not sure what
it was called where the kids got
they can't draw out enough information
from those children
to
secure a war
now
what i feel on this is the system
fails those children
and
this bill is not going to fix that
um
what i feel on this particular bill why
i think we should itl it is because if
we are going to retake if we were going
to retain it let's just work on it over
the summer we don't need this bill we
can work on anything over the summer
bring a clean bill back because where
the issues are we go back to that dusty
old piece of paper called the
constitution
we need to make sure that the courts are
be okay with the language and that's
going to take some time
and um you know it's a huge hurdle to
work around that constitution which i
want it to be that way
but again we need to itl this particular
bill and just bring a clean bill back
next year thank you mr chairman
[Music]
representative rhodes
thank you mr chairman
and i don't think that i'm alone when i
say that everybody in the room is
is very sorry for the unfortunate
circumstance that happened with the
family and their child and
it's it's just absolutely disgusting
i don't think that this bill was the
solution to that problem and i think
that the
if it was the chief of police um that
testified basically even said that as
well that he
the circumstances that
that played out which is very very
unfortunate
and that
unfortunately their that family is the
one that you know felt that crap that is
not that's not normal and normally that
is what happens you would take
any of any of that evidence and um
i just don't think that this bill is
fixing any anything at all and everybody
representative true
thank you mr chair
i support the ipl for house bill 545
because um
remember with a show offense to the uh
sponsor
uh five
as it's written
as it's drafted
through nobody's fault
it's unconstitutional and i always vote
representative marston thank you mr
chairman
um
no disrespect was taken from
representative true
and i would only point out that the
office of legislative services
has attorneys and the attorneys draw out
our bills and they drew this up i didn't
go in and dictate
and i say you're correct he did up
i
and let me you know let me just clarify
uh representative marston you can do an
excellent service by your decisions and
i i think they should be thankful
that you this is a very serious issue
and you know working in the legal field
i know firsthand how difficult this
subject is when i'm defending someone or
representing the victim so you get a
great service body decision which and
they also brought awareness in a
situation where i think we all agree
the system failed that family
yeah and fairness to what we heard
before the committee
and i appreciated that everyone in this
committee had respect for that family
and didn't ask the detailed specific
questions we are talking about a minor
so we didn't get all the information
so i want to thank the members for for
that as well
uh as drafted in a
legislative whatever reason why they
draft this way we're not going to
require a search warrant for the police
to come into your house and
take electronic device i i think that's
and the fourth amendment is very clear
that they just that's just not permitted
there was an amendment at least to fix
the would have fixed the
constitutionality problem of it i know
we didn't adopt that amendment
uh it only could be offered on a
positive motion but just the fourth
amendment the right of the people to
secure in their persons houses papers
and effects against unreasonable search
and seizures
shall not be violated in no warrants
shall issues but upon probable cause
supported by oath or affirmation
and particularly describing the place to
be served and the persons of things to
be seized
under the fourth amendment going way
back to the fourth amendment
it sounds like the police
followed that process they applied for a
search warrant
i'm not saying that the warrant wasn't
written properly
but under any scenario i agree with
representative parker in its statistics
will show this that all likelihood a sex
offender who physically does their sex
defense on a minor before they even get
to that level they often start with
child pornography and i would not be
surprised at all if those devices had
child pornography on it and that's it's
horrible and i agree that i wish the
police found a way
to seize those devices and
look to see if this evidence because it
might not just be this particular victim
it could be others
but for whatever reason a judge did not
find probable thoughts
i would say even retaining
we were not rewriting the fourth
amendment
and and to me
this is just a very unfortunate
situation
but again we don't know what the
affidavit said we don't know what
much more than that but all we know is
that the court did not find probable
cause
and if if that device was seized without
the warrant
wouldn't matter what's on they would be
suppressed
so
it's not a force
it's an unfortunate situation that
happened
but then when we had laws on this last
term i often said i wish we could pass
some of these
i wouldn't we'll have to give an
exception just for this issue but
because the fourth amendment is written
so i couldn't if i could think of a way
to fix this i would i would be on board
with retaining it i don't
i can't figure it out so that's what i'm
thank you mr chairman
um
i appreciate the intent of where we're
trying to go with this
and um i would
say that we can resolve a lot of the
issues
with the intent that we were trying
to get at
would be with some of the other bills
that we heard
this is an extremely important issue
i don't think that
this this bill was
properly
prepared
i feel that it's not appropriate
and it does a disservice to the lawyers
that work with us to throw them under
the bus
and
that issue was already addressed by the
chair of the committee we don't need to
revisit them
in the in the representative we
withdrew his comment after and
we don't even discuss it any further
[Music]
i deserve to have a voice for my people
i was trying to knew you but i can't
until you have proven
but just we don't need to discuss it
want to say for the record please mr
chairman if if i can
that it's a completely
uh we have to hold ourselves accountable
to the duties of which we were elected
and voted into office for and it does a
certain disservice to our entire
committee
um because i
think we
already answered a warning on this
okay i'm done thank you thank you
[Music]
i don't think this this bill is
necessary but
and i'm wondering whether or not
um
police standards are are should be
corrected because if we're looking at
sex crimes
we probably should be looking at
electronic devices at the same time that
we are arresting them for molesting
children right because those two crimes
go together
um
i'm not sure why the sex crimes unit was
not involved in this case that we heard
so do we need a new
law or do we need to correct
police standards
representative gabriel
i don't know
a good question
[Applause]
representative courtney
but i think it was before
i think
representative burt mentioned can you
speak up representative gabriel
um
i believe the issue might have been even
before
um
i guess the judge
i think it happened
and because we we don't we're not privy
to anything that really happened there
i think that whoever interviewed the
children screwed up
so that has nothing to do with the law
here that we have because it's in place
but for a judge to say that probable
cause was not there something happened
before that
that made him say that
or her say that
so
um
therefore i will not be i will be
representative candelagas
thank you mr chair
it was stated when i asked a question
the computer was not taken was because
no one said that peaches were taken
and we have to stand by the constitution
and i don't think we could rewrite this
bill
i feel very bad but
i always heard in other cases that they
did have the
um
computers and whatnot to prove their
cases but evidently something went wrong
here
so it's it's not a list where we'll say
this will establish it's not like very
this fact will establish this one won't
it's really it's a legal standard you
know
more likely than not it's somewhat very
closely done we've heard that testimony
yes
i don't have the the exact you know
specific
phrase but it has to be you know after
articulating the facts
it's basically more likely it's very
so what you're saying is hypothetically
if someone would say is a known addict
and you search that person at any given
time
right
and if you see someone who's a known
drug addict
if you were to search that person at any
given time you can make an argument that
they're highly likely to have a
controlled substance on
this but i would argue that the mere
fact that a person's in your addict does
not give someone a police officer a
probable cause you get a warrant to
search them or just search them every
time so that's the problem that you have
even though there is a link between the
two and you may know it just having
knowing you're having a hunch is
generally not enough
it would have to be some fact that the
computer itself was involved in some
type of crime
and we're just basing on statistics so
unfortunately i don't think there will
be
a list
see see no hands raised i think the
battery put the question on the
corporate alcohol roll if you are in
favor of the motion of any speed
allegedly please say
vice chairman welch
aye
representative burke yes representative
hopper yes
representative green yes
representative wallace yes
representative testerman yes
representative true yes
representative pratt
yes
representative marston
with no disrespect to the committee i
will be the lone
nay
the clerk votes yes
representative harriet gathering yes
representative pantalakis
yes
representative
did we lose him is he there
representative boarding
he was yes
representative muse
yes
representative newman
representative bolden
yes
representative conley yes
representative klein knight
yes
representative bradley
chairman abbess
the chair of ogs mr chairman the vote is
20.
to 1.
by a vote of 20
days in
one day the motion of any speed to
legislate
passes
i'll move to consent representative
yes i would move to consent thank you
so when a bill has a fiscal note if it's
itl it does not require it's still going
to descend
i also did check on the other bill we
had
hb 945
it's our hb 270 that also is still
permitted to go to the same calendar i
did consult the card
on one of the bills i saw
um under 10 000 is that to cut off
for
the court said
my understanding is that a bill does not
require a fiscal note
if it is under
if the fiscal impact is
under 10 dollars so the issue when that
came up it involved like a piece of
paper and
really
small marginal cost so
that did not require this one
but that just means it can't go into
and it also means that the bill is
required
all right this time we can close the
executive session
on
house bill
545 would anyone like to write the
oh sorry 525 yep all right thank you
representative
at this time we are opening the public
hearing on house bill 200 increasing the
penalty for certain invasions of privacy
in addition at the same time we'll be
hearing
house bill 296 establishing crime
unsolicited disclosure of an intimate
image
we will be limiting testimony of the
members of the public
to one minute for these bills and i will
on exception for these the
representatives who either sponsored the
bill or are introducing the bill that's
like
is
clarify you are being recognized and
introduced house bill 296
yes
thank you
um i am representative allison nutting
wong i represent nashua's ward 5 and i'm
here to introduce hb 296
establishing the crime of unsolicited
disclosure of an intimate image uh this
is more commonly known as cyber flashing
uh this bill if we were to become law
would make the unsolicited select that
the unsolicited sending of genitalia via
electronic device a violation with
multiple offenses being a class a
misdemeanor punishable by a fine of up
to a thousand dollars
um the bill in front of you is the exact
language that came out of this committee
last year
i passed on the consent calendar but was
a victim of the pandemic
while it's not a pressing issue
um
it did seem
like a larger issue with the kovid 19
pandemic
this law would be part of the harassment
laws which is what cyber flashing is um
i have received these unsolicited
intimate images before and is incredibly
violating it's illegal to flash someone
in person and i believe it should be
illegal to do so digitally
um regardless for the reason of sending
these messages
the action of sending these images is
harassment with nearly no recourse for
the people who receive them
uh when i receive a message or an email
i expect to have a conversation not send
graphic images with no warning
these images are often sent without
prior contact purely to get a response
when i've received one the advice i'm
given is to block the sender
indecent exposure is a similar crime
with similar recourse that i'm asking in
this bill but cyber flashing can
be
uh
a fiber flasher can send many more
images at a time which is why i think
similar action and therefore similar
crime
um so thank you very much
representative martin i just have a
question i do not have a copy of 296 and
where do i go to get one here you can
represent uh representative bourdain
thank you mr chairman
thank you for taking my question
um
so you said that that
most likely this would happen
uh by phone
and usually
most these kind of uh crimes might be
sent these images may be sent to more
than one person at a time
would
if that is the case would that be one
i would assume
multiple crimes it would have to be
reported by the person who received them
um so i think that by that manner it
would be multiple crimes but i i guess
it's not listed in the bill itself
follow-up please
representative boarding you recognize
for a follow-up question
thank you um the reason i ask the
question is because um
under the vision there's a section
guilty of a violation for the first
offense and a misdemeanor for a second
are other offenses so uh
i guess it's a isn't really an important
question
so in the original bill last term um it
was going to be a misdemeanor every time
the committee changed it to a violation
for the first events
um at the recommendation i believe of
um but yes that would be something we
need to look at
we do
well for someone thank you
representative for testimony and if you
don't mind the chair will require a
question and just to clarify
i was opposed to that amendment last
term of making it a
just a
first offense that didn't work out so
well but i was going to ask you though
do you have
would you support an amendment that
changed the first offense to
stay either a misdemeanor or a class b
mission
yeah
thank you
representative marston thank you mr
chairman and thank you for taking our
questions i have a simple question
i uh
i'm curious if
this situation of unsolicited disclosure
of intimate images
would that constitute a probable cause
and be allowed to confiscate the
computer
that is a real relatively complicated
legal question but i will allow the
witness to answer if she wishes
um i'm not a lawyer and
don't work in criminal justice for the
most part so i would not be able to
representative
thank you mr chairman and um there's a
possibility i may have a follow-up but
the
first question is
i'm assuming this is going to be only in
state
um because it is rare but i get these
weird friend requests on
facebook um
and occasionally it is a woman that is
uh
dressed very loosely and
i'm not welcoming it so i delete it
instantly you know you know i don't have
a friend request and then one night and
from what i understand everybody gets
them how are we gonna
stop that
from
um i would agree that this is a much
better federal law than it is a state
law but i am only a state rep
um
i guess it would be
at the discretion of
i don't really know um i would say that
as the victim it would be where the
victim is but i'm
not the boss on this
in fairness
that was also a very complicated legal
question it was back to
so we we respect the representative for
hanging in if i could do a follow-up
representative
representative recognized for a
follow-up yes thank you and thank you
again for taking my question that was
you know i i just didn't know how to
even begin to answer that last question
what would happen if
if a
girl was sending a boy
some pictures that both of them enjoyed
and then all of a sudden they broke up
and the boy says hey stop sending me
pictures and she continued to do that
you know where does it become
consensual
so if it's unsolicited which i would say
is anything that wasn't specifically hey
can you send me this um that would make
it a crime
representative
thank you chair and thank you
representative for taking uh my question
i have a follow-up if i can after
um so
just for clarification there's currently
nothing in place that would allow people
of new hampshire to report
a crime like this and hold these
offenders accountable is that correct
um there is a law that applies um if
you're a minor if an adult is sending a
minor a
and my follow-up
night you're recognized for a follow-up
question
thank you
so if this were to be
law there would be some mechanism in
place for
reporting getting the data of how many
people harassed sexually harass others
uh yeah you would file a police report
and therefore the police would then have
representative
thank you mr chairman um
my question for you representative
i i've been flashed i was on elm street
and uh man walked by my friend and i
were sitting outside of a cafe
and a man walked by and um
you know i'm sure you can imagine what
uh what else happened and then he went
to the ben and jerry's down the street
again
and um it wasn't pleasant
and i i can
i agree
it makes 100 sense that if this is
happening
on the computer on the phone and text
message that it's going to produce
exactly the same experience the same
unwanted result in the recipient
um
so i was curious did you file this
legislation because you had an
experience that led you to
the realization that this legislation
was necessary or did you just observe
that there was
discontinuity between
the law
as it applies to in real life
interactions versus online interactions
because i know that
we wouldn't have legislation like this
30 years ago because of the advent of
the internet
this representative
before the witness answered that
question i i didn't need to wait for a
moment and i
that is a i i appreciate the question it
is a very personal question
so i i'll give the representative the
discretion to answer that or not but i
i think you understand what the point
um hello uh so it was part of my
testimony that i have received um a few
of these um as a state rep and then as a
private citizen before that
um so yes it was inspired by that i also
had uh seen it in the news that other
states in town um in like the city of
new york had also banned it
um so it would be
one of the first states we would be one
of the first states to do this um
thank you representative and the
chairman no disrespect by
you know cutting off that i just want to
make sure you confirm
you had i will say you've had some very
so
if i could just get clarification
i believe you would the chair was asking
you would support an amendment that
would make this
the first offense a misdemeanor
uh if said amendment was prepared would
would that be a would you support a
class b misdemeanor
i would support either
representative
yes mr chair and i'm not sure if the
sponsor also has the same recollection
but my recollection last year was
the amendment was made to change it to a
violation
because of concerns over some members of
the committee about
a
underage or teenage person
doing this because this is what stupid
teenagers do
um and possibly having that go on uh you
know their permanent criminal record
so i think that was part of the
rationale for changing it to a violation
and uh and having subsequent crimes be
misdemeanors but
uh i'm not 100 sure and maybe the
um while there was a work session on
this bill i had my own committee to be a
part of okay uh so i just remembered
that it was at the
um
at the advice of the aclu to make it a
violation
see no further questions i want to thank
at this time the chair is going to
recognize representative conley who are
you going to be i believe he's going to
be introducing
house bill
yes i am oh excuse me representative
jack right is rentals coming here
i
is introducing the house bill 200 on
[Music]
this bill is increasing the penalty for
a person is guilty of a class a
misdemeanor for first offense and a
class b felony for a second or
subsequent offense if such person
unlawfully and without the consent of
the person entitled to privacy therein
installs for uses
and i believe that the um the response
of this bill
was referring to like the bathroom and
hidden cameras and things of that nature
and um
that's about all i have let me see what
else
representative
thank you mr chairman
and thank you
representative
for taking my question excuse me i heard
from the stroke
as i understand this bill it's just a
completely up the
penalties involved in the situations of
all cases
that's what it looks like to me i
haven't personally spoken
right
but i believe that the intent was to
increase the criminal penalties for
these violations
see no hands raised i want to thank
representative exactly for assisting her
if there's any members of the public who
wish to testify that have not already
[Music]
friedman hopefully i announced that
correctly
audrey
can you hear me yes okay okay thanks uh
aubry friedman i live in bridgewater uh
private citizen just representing myself
mr chairman committee members
i totally oppose oh this is on hb 296.
i totally oppose this bill um and it was
as it was mentioned before the thing
with the
uh if a couple is uh intimate and
they're sending them and then something
changes it becomes a very hairy issue so
that's that's an issue right there but
the biggest thing is police are for it
to take care of murders assaults rapes
break-ins that's their job and we don't
need more laws on the books this if they
have another law for this unsolicited
images thing it just takes the police
away from what they're supposed to be
doing
the more important work
i mean this can be easily remedied you
get a
you know dirty image whatever on your
phone or your computer you just delete
it and block it i mean how simple can
this be why do you need another law get
the police involved the courts don't
they have enough to do let them work on
the real stuff
and let's not forget every new law then
you have a
enforcement and when you have
enforcement you have police
dealing with civilians and you know how
that works out sometimes somebody gets
uh you know abrasive and then there's
overreach and a simple little incident
can turn into like a deadly you know
like you know somebody gets stopped for
taillight not working and it becomes a
whole out of blown out of proportion and
somebody dies a shooting so
let the police do the work for the
important things this is a really
trivial issue that a person can fix it's
annoying it's
you know i agree it's tacky but you can
just block it do you really need another
life
thank you for your testimony
representative knight
thank you chair thanks for taking my
question
uh what's your current relationship to
are you speaking to me
yes sir oh i i'm just a private citizen
i don't like getting involved with
police and um
the less let them do their thing and i
think i got stopped once for as i've not
didn't do a signal or something like
that but i don't uh i don't mess with
police and
i i want to have
as little to do with them as possible
thank you and my follow-up
oh
apologies
um
you think that sexual harassment is an
inconvenience and not a serious crime
i think it's tacky and it's ugly and it
shouldn't be done
should it be involving the police no
absolutely not when you can fix this
yourself you can just block it what do
thank you representative
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question sir
um i guess i got the same concerns and i
didn't know if you you know could
elaborate a little bit more on it
because i was concerned also if you you
know have a girl sending the boy picture
and the boy sending the girl picture
back and then all of a sudden one of
them breaks up with them
um you know when does it become
you know against the law and and you
know when like you said they could just
delete it but um you know where do you
think that could lead to
it's a big mess i mean that's becomes a
he shed he said and she said type a
situation and they're both going to
argue from their point of view
uh maybe she just doesn't want to have
anything more to do with him and she
period but the actual bill says that he
knows that she doesn't want to she
didn't give consent so you know it's
quite messy
and to make a law on this and get the
police involved i just think is is just
uh will be an endless and not going to
get anybody anywhere to be honest
um it's that's a very messy area to get
into especially if it was a couple that
was intimate and they were sending
images back and forth everybody was
happy with it and then the relationship
turned sour and suddenly that very first
text after the souring point became
that's harassment and that is now
against the law uh how are you going to
find out exactly maybe he thought that
she was still
consenting to it but no in fact she no
longer wanted to be part of that so
it's hairy i wouldn't get the law
hands raised that witness is excused i
want to thank you for your testimony
all right well seeing no members of the
public will be handed raised for either
house bill house bill 296 or
house book 200
representative muse will you do the
honors
bill
i sure will um
for house bill 296 we had
uh
we had 41 people signing in in support
and one person uh signing in an
opposition
or house bill 200
we had 20 people signing in in support
thank you
thank you representative
news
at this time we will close the public
hearing on house bill 200 and house bill
yes
this time we are opening the executive
session house bill 316 requiring a
person issue of summons to remain on
good behavior
representative kessman would you like to
be recognized to make a motion
and now you want to make a motion lots
[Music]
i understand that and my understanding
is and i'm glad that we have to sponsor
him to uh correct me is that in lieu of
being arrested
that police officer can issue someone's
subject
so they're now released on the summons
and they're notified that they're gonna
have an arraignment on
so and so dates
in between the time that they have the
summons and the time that they have
their arraignment
this summons states they must be under
the age
that's what this will i guess my
question is what would happen if we
didn't pass this but someone was not on
good behavior in between that time here
so they would be arrested for the new
crimes that's what i believe and then my
other question is so the term good
behavior that's usually a condition of
your release
basically don't commit any further
offenses
but in here we're not having a judge to
separate the new conditions of the
release being done by a police officer
which
i'm not saying the police officer i'm
not
sure it's appropriate for the police
officers creating those conditions
that's some disrespectful please often
you may respond
may he respond without that point of
order
you're recognized for your point of
order thank you mr chairman
i spoke out of turn i thought he was
gonna itl he opposed
he presented it the opposite way and i
jumped in i'm gonna take back my second
you will be drawing your second yes i am
i withdraw my otp
okay
what's the flag in the football game
all right
represent so represent marx i'm not 100
clear you can withdraw your second at
this point but at the same time you
would with the representative
withdrawals actual motions
[Applause]
and is there i'm not sure we need a
second but for good practice is there a
second to that withdrawal
i would draw my you would like to second
okay
would anyone
would you like to recognize them for a
represented marston you wish to be
recognized
is there any any discussion to be had
anyone speak who hasn't spoken already
yet
seeing no hands raised the clerk will
call the roll
if you're in support of the motion of
any excuse to legislate
please say yes if you were opposed
representative burke
yes representative hopper
yes i think representative greene
if testimony does also yes
representative green are you yesing yes
representative wallace
yes
representative testerman yes
representative true yes
representative craft yes
representative marston yes
the clerk votes yes representative
harriet gathering yes
yes
representative o'hearn
representative gordon a
yes
representative muse
representative newman
yes
representative bowden yes
representative conley yes
representative klein knight
yes
representative bradley
chairman abbas
21 nothing
[Music]
13. five voted 21 years
chairman
yes i believe representative mastin owes
me an apology he is not my boss i'm
elected by the people
he's not to tell me what i can raise my
during orientation i said
that it's an honor to chair this
community having someone's experience of
representative welsh has to
work with me as a vice chair and then
now the dean of the house of this
community
and i i certainly respect the strikes in
the tenure of perhaps
representatives of video along with me i
did not hear any
i
it works in remark but i would just if
that comment was made i would find it
inappropriate
and not forget any member well
if you didn't hear it it's fine but i
just gave my opinion
if it was said that would be
inappropriate
and we've always been able to do that
representative
thank you mr chairman i don't recall
that i made any disparaging reliable and
if it was taken as such i would still
attend a apology to the representative
analogous
representative i do appreciate it
i do appreciate that
at this time i will i'll move with uh
316 if you put on consent
it's custom that someone make one but i
would like to show you guys
i will do
that thank you very much we'll now close
okay
[Music]
and open the executive possession of
house bill 307
i believe there was an amendment that
was
the members at home have the amendments
and just but please turn your videos on
representative
i see a
a prior amendment from which means we
okay i just want to make sure you guys
got that before we begin okay
representative do you wish to be
recognized
i recommend you to make an emotion
on the amendment or on the bill mr
chairman
but which one has to come first my the
tears understanding is if you think the
most about the past
any off you wish often yes okay i would
like to make a motion about to pass with
amendment
uh amendment
2021-04
[Music]
so right now we're only considering
when i get to representative welch's age
i'm right down to assignments
representative
representative burke you wish to speak
to the amendment yes i do uh thank you
mr chairman uh mr chairman
concerns on the actual bill
and
the amendment
thank you mr chair i guess mine would be
just a question for the chair
since i've been sitting on the uh
criminal justice committees this is i
guess the first time
congrats to an amendment that uh
usually when we're an executive the
amendment has to be sponsored by
a committee member uh and i see that
there's a representative's name before
representative burt's name which seems
kind of strange that it should only be
representative first name on it am i
incorrect or am i correct we had that
question came up last week last week or
a week before i did i did actually check
with the clerk
and represent well just told me lunch
my what i
what i understand is this in this after
consultation with the clerk is that
although it's a good practice to have a
member of the committee be sponsored the
amendment remember a member's name does
not have to be on the amendment but it
has to only be offered
by a member of the committee so if it
didn't have a member's name on it of the
criminal justice public safety committee
that is still acceptable provided
there's a member going
or sorry willing to offer these so
it's not it's not out of order for
representative bert to offer
representative muse
yes just some questions um it is a
rather lengthy amendment and it looks
like uh
essentially
a rerun of the entire bill
um there were several issues
more than several issues that were
raised during the public hearing on this
bill we had testimony that educational
institutions should be exempt from this
bill
we had issues
from the municipal association with the
whole idea of penalizing
municipal officials um doing their job
um we had a whole series of issues and
it would be helpful if uh if
representative burke could speak to the
differences
in the amen between the amendment uh and
the bill
so representative news what i can
explain is involving the issue of
uh
liability involving the individual board
members whether it's course collections
board members
i assume that the the amendment does fix
this
please fix that one issue
selectmen or a school board member or
uh any any public official will not be
being liable uh for any reason merely
the way they voted whether to support or
object to any type of
rule law regulation that's applicable at
the municipal level
so the amendment does resolve that
it's aware of where the changes
and then in regards to the issues of
school
and this is something that this was
actually in the first
of the original draft
and i believe it's
still being hearing the amendment it
what it what it does is that the schools
our school system is not allowed to make
any rule they would be preempted unless
explicitly authorized by statute
so when
that's the case
at the same level they can be an
authorization
expressly authorized for school to
make sense
under the current law that is irsa
193 colon 13
this school has the authority
at this time to
suspend or discipline a student if they
were to carry a
firearm on school property
uh while the school concession they
would actually
the superintendent or the designee would
have the authority to expel this when i
first read this bill the biggest concern
i had was
would this allow a student to
let's say open carry on school property
while the school's in session
that seems
to go too far and
it was discovered that there was a law
that law would protect that for me it
would happen
i would presume that most schools would
keep that
rule in place
here when you say schools are you
talking about universities like the
university of new hampshire
i'm reading uh
chapter this is under education chapter
i guess this is a question to
the chair
okay
um
i'm kind of struggling with this right
now because
this is
coming through a very four
four and some change pages
and i really would like to read this and
i understand that representative burke
sent it out last night but yeah
that
and maybe we can cover this on monday
this recommendation and we just had two
bills that we probably could just knock
out like if that's what you wanted to do
[Music]
i i understand the point i if i recall
last term we were given a 15 page bill
it was about
[Music]
but with looking through the amendment
if members want to take time that we're
still discussing it i would encourage
people to continue
reading through it and
if those are the major
issues been changed the majority of this
bill is
uh i reminds you the same language as
before
i mean you can take me through and show
me or tell me what was changed then line
by line yeah
i believe that the chair is required to
do that but i'm just explaining because
if you go line by line that's gonna take
without the opposition it would be
faster if someone actually
independently read it
okay
can you give this chance to leave
can i ask a question of representative
burt
yes
and i do it during the executive session
i do if i encourage the free club
discussion
representative byrd if i understand you
wrote the
i have no draft in this shift
follow it
yes
and somebody already somewhat stated or
asked
this almost totally replaces the bill
from all the concerns we took care of
all the concerns from the previous bill
that was in existence and basically
yes thank you
why not just rewrite the bill an
amendment is
it
it's concluded i'm i'm confused why not
just a build
and state stated
because how the legislative process
works is i wrote well i didn't write the
original bill uh representative silber
did
uh there was a lot of concerns and the
only way to fix house bill 307 is with
an amendment that's the only way we can
do it because we can't introduce a new
bill
and we don't want to wait till next year
so it's better to as
processed
many bills are amended and that's what
we
well i know when it comes to schools
you know the rsa
193-13
i'm trying to think you know find the
language i got here
it does still allow schools
you know any pupil who brings or possess
a firearm as defined in section you know
92 921
title 18 of the united states code
you know it allows the school boards
and the superintendent to
still
you know i have the
if you would like to look at this
representative
and probably the chairman but
last year
when we saw the red flag bill but we had
i don't know how many
replace all
kinds of changes
i specifically
representative sponsor coming in
and doing a replace all
the day of the final day of your
executive and that we just
it ended up just coming apart getting
tossed out and and i question
you know somebody
all it is is the same as we had before
and
but with a few changes
yeah and so i said well who told you
that well the sponsor told me yeah
and i said well i don't trust the
sponsor now i trust
for example i trust you but i don't
think it's unreasonable
to say let's take a look at this over
the weekend and we could go down it's
going to pass
don't worry about that
i think yeah
there was anything
you had to write answered you know
give me a chance i mean i
she even you know last year
representing said well i said it to you
at 5 30
well i recall that was 5 30 it was it
was the town election you know sent to
us on a town election executive
i actually took the time to read the 15
pages that were sent to me at night and
show up the next day to have an
amendment there after so that was
actually particularly frustrating
because i read 15 pages for nothing and
i at the time still my first year in my
first term i used to like to reference
the line for page numbers when you
change
three paragraphs all my notes would
completely help you out
so i can appreciate the frustration and
you know is coming back you know
that can be frustrating so second that's
cute
i understand we had a very
long day yesterday
a longer day on wednesday
so if i'm assured that the members
at least we know everyone has the
amendment right yes we got it
so that that solves that problem
no one did not have it
so
if you don't have the amendment you may
give me a thumbs up or something
well i'm sorry but i didn't get to do my
at nine o'clock
yeah what what we'll do is for the time
being rather than answer a bunch of
questions about the bill that would i
the feeling of the committee is
that people want to have more time to
read the amendment so why don't we
recess this executive session
you can save your questions about this
amendment until we'll get your time
thank you i'll make a hint
between nine
and four whatever whatever collie gets
here
slightly after nine
[Music]
maybe poster five
so we'll do that so what we'll do is uh
guys we have
remembers we have a lot of bills that we
need to exact we can answer ten
questions on this if they're above this
amount we can talk after but let's
exactly as much as we can
please
so thank you
307 is now in
before we open the next session
i'm going to give you a hint it's a hp
there is an amendment
on that
assuring that it's much shorter than
then
i'm not taking any questions at this
time i'm just simply asking if people i
asked a question and i didn't get a
response
i'm just simply trying to see if
everybody has the amendment they want to
interrupt well everyone's looking for
something
you know do we want to do
we're not any following hearing to make
a point of order there's no ruling that
and then you challenge the rule we had a
very appropriate challenge in the
appointment today where i
let someone else speak and
since we are nodding and hearing do uh
do i could i ask a question of the
chairman
the only my only question is and i would
i know what a point of order is i know
when
and i know how sensitive you are about
correct parliamentary language
my question is i did not hear
the the bill number and all i wanted was
a clarification so if i could have that
please that would be helpful in finding
the material because we don't have a
list of the bills to have that already
hp 471.
representatives yes mr chairman and all
due respect to you
we're not used to hearing a bill
and executing it so please be patient
with me i'm not anyway maybe the rest of
them are but i'm not
thank you representatives i
i
i appreciate the
no does everyone have a copy of the
amendment just a thumbs up thumbs down
yeah
represent new me
it should be
[Music]
i believe it's only adding one sentence
to the original bill
and i believe that representative wells
will speak on that amendment
but
it's all it's obviously the preference
mr chairman i have the copy
okay we're just going to tell you the
the the assistant sent the copies out
at this time
i am mr chairman i'm not trying to give
you a hard time but it's very hard to
hear about an amendment that you can't
get up and just walk to the table and
get like we used to be able to
i i agree and you're doing a good job
i think we're doing you know overall
we're doing our best uh and i think
we're
all getting better this time around but
this event is to be shorter that's the
let's open the executive center this
time we are opening the executive
session on house bill
relative to a police disciplinary
hearing
at this time
the chair is wrecking recognizing
and just just to clarify that that
you wish to speak on the amendment
yes during the hearing we had testimony
from retired law enforcement officer
who made the point
that
while this bill
opens the discipline of hearings up to
the public there are some things
that shouldn't be in the public for
instance
uh
the present language of the bill talks
about the ability for an involved paddy
presumably a police officer
to seek closure of a portion of the
hearing that would disclose confidential
perhaps of solicitous information
related or perhaps not related to the
allegations that we also support however
the bill suggests that the body might
approve the specificity
that the portion of the hearing will
reveal
confidential information that creates a
[Music]
so while the bill
says
the original bill
has the one sentence added to it
any discipline hearing shall be
published however
a portion of the hearing may be close to
the public only if the party seeking
closure
the specificity
that the portion of the hearing will
reveal confidential information that
creates a compelling interest
outweighing the public's presumed right
of access
the amendment
adds to that this sentence the council
made in a non-public session
hear and consider the request for
closure and rule on such requests
this
representative martin thank you mr
chairman
i have a question on the amendment in
the wording of who or what is the
council please stand as a training
representative
thank you mr chair
um
this amendment takes care of the
questions were raised during the hearing
it does
that was pretty much the language that
[Music]
i have nothing to say
for your expertise
um do you feel that
or do you have concern that this
language could essentially make the
entire hearing
be
somebody can make an argument to
essentially put much or all of a
disciplinary hearing behind closed doors
based on the language here as opposed to
a smaller part
cities and towns going behind closed
doors to make certain decisions that
they can cite that statue
[Music]
basically at any moment and i guess i'm
curious is this sufficiently narrow
i guess it would depend on
what the hearing is about uh
it could be any number of issues some of
which may
actually be entirely nonverbal
all kinds of what's being angered
[Music]
in representative calling i think that
the concern was this was legitimate that
if someone were to assert
confidentiality
that's one that's one step but if it
were to be challenged or that the board
did not agree that confidential
subject or
here it was involved confidential
information
in order to argue that one way or
another
would be rather difficult without
reaching the confidentiality so the idea
is to kind of to close that hearing the
hearing off to argue that point if it is
confidential then the board will also
make a decision whether the public
interests are wasted but
i would agree that there would be no
effective way to argue that point
without
filing competition for example
involving a confidential form
would be
not only problematic for the officer to
say that but disclosing that the
identity of the conventional performance
could put that person's
[Music]
if it's obvious that they're violating
we can always
open the area much more by
changing the law
i
i know why they want to do it i mean
it's not like the nashua school board
that's not nice in this case it's not
nice
justin
specific references
uh especially
we actually have two representatives uh
members of the committee that are from
nashua
uh we don't need to open that can of
worms but that does defend the school
district
and that is a school board hearing not a
police discipline okay so even the
analogy
just
you may continue uh that's fine i just
wait
if they decide to
you know get out of hand or right you
know they're being a little bit too
lenient with their closing of the
hearings
all right representative martin thank
you mr speaker mr chairman
uh just all of a sudden
welcome
uh
mike i have a question regarding
this is a disciplinary hearing
and i don't know if we asked it when the
discussed or brought up
are there a lot of disciplinary hearings
i got it
no not hundreds
i've had two law enforcement officers uh
be certified because of tesla that's
different that's that was certified
well that's a hearing yeah the
disciplinary area which resulted in them
being being certified
follow it you may follow i'm under the
impression that a disciplinary hearing
and a de-certifying hearing is two
different hearings
it could be
one would run
again follow what
you mean
so
what i'm trying to understand here
is
if there was just a a hearing every now
and then once in a great while
it should be open but if all of a sudden
the the police
that council as you called it
if they're hearing
disciplinary hearings constantly all the
time because the public at large finds
out oh we can just
make an accusation and it's going to
have to be a hearing and it's going to
have to be open and we can then they're
going to just
expand and expand and expand on it and
now they're doing hundreds of these
kinds of things wouldn't that be
delatorious
[Music]
they're gonna do hundreds they're gonna
yes
thank you mr chairman
i think the only reason
or one of the main reasons
for these hearings before that board
is to
really fire them
they can't work in the state of new
hampshire
other hearings are heard by their chiefs
and and
board of police commissioners so i think
i don't think we're going to hurt
representative
thank you mr chairman um
i'm not sure who wants to answer this
who is going to police
this
because i know
in my town
they hide behind
confidentiality all the time with
personnel matters they you know they'll
just say oh hey let's talk with just a
ninja about personnel monitor and then
the whole meeting is is
under wrap this just specifically limits
the portion of the meeting
that is
raises the issue called evangelion it
does say that so okay they can't simply
make the whole entire here like today if
we're gonna discuss some confidential
we couldn't make the whole day
that wouldn't have so so this if i may
mr chairman so this will
clarify that to them that that cannot
happen
yes it's very specific that someone has
to raise the issue of competition it's
almost like his parallel raving of
raising a privilege to make a quarrel
you can challenge the privilege
and say i i don't know i don't agree
that that's the privilege
it can then be ruled on if it's if the
board rules that it is
it's privilege and confidentiality
different important rules that way it
agrees that it's
even if they find it as confidential
they still have to make the
determination that
you know not disclosing the
confidentiality outweighs the public
interest so even if it is confidential
if it's possible it could still be
disclosed
but they but the argument for that is
going to become okay thank you for
clarifying
represent true
thank you mr
chair
uh just
maybe clarification
from the chair
a couple of people
i believe have made reference to other
meetings
representative welch made reference to a
particular
counselor but this only deals with the
police whatever
representative wells calls it it doesn't
refer to meetings by towns
no it does not
doesn't even affect a meeting by tax
if mr
perhaps if somebody could say the name
of the council again
the fleet standards and training council
and by the way the ag has a position on
i think there's two members of the
republicans
yeah this is the actual testimony that
we got from the
uh
that the new hampshire police chiefs are
in support of public hearings on matters
involving police conduct and allegations
of misconduct are abusive
but it did
it was
the council me
[Music]
representative marston thank you mr
chairman
i'm now starting to recall our hearing
on this
and
i remember asking a question because we
have a young lady that wanted to testify
and she did
but what i'm getting at is
this is taking the policemen in my mind
and hanging them out
to dry if you will the phrase that's
been said many times and different
things
[Music]
because we're going to have a public
hearing whereas
i think if you're going to discipline
one of your offices that should be done
behind closed doors
it's not something that should be
splashed across the newspapers and the
radio stations and embarrassed the
officer
he's going to be disciplined and i don't
have a problem with that but making it a
public hearing
i find it a little intrusive and i like
to protect my policeman because i don't
want that guy
afterwards
going off half car or maybe even
resigning and we need as many policemen
as we can get with that being said
representative marston
although i i appreciate the comments i
think
what the remember votes yay or
nay on the amendment i don't i think
this is not something that's meant to
harm police officers
exactly
i respect police officers they have a
very the public service they provide is
it's an essential part of our society
and
i'll tell you what
they they are underappreciated and you
know and that goes for a lot of first
responders
uh there is also a public interest on on
the right to know
so when these in these things
these happen
here there is a public interest to know
what
you know the circumstance relate to that
that ins especially
if it can involve
uh exculpatory evidence which is you
know mandatory disposed in some
circumstances there's a circumstance
where the public has a strong interest
to
have the information on
on what
circumstance in surrounding hearings i
don't think that that's necessarily
going against or putting our police
office in halfway and that's why the
confidentiality provisions
uh
a lot of us members felt it's important
to address that concern before
this amendment does trust that that was
i believe the biggest
primary concern that the
um was the police association
i think that was the primary concern
that they had
was the issue of confidentiality how
um thank you chair thank you colleagues
i'm gonna be voting on to pass because
the prime sponsor
i respect
and um
admire
the experience that he brings to the
table at
by being he's he used to be a police
officers
if correct me if i'm wrong
and i think we're in a very tumultuous
time
and part of our responsibility
is to mend the relationships between our
communities and our police officers
and this gives us a choice to start
doing that because people
want to know that
the police are being held accountable
and there's no transparency that of of
that right now um
so
with that i think this protects the
police officers and highlights
um you know separates
a potential bad one from
naming all of them bad and
damaging the trust of communities i
think this is a a much needed bill that
can repair
our relationships with the police thank
you
representative rose
thank you mr chairman i
i agree with representative klein knight
i think that
if you're going into a hearing it isn't
because you didn't do anything wrong
and i think that
it's unfortunate but i also think that
their perception is that
a lot of times officers feel like
they're above the law
that's not necessarily my opinion that's
just what i hear to be the opinion of
i think this is a good thing
actually and you you're still going to
protect me if there's a
victim specifically that doesn't want
their name to be said or you know that
that's all going to be kept secret as
well you're not bringing that person
into the light you're just bringing the
charges
yes i just wanted to clarify that
i wouldn't want to hurt any police
officers either but i was told that it
was when they went before
the police standing and training
for disciplinary and that has to be very
bad to be sent up there so i believe in
representative jaffrey what i just want
to say that
the only thing that changed in this
amendment is the very last sentence
which is a good thing
well i i told i probably should be much
all right seeing a note known for the
hands raised uh the matter where we put
the question the corporate poll involved
this is the question to be considered
is whether to adopt amendment number
[Music]
you heard it
if you were in support of adopting the
amendment
please say yay if you were opposed
vice chairman welch
hi
representative burke yes
representative hawker yes ma'am
representative green yes
representative testerman yes
represent
that's somebody i know i'm going on i'm
sorry yes
[Music]
representative wallace
yes
representative testerman representative
true representative pratt yes
representative marston yes
the clerk votes yes representative
representative harriet gathering yes
representative pantalakis
yes
is he don't was he here at the beginning
representative muse
yes
representative newman
representative bowden
yes
representative conley yes
representative klein knight
yes
representative bradley
chairman
the chair votes yes
amendment
two zero two one gas
zero three eight
six h is adopted
representative welsh do you wish to be
recognized to make a motion about the
past amendment all right i move how to
seconded that
that motion
seeing your hands raised on the clerk
what i'll call the role of you in
support of
the motion about the past as amended
please say if you're opposed please say
nay
vice chairman welch yes representative
burke yes representative hawker yes
representative greene yes
representative wallace yes
representative testerman yes
representative true yay representative
pratt yes
representative marston i haven't been
shown the errors of my ways i vote yes
the clerk votes yes
[Music]
representative harriet gathering yes
[Applause]
yes
representative muse yes
representative newman
yes
representative golden
representative conley yes
representative klein knight
yes
representative bradley
chairman abbas
the chair votes yes
house bill
and we will be in recess uh for just
five minutes we will be doing more
executive sessions
cacra which is still in committee
that we really
is that there's gonna be a
reconsideration on that one and we're
not gonna do 307. i'm not sure the order
but we're going to be in recess
now let's put a specific time we need
recess to 405 amps can you find out if
everybody got the ca
just
we are now in recess until 405 pm
because members at home please give a
thumbs up or thumbs down if they have
if you don't have
yeah
[Music]
question of the chair
here
would you just repeat the numbers of the
of the bills that you're going to do i
didn't have a chance to copy them down
we have hp 200 which was today
uh hb 296 and cacr8 i'm not guaranteeing
it in order but we just have the
hearings on 200 and 296.
thank you very much mr chairman that
information is very helpful
and i hope you have the amendments
to cac i've seen that one somewhere so
i'm gonna go get it
if anybody is in the room that is doing
a minority or a majority report i would
just ask that you make yourself a little
note when i go home i don't take this
paperwork with me
and people you know
the room is not muted
they email everything to
voted on
cacr8
john they're on recess
you can answer the question that is
correct it's going to go for
reconsideration recommended that's
correct
committed or reconsideration yeah
reconsider it
we're going to do something with it
that's for sure
david you're not muted either if you're
interested
oh thank you i'm not not saying much so
that's okay it's all being recorded
though
i have not looked
um
your emotion would be ipl i know
that's why that was the joke right he
[Music]
you we are live you're alive
and translated
[Music]
all right
thank
you at this time we are opening or
reopening the executive session
here recognizing representative burke
taking motion
let's see uh
you're asking today consider reconsider
i apologize
for being considerate
i would like to make a motion to
reconsider uh reconsider cahcr8
representative would be recognized
i consider uh reopening this uh
amendment is uh a waste of time
and if you want to bring up a new
amendment on the floor i think that
would be
a better uh
[Music]
use of time for both our committee and
the house
thank you
the bill is still in the committee so we
wouldn't we would we're permitted to
reconsider it
with the bill still in the committee
uh if it was out of committee it would
be there to be a floor amendment or
recommend
but
[Music]
if you don't support the amendment
that's that's the different conversation
i see no hand raise uh spark will call
the roll if you're in support of the
motion of reconsideration please
if say
representative burke yes representative
hopper yes
representative dream yes
representative wallace yes
representative true yes
representative pratt yes
representative marston yay
the clerk votes yes
representative harriet gathering no
representative pantalakis
no
representative o'hara
representative gordon a
no
representative muse
representative newman
no
representative bolden
representative planley oh
representative klein knight
no
representative bradley
chairman abbas
chief otf
by a vote of 11
days and nine days
of reconsideration
cacry has been allowed
you're not recognized as representative
to make a motion
thank you mr chairman i would like to
make a motion of pot to pass
21 0
1 6 8
thank you representative is there a
second
[Music]
yes i would mr chairman and thank you
for
bringing this you know
the amendment is very easy we cleaned it
up
it basically says that
the new hampshire
constitution
and not allow
our law enforcement to
enforce any federal
uh gun
amendment
2021-0-5
vice chairman welch
hi
representative bert
yes
representative popper yes representative
green yes
representative wallace
yes
representative testerman yes
representative true yeah
representative pratt yes
representative marston yay
the clerk votes yes
representative harry gabriel no
oh
representative o'hearn
representative ordnae
no
representative news
newman
no
representative bolden
representative conley no
representative klein knight
no
representative bradley
chairman abbott
chair votes yes
mr chairman the vote is 11 to 9.
i go to the eleven years nine nays the
amendment is adopted
representative he making a motion to
pass
yes i am uh mr chairman i'd like to make
a motion um cacr8 ought to pass as
amended
representative wallace thank you mr
chairman i have second that motion pass
mr chairman if i could um the motion to
reconsider was representative burke but
i was not able to get through
the damage
[Music]
can i make a motion to reconsider a bill
so that's the question of the chair
uh at this time there is a motion
already made it's not props to make a
motion uh it's not in order to make an
then you would have to be recognized to
make emotions
[Music]
thank you mr chair i would just like to
say that there is
nothing in the amended version of this
bill that makes it any better public
policy now than it was a week ago
[Music]
about the past as amended please say yay
chairman welch
hi
representative
yes
representative copper yes
representative greene yes
representative wallace yes
representative pesterman yes
representative true yay
representative pratt yes
the clark votes yes
representative harry gabriel
no
representative o'hare
representative gordon a
no
representative muse
no representative newman
no
representative conley no
representative klein knight no
representative bradley
no
chairman abbott
the chair votes yes
[Music]
normally appropriate while in the voting
mode
i suppose this this
regarding whether someone's camera's on
or off
it's not on or if it's online while
they're voting
i'm assuming it's not incidental just
please point out your chair
i would not find pointing that out out
would there be any uh
jewelry reports yes
representative
yes mr chair i believe you have a
minority report already on this
particular bill
we can discuss that at different times
thank you
we now close the public hearing by the
executive sessions
cr8
at this time
we open the executive session the house
bill
200 increasing the penalty for certain
i don't have anyone recognized to make a
motion so someone that would like to
speak
okay
yes representative yeah yes on the
and if i may speak for that motion
you are recognized to speak on the
motion of the police thank you uh
representative vincent is uh
he lives in somerset's district
part of dover i know him well
um
is it they've been disposed this week i
know he would have liked to have been
here to explain more about what his bill
was about she had approached me to
co-sponsor this bill a while back
and it really was intended to put more
strength and more behind sort of
egregious invasions of privacy involving
um exactly where it sounds like cameras
placed in places
um i would have liked to have known more
about this
uh i did not have that opportunity
um
i think igl best course
thank you i i will i will say that
and i had to say he's on here this bill
is going to be straightforward it
involves
uh
really
disposing intimate images that were one
they did
the image was our video was captured
without the person's consent
and then it was publicized it does
create a
exception if you have a wildlife camera
on i suppose that's outside and if a
person's neuter engaging in the sexual
life outside
is not really as much of an expectation
privacy
as much as it would be inside your home
or decent side of the building
but
what happens is that people
nowadays are there's cameras everywhere
and people make recordings i mean people
take screenshots
there's a lot of inappropriate things
that can be done with a camera without
someone's knowledge or consent
and if that were to be done and then it
was to be shared
i will say that just
once it's out there in cyberspace it's
probably never going away i mean i hate
to don't naming any names when it
happens to celebrities unfortunately
more than
you know that's when it gets a lot of
news but once it's out there it's out
there forever it's not going away
uh it's a permanent person we're 20
years old when it happens and when
they're 50 that new photo will still be
up
so what this will do
what this will do is sim
represent
you're on the phone while we're in
what this would do is
simply this would increase the penalty
uh i think for the
right now the first it's a it's a
misdemeanor but what would happen for a
subsequent offense it would be a classy
film
as wrong as this act is the first time i
think it's worse to do
that's just
that's just my my thought
but
[Music]
yeah i mean so i i respect that um
and
you may have brought me along i mean i
would have liked to learn more about it
the concept is
um
your description
i think
clear some things out um
so
it seems like you're gonna take the
effort and if the will of the committee
uh
make another motion i'm happy to pull my
back and to try another approach
we've had several motions withdrawn in
this committee you're free to
withdraw your emotion uh mr chairman i'd
to make it consistent
with would there be a second to allow
representative colony to withdraw that
motion
yes i have a problem when we try to
increase penalties i really do
so that was my problem that i had with
this but unfortunately i wasn't able to
talk to the prime sponsor
so i cannot vote for this in good faith
with penalties increasing
so what we need to do is right now just
i appreciate the
the comment there's been a motion now
about the past
the question now is will some of the
[Music]
when enhancing penalties is a concern
and i understand that there's different
movements enhance some penalties or
reduce others
what i
i understand we all have different
opinions
this really enhances the second offense
more than the first so the first offense
will not be
uh it let me correct that roman numeral
three
uh at the very bottom the person is
guilty of a class a misdemeanor the
first offense and a class b selling for
the second assumption offense
the way that is written just says when
it says just misdemeanor they haven't
this is just maybe a learning point too
and i was taught this by the chairman
if you ever read an rsa and it just says
misdemeanor
that means it's like an older law what
that does is that the
the prosecutor or the district attorney
has the discretion then charge that as
an aorta
most laws written now
today
will specify a or b what they wish
so
in the differences with the class b
misdemeanor there's no uh
there's no chance of any jail time
so when you look at
roman numeral three whereas a person is
guilty of a
now specialized class a missing from
breast offense before that was within
the discretion of the prospect
by the excuse the district return
to
of how to charge them
that this will eliminate that
and then
it's then a class b for the second or
subsequent offense it doesn't keep
elevating them eventually
a felony
so
when i say that it doesn't enhance any
penalties for the first offense that's
not entirely accurate
but it wouldn't eliminate that
discretion
my understanding is a lot of these
things are
registered or occurred you only charge
the class a
just
that's just from what i eat what i hear
in the community
so
yes thank you um
this is actually a bill that we heard
last year it was uh hb uh 1175
and uh we passed it in committee 19 to
nothing after we decided to amend it
and last year
our debate mostly focused on the fact
that originally what the bill did was it
made even the first offense a class b
penalty
and so i have a note that representative
welch had submitted an amendment
that reduced that to a misdemeanor
so that is
sort of where we are and just kind of
looking through the bill um it seems to
be
what we passed last year uh 19 to
nothing
one of the issues that we have sometimes
when you have bills that kind of go over
multiple sessions is um you know you
have notes and longer memories of the
the testimony and
one of the things that stuck with me in
the testimony for 1175 last year was
that we had a
a sitting state representative who came
and testified
in a really
kind of a heart-rending way
and described how this had happened to
her
and she had been in a situation you know
where time after time after time
somebody that that she trusted
used a hidden camera to take pictures of
her uh video of her that he put out on
the internet
um
and uh to sit there and listen to that
story was just heartbreaking and i know
we didn't hear that testimony uh this
year and
we hear so many bills and sometimes a
testimony in individual bills can be
really hard to
to remember but this particular one did
stick with me
um and uh
this is another one of the bills that
sort of disappeared into the cobit haze
last year
it would be really nice to sort of pick
[Music]
representative trump
thank you mr chair
uh probably a question of the chair i'm
just trying to figure out
what a felony charge is and this myth so
i think if i'm reading it correctly
a misdemeanor
could be pled down or he didn't just
charge you with a violation like
having a tail light out
but a class b
is up to seven years in jail four
thousand dollars fine yeah and five
years probation let me clarify this so
a class b misdemeanor
there is
a woman
a misdemeanor
can go down to they can charge you the
state could charge you with a violation
it's essentially a cloud it's not
exactly the same as a violation but
because it's still a criminal offense
the class being misdemeanor but the only
penalty is is a fun
there's no you can be on probation as
well but you can't
there's really no chance of
just trying to figure out what the class
would be is
class b is when you're sent to jail five
to seven years
last week when you go to state proof
yes
and that would be the second
what's my understanding if
and i will i will say that if a person
does this once it is inherently wrong we
talk about as intimate of an act as it
will be
to secretly record that person without
their consent
and then to distribute that
and that
in a domestic violence context
uh often these video these images are
often used as blackmail or enhanced
abuse they use it to
as a form of abuse meaning they will
firmly disclose or publish it in
i need to get into the details do you
happening a second time i i can't
imagine now we're dealing with uh
it's more of a pattern
i actually would really appreciate to
see this law passed
for a lot of
people's protection i've seen
some mentally ill people
being photographed and taken advantage
of in manchester
and
this their images were disseminated
by a public official
on um
social media pages
where everybody like i said shamed this
person that was unbeknownst to them
um
and it was that's it that's that's there
forever
so
i would really appreciate this being
thank you
uh seeing no hands raped uh the clerk
are not called a role if you were in
favor of the motion of bought the past
yay
thanks chairman welch i'm gonna like
this
oh hey
we're still friends
[Music]
um i'd like to follow representative
welch
no
representative hopper yes
[Music]
representative green
no
representative wallace
yes
representative testerman yes
representative marston
no
[Music]
the clerk votes yes
yes
representative pandalakis yes
representative o'hearn
representative board nay
yes
representative muse
maybe
yes yes
yes
representative conley yes
representative
yes
representative bradley
the chair votes yes
mr chairman the vote is 15 to 5.
if i go to 15
years and five
nays of the motion of the past passes
no
well
representative colleen will be writing a
[Music]
guys at this time we can open the uh
executive session on house excuse me
okay before you close i may be a
minority reporter
all right can you let the chair know
fight
10 damn tonight i can let the chair know
before we leave today
thank you everyone true this time we
will close
the time we
open the executive session on house bill
and for a long time we've been trying to
enough for discussion representatives
um i wasn't in here i think when um
when um prime spencer
monster testified but um
i remember this bill from last year we
did have it
i don't remember what the vote was
i'm sure someone on the team might
remember
but um it's a great concern with
what happens electronically now with um
cameras with it's sort of like
the bill that we just
passed
they're
very close in nature
about unwanted or
unsolicited
so
with that said
the other thing that i liked about this
because i remember i think it was last
year
originally the penalties came out they
were really strong penalties
and
i want to say it was david or either me
that talked to um
the violations
and um so this one started because we
worried about young people and
everything at the same time
last time we talked a little bit about
you know how silly they can be
and um so um the prom sponsor as she
said she had agreed that the first
offense
would be
a misdemeanor
and um for a second or subsequent
offenses
a violation
i think you were trying to make it
heavier
i uh
that is a correct statement that the
last term uh as a representative i
fought very hard to
i think i did a good job i didn't do a
good job that did not happen
i'm speaking to members of the of this
committee i despite being the cheer i
still don't think i have the support for
that so i am the odd man out of that
but at the same time just because i it's
not
perfectly drafted the way i wanted still
creating a good policy
and i
even i wouldn't like them amendment
better
representative
thank you mr chairman i just wanted to
share that the docket for the 2020 bill
um shows that the this committee passed
the bill 20-0 and it was on
um
it was on consent i think
as well
representative
i was going to say that representative
harriet gathright has a has a really
good memory um the one additional thing
that we did in this in the subcommittee
last year
was um the aclu during the public
hearing it had an objection that the
original bill
didn't have a requirement that the
recipient actually be harassed annoyed
or alarmed by that electronic
transmission so one of the things that
we did in the subcommittee was we
we uh we we made that change along with
the change to the to the penalty
um and
that's what we passed 20 to nothing last
year
representative
thank you mr chair relying on everyone's
memory or
chair's memory
who
and he had consent well how does
so
i i can answer that
that's one of it doesn't be very fact
specific
but
keep in mind that the state has the
burden of proof you know the reason
without
if if you are in an intimate
relationship with someone and have been
for some time and there's been foes
exchanged three or four months back the
biggest concern was people the
relationship went sour
and then all of a sudden they bought
woodwork all these all of this
this
there is
data on when that photo was originally
created when it was sent
if you're if there's evidence that the
phone was said well but people were in a
relationship
it is going to be much more difficult to
prove this if the parties are going
through a divorce or if they separated
the restraining orders involved
or in situations where the person
doesn't even know the other person or
they barely know each other
i you would be able to prove but that
would be evidence of saying dog said
also if there's an exchange of back and
forth of
i don't want to get into the details but
sometimes they can be
messages or comments that you know
go into it so there's a lot of ways to
prove it but ultimately
but if there's nothing to show
it was just unsolicited at all it would
just be great
really
so
represent holden um you race vocal once
if you've already spoken
the chair is not going to recognize
just
all the members
[Music]
seeing no hands raised remember i've not
already spoken
uh the material for the question the
clerk would call the roll
if you are in favor of the
motion about the past please say yay if
vice chairman
welch hi
representative burke
representative hopper yes
representative greene yes
representative wallace yes
representative testerman yes
representative true gary
representative pratt yes
representative marston
no
the clerk votes yes
representative harry gathering yes
representative cantalakis
yes
representative o'hearn
representative gordon a
yes
representative muse yes
representative newman
yes
representative bolden
[Music]
yes
representative conley
yes representative klein knight
yes
chairman abbott
[Music]
is
oh
yes
[Music]
um sure
can we now close the executive session
on
house bill 296
[Music]
is
next monday wednesday but the following
wednesdays the 10th
the bills we have right now have a
deadline of the 11th
so
those reports need to be done
right away if you
and then any amendments you're going to
want for the bills that haven't been
left i'm not sure we're going to have
another meeting other than next monday
next wednesday and then
so monday the 1st
march 3rd
and then i believe
march 10.
i'm not sure we're gonna have another
meeting so if you have an amendment for
the love of god and please bring him
you gotta be proactive with that and
then otherwise it's gonna not it's not
so on the third
and
representative ordnay
i have in my notes which is not always
accurate that hp 125
you were making a
you were going to prepare the
i
don't remember i think that maybe i
either i did it or i sent it to uh
nicole to do
if you have uh can you if members can't
say just he says more than one
if you haven't done it already
uh
please do so if if you
don't if you've done it already and
forward to me i've clearly
lost that email
if you don't mind pointing myself into
i have written check
sorry john there is a uh representative
ordinate
miscommunication on my end i
liked yours
okay can if someone could forward that
to me
into the committee assistant
that would that would be helpful
uh representative wallace i have you
down as um
octopass is amended from khp 180.
okay
the majority report for
sorry
when was uh did we do that today no
i think that involved uh snowmobiles and
oh i think i sent that in
i'll resend it just resend it i'm not
that i hadn't sent 338 so long all right
then i think you have it now yep i'll
double check but if you're not checking
if you don't mind just reach into the i
was the one if i'm not making sense just
really just like yesterday because i
think i came
when i got home last night i was born
through hundreds of emails
[Music]
the criminal justice public safety
payment will now be in recess everyone
please enjoy your weekends